ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA. OUR QUE HAN BERMAN.
HELLO BLOOM. BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA BRO BURKE CALDERON
CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU JUNE
DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
DALY DEEP EGGMAN FLORA FONG
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GLORIA
GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER KILEY LACKEY LEVINE
LIMON LOW. MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK WORK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS LOOSE REBAJAS
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH STONE TING
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
THAT OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN
THE GALLERY. PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER WILL
BE OFFERED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TIM GRAYSON DISTRICTS. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN YOUR THOUGHTS AND
PRAYERS. LORD WE STAND IN THIS
CHAMBER TODAY WITH THE WEIGHT
OF ESPONSIBILITY UPON OUR
SHOULDERS TO SERVE AS
TRUSTWORTHY STEWARDS OF THE
PEOPLE'S RESOURCES. WE GIVE
THANKS FOR THE WISDOM JUDGMENT
AND GOOD COMMON SENSE TO
FORECAST IN SOME CASES PLAN FOR
MANY IN OTHER CASES AND ENTER
IN ALL SITUATIONS SUCH AS
DROUGHTS FAMINES. OTHER NATURAL
DISASTERS CONFLICTS AND EVEN
PANDEMICS. AND MAY WE NEVER
ATTEMPT TO STAND WITHOUT THE
THOUGHT OF LEANING UP ON YOU
FOR OUR PROVISION AND CARE. AS
WE HAVE LEARNED FROM NATURE
INVESTING A KERNEL OF CORN INTO
THE GROUND WILL LEAD TO A
RETURN OF OVER EIGHT HUNDRED
KERNELS. SO LET US WISELY
INVEST IN THAT WHICH LEAD TO
RETURNS THEY CAN BE COUNTED HIS
BLESSINGS FOR ALL OF
CALIFORNIANS. THERE ARE NEEDS
FOR THE HOMELESS AND THE HUNGRY
THERE NEEDS FOR HEALTH SERVICES
OUR CHILDREN DESERVE QUALITY
EDUCATION AND ALL WHO WORK
WORTHY OF THEIR HIGHER. WELL SO
MANY OF THE FOR THE VERY BASICS
OF LIFE WELL GOVERNMENT STRIVE
TO PROVIDE FOR MUCH NEEDED
SERVICES AND WHILE WE AS
LEGISLATORS. ENDEAVOR TO MAKE
THE RIGHT DECISION. GIVE US
WISDOM AND KNOWLEDGE AS- TO
ASSURE THE UNDER. RIDE MIGHT BE
SERVED THE STRUGGLING ARE
AFFORDED RELIEF. AND FUTURE
GENERATIONS ARE PROVIDED THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE HAVE BEEN
AFFORDED AND MORE. LAY UPON
THOSE WHO HAVE TO GRACIOUSLY
MAKE WAY FOR PROVISION FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE NOT. HOPELESS TO
KNOW THROUGH TRUTH THAT IF WE
RIGHTEOUSLY GIVE IT WILL COME
BACK PRESSED DOWN SHAKEN
TOGETHER AND RUNNING OVER.
REBUKE THAT WHICH DEVOURS AND
MULTIPLY WHAT WE HAVE TO MEET
THE NEEDS THAT PRESS OUR
COMMUNITIES ON EVERY SIDE. JUST
AS THE STORY OF THE MIRACLE
WE'RE OVER FIVE THOUSAND WERE
FED WITH FIVE LOAVES INTO
FISHES. WE HAVE FOUND OURSELVES
FACING A SIMILAR DILEMMA WHERE
THE NEED IS FAR GREATER THAN
THE RESOURCES ALL. AND HE GOD.
ANY MIRACLE YOU COULD SEND OUR
WAY WOULD BE GREATLY
APPRECIATED AND HUMBLY RECEIVED
IN YOUR NAME AMEN. THANK YOU
MISS GRAYSON WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS REMAIN STANDING
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER MEDINA PLEASE
JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO OUR NATION'S
FLAG. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THE. IT IS. ALL THANK YOU MAY
BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER SOCCER MANY SIXTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY THE CEMENT AT ONE
PM HE AUDIBLE COVER MULLIN
SPEAKER FOR TO FOR THE ASSEMBLY
WAS TWO FOUR TWO FOUR THE DEATH
WE IN LOS RITA. WAS CALLS IN
ROAD. WITH ALL THE RAW MOVES
AND MISS SECONDS AT THE READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
BE DISPENSED. PRESENTATION
TEMPERATURE. THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE TO BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THERE
ARE NO ABSENCES TODAY. AND
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER GALLAGHER
TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN RIGHT
TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I MOVE TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX TO WITHDRAW SB SEVENTY FOUR
NINETY SEVEN AND ONE FOURTEEN.
FROM THE BUDGET COMMITTEE AND
ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING TO
TAKE THEM UP TODAY WITHOUT
REFERENCE THE FILE FOR THE FOR
THE THIRD READING. MR FLOOR FOR
PURPOSE ARRESTS ARE. YOU MISTER
SPEAKER WE WITHHOLD UNANIMOUS
CONSENT IN ASTRAL CALL THE- MR
FLOOR WITHHOLDS. MISTER MOVES
AND MR BONTA SECONDS ON THE
ROLL SUSPENSION MEMBERS THIS IS
A PROCEDURAL VOTE PROCEDURAL
VOTE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR
AN- VOTE MISTER FOR AND NO.
THIS IS A PROCEDURE VOTE. ON
THE ROLE SUSPENSION TAKES FORTY.
MISTER CALDERON AS FOR NINE
MISTER FLORA IS ASKING FOR NO.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
BUT I FIFTY FIVE KNOWSFIFTEEN
THE RULES ARE SUSPENDED. MISTER
CALDERON YOUR AGAIN RECOGNIZE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RE REFER SB TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT WINNER FROM THE
ELECTIONS REDISTRICTING
COMMITTEE TO RULES COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER MISTER CALDERON
AGAIN- AND MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT THAT
THE BODY- SAY- CONGRATULATIONS
AND HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO OUR
SPEAKER PRO TEM TODAY IN HONOR
OF HIS. FIFTIETH BIRTHDAY. IS
THE FLORA JACK'S THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER WE DO OBJECT ASK
FOR A ROLL CALL VOTE. THE CLERK
WILL. THANK YOU MEMBERS. MOVING
TO. BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO START.
BY TAKING THE AMENDMENTS. THAT
ARE ELIGIBLE AND ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH THE AMENDMENTS. AND THAT
IS. MR HOLDING. THIS IS FILE
ITEM FIFTY SIX AB. TWENTY NINE
EIGHTY THREE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS PURPLE READ WITH
AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
NINE EIGHTY THREE WITH A
MINUTES BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HOLDER MR HOLD ON MINUTES THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
TODAY I'M PRESENTING AMENDMENTS
TO ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE
EIGHTY THREE THE BILL ABOUT
CONSUMER PROTECTION AND SAFETY
AND HEALTH CARE. AUTOMATED
PHARMACY SYSTEMS CAN BE HELPFUL
FOR PEOPLE WITH CHRONIC
CONDITIONS TO TAKE DAILY
MEDICATIONS BY REDUCING LAG
TIME BETWEEN REFILLS. HOWEVER
SOME LARGE PHARMACIES HAVE BEEN
BAD ACTORS AND HAVE TAKEN IT A
STEP TOO FAR. THEY REQUEST
REFILLS BEYOND WHAT WAS
ORIGINALLY PRESCRIBED SOMETIMES
TO THE DETRIMENT OF THE
PATIENT. AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTY
THREE WOULD ENSURE PATIENTS OPT
IN TO AN AUTO REFILL PROGRAM IF
THEY WANT TO USE IT AND DOCTORS
HAVE MORE CONTROL TO ENSURE.
THE NUMBER OF REFILLS PATIENT
RECEIVED AS RECOMMENDED BY THE
DOCTOR NOT THE PHARMACY THE MMS
CLARIFY THE WORD AUTOMATICALLY
TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT THE
THIRTY DAY RESTRICTION DOES NOT
APPLY TO PEOPLE WHO ARE. IN TO
THE AUTO REFILL GRAHAM THEY
STRIKE THE REQUIREMENTS THAT
EACH PRESCRIPTION NEEDS AS
SEPARATE WRITTEN AUTHORIZATION.
PATIENTS CAN CONTINUE TO USE
AND I AGREE FILL PROGRAM. AS
THEY ARE NOW. AND THEY DELAY
OPERA DATA. TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TO ENSURE PHARMACIES HAVE
ENOUGH TIME TO IMPLEMENT THE
LAW OUTSIDE OF THE PANDEMIC. I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS. THEY YOU MISTER
HOLDING. WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY THE
EYES HAVE IT THE MEMBERS ARE
ADOPTED BILLS OUT TO PRINT AND
BACK ON FILE.
OKAY MISS KOREA
IS READY THIS IS FILE ITEM
FIFTY SEVEN. FILE ITEM FIFTY
SEVEN MEMBERS AB THIRTY THREE
THIRTY SIX FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS CORKERY OF MEN
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY THREE
THIRTY SIX WITH A MINUTES BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARILLO. MYSTERY
OF. YOU MUST. MEMBERS IN ORDER
TO ADDRESS THE- X. RAYS POLICY
COME. THE AMENDMENT TO AB
THIRTY THREE THIRTY SIX WILL
REMOVE. THE REQUIREMENT FOR
THIRD PARTY DELIVERIES TO
OBTAIN A FOOD HANDLER CARD
THESE AMENDMENTS WILL ALSO
ACCEPT FOOD DELIVERY BY A
GROCERY STORE FROM A THIRD
PARTY. DELIVERY SERVICE
REQUIREMENTS AS WELL AS EXTENT
TO TRANSPORT AS PART OF A
TERRIBLE FEEDING PROGRAM FROM
PROPOSED. FIREMAN'S I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
AMENDMENTS BE ADOPTED YOU.
THANK YOU MS GRILL WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY YES HAVE IT. HE
MENTORED OPTED BILLS OUT TO
PRINTED BACK ON FILE. MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME WE ARE GOING TO
WANT TO PASS TEMPORARILY A
MISTER GIBSON'S AMENDMENTS WE
WILL RETURN TO THOSE LATER WE
ARE GOING TO. CHECK UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
UP. FILE ITEM. FORTY NINE. IF I
COULD FIND MISTER O'DONNELL. WE
ARE GOING TO PASS WE WANT TO
PASS TEMPORARILY. AB MEMBERS
ARE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM FIFTY AS WELL. IF
MR KILEY IS READY TO TAKE A
FILE ITEM FIFTY ONE THIS IS AB.
THIRTY TWO SEVENTY ONE CORRECT
SOME PEOPLE THIRTY TWO SEVENTY
ONE BY SOME REMEMBER KILEY AN
ACCOLADE TO ENROLLMENT
AGREEMENTS MR KILEY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I AB THIRTY TWO
SEVENTY ONE INSURES THAT A
VICTIM OF CHILDHOOD SEXUAL
ASSAULT CAN PURSUE A CIVIL
ACTION AGAINST THE PERPETRATOR
AND OTHER RELEVANT PARTIES THE
BILL WOULD GIVE A MINOR THE
ABILITY TO OPT OUT OR JUST A
FIRM A PROVISION AND ROAMING
AGREEMENT FOR THEIR SCHOOL THE
DENIES THE MANY LEGAL RIGHT
REMEDY FOR IN PROCEEDING OR
PROCEDURE. FOR A SPECIFIC TYPE
OF CLAIM ONE ARISING OUT OF A
CRIMINAL SEXUAL ASSAULT OR
BATTERY THE GOALS OF
ARBITRATION OR POORLY ADAPTED
TO THIS NARROW AND UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE THE AGENT OF
ENERGY CAN ESTABLISHMENT HAS
COMMITTED AN ACT OF SEXUAL
VIOLENCE. MY FROSTED ITS CARE.
AN INJURY OF A KIND THAT WOULD
NOT BE UNDERSTOOD THE SUBJECT
ARBITRATE BY READ PARA MUCH
LESS HI MY STUDENT WHO LIKELY
WILL NOT AWARE OF THE PAUSE OR
THE CALL. OF ARBITRATION AT ALL
I RESPECTFULLY ASK ABOUT. KILEY.
SEEN NOTE. YEAH MISS CAN YOUR.
I HAVE THIS AND I THINK IT
BRINGS OUT A VERY PROBLEM THAT
WE TRY TO DEAL WITH THROUGHOUT
THE YEARS I KNOW MY COLLEAGUE
FROM I'M SAN DIEGO AND I BOTH
HAVE HAD BILLS ON BINDING
ARBITRATION AND THE DAMAGE THAT
THAT CAN CAUSE WHEN PEOPLE ARE
FORCED INTO ARBITRATING
SOMETHING THAT'S INAPPROPRIATE
FOR ARBITRATION MAYBE THEY
DON'T EVEN CHOOSE FOR
THEMSELVES. IT ALSO BRINGS UP
THE ISSUE OF CHILDHOOD SUCH
ALSO I'M VERY HAPPY THAT WE
HAVE MEMBERS OF A ACROSS THE
AISLE NOW THAT ARE SEEN THE
DAMAGES DONE BY CHILDHOOD
SEXUAL ASSAULT NEED TO BE ABLE
TO S. STAND UP FOR THOSE
CHILDREN AND THE PROBLEMS WITH
BINDING ARBITRATION HOW THAT
NEEDS TO CONTINUE TO BE AN
ISSUE WE HAVE TO TACKLE WITHOUT
AYE I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AS
WELL. THANK CONSULT. SEEN
NOTICE SURVEY ON THE ADAM
MISTER KILEY YOU MAY CLOSE IF
YOU WISH HI THE ASSEMBLY WILL
FROM SAN DIEGO FOR HER SUPPORT
NOW FOR AN ITEM. THANK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. MEMBERS RESERVE
VOTE ON VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER RALPH
TELEVOTE AYE SIXTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS REMEMBER BACK IN THE
FILE TO TAKE A FILE ITEM FORTY
NINE THIS IS FILE ITEM FORTY
NINE AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY TWO
BY MISTER O'DONNELL QUIRK WITH
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE
THIRTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
OLD ON ONE ACCOLADE THE PUBLIC
CONTRACTS TO CLEARING YEARS
EITHER OF TAKE VERY. MR
O'DONNELL. MISTER AND MEMBERS
AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY TWO IT
JUST BILL. THIS BILL AUTHORIZES
THE CITY OF LONG BEACH TO
UTILIZE THE DESIGN BUILD
CONTRACT METHOD FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION OF CURB RAMPS.
UNDER A SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT
THE CITY'S REQUIRED TO BUILD
CURB RAMPS THAT MEET THE-
AMERICAN WITH DISABILITIES ACT
BY THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. THIS BILL WILL ALLOW THE
CITY TO ISSUE A CONTRACT FOR
BOTH THE DESIGN AND
CONSTRUCTION OF THE CURB RAMPS.
THIS WILL EXPEDITE THE
CONTRACTING DESIGN AND
CONSTRUCT THEM PROCESS SEES TO
ENABLE THE CITY. IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO DEADLINE AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY. TO ENSURE THAT
SAFE SAFETY AND ACCESSIBILITY
OF ALL TO ALL UPON WHICH TO
RESIDENT PASTOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL SEE
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE THE AT.
QUICKLY. RESERVE VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTED AS I TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. IS A. THE CLERK
WELL OR CULTURAL TIED ABOUT I
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO. ON THE
URGENCY I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO ON
THE MEASURE THAT BILL PASSES.
AND NOW WE WILL TAKE A FILE
ITEM FIFTY. THIS IS MISTER
STONES AB. TWENTY FIVE TWELVE
PURPLE RATE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIVE TWELVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MARK STONE AND OTHERS AN
ACT RELATING TO CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE MR STONE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
NEARLY TWENTY YEARS AGO THE
UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT
DETERMINED THAT IT WAS CRUEL
AND UNUSUAL PUNISHMENT TO
EXECUTE SOMEONE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
CALIFORNIA FAIRLY QUICKLY
FOLLOWED SUIT. AND ALIGN OUR
LAWS. AB TWENTY FIVE TWELVE
THOSE TWO THINGS PRIMARILY ONE
IS IT UPDATES THE CLINICAL
STANDARDS THAT ARE USED TO
DETERMINE WHAT INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITY IS. AND THEN
SECONDARILY AND VERY
IMPORTANTLY IS IT PROHIBITS
PROSECUTING ATTORNEYS FROM
ASKING THAT A AN IQ SCORE BE
BUMPED UP BECAUSE OF REASONS OF
RACE WHICH HAS HAPPENED QUITE A
BIT IN THE PAST. FACT ARE
TURNING GENERAL THIS BILLS
INTRODUCED REALIZE THAT THEIR
PRACTICE IS UNFAIR AND IS
RACIALLY BIASED. AND IS NO
LONGER FOLLOWING THAT POLICY.
THIS WOULD END THAT RACIALLY
BIASED. PRACTICE THAT HAPPENED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON TWENTY FIVE
TWELVE. THANK YOU MISTER DOWN.
SEEING NO MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM QUIRK
LIBERAL. OBSERVER ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. THE DESIRE TO VOTE. QUIRK
WELL. CLOSER ALL TIDE OF A ICE
FOOD THREE NO ZERO THAT MAY
PASSED. WE ARE FILE ITEM. FIFTY
TWO. FILE ITEM. FIFTY TWO IS AB.
NINETEEN FIFTY. THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEENTH
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KAMLAGER AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE A PROBATION.
MS KAMLAGER YOU MAY OPEN. THANK
YOU COULD HAVE MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT AB
NINETEEN FIFTY THIS BILL IS ONE
OF THE BLACK CAUCUSES PRIORITY
BILLS IT WOULD SET A MAXIMUM
PROBATION PERIOD OF ONE YEAR
FOR MISDEMEANOR OFFENSES IN TWO
YEARS FOR SOME FELONY OFFENSES.
I WANT TO START BY SAYING THAT
MANY OF THE LETTERS OF
OPPOSITION STATING THAT THIS
BILL. HAS A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH WERE. DATED PRE
AMENDMENT CROSSING AND THOSE
ISSUES HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED THE
BILL EXAMS CRIMES COMMITTED
AGAINST MONETARY PROPERTY
VALUED AT OVER TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND AND ANY SPECIFIC
CRIMES WITH PROBATION TERM
LINKS IDENTIFIED BY STATUTE
WHICH INCLUDE DO YOU EYES.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND SUCH AND
STRIKE FELONY OFFENSES MANY SEX
CRIMES ARE IN ELIGIBLE FOR
PROBATION BY STATUTE UNDER
PENAL CODE SECTION ONE TWO OH
THREE POINT SIX FIVE AND ARE
THEREFORE ALSO EXEMPT FROM AB
NINETEEN FIFTY. BUT I WOULD SAY
THAT WHAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE. IS
A STATE'S ALL. GEN A JUDGE CAN
REVOKE EXTEND TERMS OR RESTART
THE CLOCK ALL AMOUNTING TO
LENGTHY AND COSTLY PROBATIONARY
TERMS. AB NINETEEN FIFTY
CREATES REASONABLE AN EVIDENCE
BASED LIMITS ON PROBATION TERMS
AND IT OFFERS A SLIDING SCALE
APPROACH SUPPORTING SUCCESS
OVER PUNISHMENT AND LOWERING
COSTS TO TAXPAYERS. IT RETAINS
JUDICIAL X. DISCRETION AND
RECOGNIZES THAT PROBATION CAN
STILL BE REVOKED FOR
SUBSTANTIVE VIOLATIONS. WHY IS
AB NINETY BE NEEDED BECAUSE THE
STATUS QUO HAS TO CHANGE
PROBATION IS RACIAL CULTURAL
REGIONAL CLASS BASED AN
ARBITRARY. IT CRIPPLES SUB
CULTURES AND ECONOMIC THE KANA
MEANS ACROSS COUNTIES IT
DEBILITATE FAMILIES. A CHILD
HAS TO WATCH HIS OR HER MOTHER
INDOOR THE FRUSTRATION OF
FIGURING OUT WHERE TO LIVE AND
WHERE TO FIND EMPLOYMENT ALL
WITH ADDITIONAL LIMITATIONS
THAT MAKE THESE TASKS MORE
DIFFICULT THAN THEY ARE.
PROBATION IS AN INTER
GENERATIONAL CURSE AND IT IS AS
ARBITRARY AS THE CULTURE OF THE
PROBATION DEPARTMENT AND THE
OFFICERS WHO WORK WITH ANY. IT
IS AS FAR FROM THE VISION OF
JOHN AUGUSTA'S AS YOU COULD GET
WHO WAS JOHN AUGUSTA'S HE WAS
THE FATHER OF PROBATION. HE WAS
A COP COBBLER FROM BOSTON WHO
WOULD SIT IN THE BACK OF THE
COURTROOM. AND HE WOULD ASK THE
COURTS TO LEAVE THE DEFENDANTS
IN HIS CARE WHERE HE WOULD
RECLAIM THEM HE WOULD GUIDE
THEM WITH STRUCTURE WITH
TREATMENT AND COMPASSION
WORKING THEM TOWARD SUCCESS NOT
EXTENDED TERMS. WHY IS AB FIFTY
NEEDED NINETEEN FIFTY NEEDED
BECAUSE PROBATION IS THE MOST
WIDELY USED FORM OF
CORRECTIONAL CONTROL IN THIS
STATE. OUR ADULT SUPERVISED
PROBATION POPULATION IS ALMOST
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND IT IS ONE
OF THE LARGEST IN THE NATION
MORE THAN TWICE THE SIZE OF THE
TATE'S PRISON POPULATION
ALMOST FOUR TIMES LARGER THAN
ITS JAIL POPULATION. AND ABOUT
SIX TIMES LARGER THAN OUR
PAROLE POPULATION AND A CLOG
THE COURTS MORE THAN ANY OTHER
FORM OF SUPERVISION. A
PROBATION TERM MAY REQUIRE THAT
YOU CONTINUOUSLY SEEKING
MAINTAIN GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT
YOUR ABILITY TO TRAVEL ACROSS
COUNTY LINES MAY BE RESTRICTED
YOU MAY BE SUBMITTED TO A
SEARCH OF YOUR PERSON OR YOUR
HOME WITHOUT WARNING. YOU MAY
BE IN VIOLATION OF YOUR TERMS
IF YOU ARE LATE OR MISSED AN
APPOINTMENT INTERACT WITH
FRIENDS FAMILY MEMBERS RIDE IN
THE FRONT SEAT OF A CAR OR EVEN
GET PREGNANT. I HAVE SOME REAL
STORIES FOR YOU. CHRISTOPHER
LAW LOS. WAS IN VIOLATION OF
HIS TERM BECAUSE HE WENT TO
VISIT HIS MOTHER AT HER HOUSE
WHERE HIS ON PROBATION COUSIN
LIVED. ULYSSES RODRIGUEZ WAS IN
VIOLATION OF HIS PROBATION
BECAUSE HE COULD NOT COMPLETE
HIS FINAL TWELVE HOURS OF BEACH
CLEAN UP FOR HIS COMMUNITY
SERVICE DURING THE COLD A
PANDEMIC WHEN THE BEACHES WERE
CLOSED. CRUZ MEMBRANE AN ARMY
VETERAN WAS IN VIOLATION OF HIS
PROBATION BECAUSE HE COULD NOT
KEEP HIS PROBATION OFFICER
APPRISED OF HIS PERMANENT
ADDRESS WHEN HE WAS CAST FROM
TEMPORARY HOUSING AND ENDED UP
HOMELESS LIVING ON THE STREETS
THIRTY SECONDS RODRICK SCUDDER
WAS VIA. FOR MOVING FOUR MILES
FROM CONTENT TO LANGUAGE
BECAUSE HE SIGNED THE LEASE
WITH OUT ASKING HIS PROBATION
OFFICER'S PERMISSION WITHOUT
HER GOING TO SEE THE APARTMENT
AND APPROVED THE APARTMENT
CRYSTAL RIOS WAS ATTENDING
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO BECOME AN
LV IN AND HAD TO MAKE A
DECISION BETWEEN GOING TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND GOING TO
HER PROBATION OFFICER
APPOINTMENTS BECAUSE WOULD NOT.
CHANGE THE APPOINTMENT TIMES.
BEING ON PROBATION WITH THESE
EXTENDED TERMS IS LIKE LIVING
IN QUICKSAND. AND PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS MICROMANAGE PEOPLE
IN APPLY HAPHAZARD RULES
DESIGNED TO CATCH FOLKS THIS
BILL. THE ONE CHALLENGE THAT I
HAVE COMMITTED TO WORKING ON
WITH OUR PROBATION DEPARTMENTS.
IS ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT WE
KEEP THEIR FUNDING SUPPORTED
THROUGH THE SB SIX SEVEN EIGHT
PERFORMANCE BASED FORMULA.
BECAUSE IF YOU CAN LESSEN
CASELOADS AND FOCUS ON
INTENSIVE TREATMENT AND
GUIDANCE AND SUPPORT YOU CAN
CYCLE FOLKS OFF OF PROBATION
SUCCESSFULLY PEOPLE SAY TWO
YEARS IS NOT A LONG TIME YOU
CAN BECOME AN AIR TRAFFIC
CONTROLLER IN TWO YEARS. IF YOU
HAVE MEASURABLE. PROGRAMMING
ROBUST RESPONSIVE. AND
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS WHO ARE
RESOURCE AND INVESTED IN
WORKING TOWARD SUCCESS YOU CAN
LOWER COSTS TO TAXPAYERS HAVE A
SUCCESSFUL DEPARTMENT OF
PROBATION. AND GIVE PACKED
FOLKS WHAT THEY WANT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEAD SUCCESSFUL
LIVES WITHOUT BEING TETHERED TO
THE SYSTEM FOR EVER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON A. B. NINETEEN FIFTY
MISTER MURATSUCHI YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I. RESPECT WITH THE AUTHOR IS
TRYING TO DO WITH THIS BILL.
BUT I MUST SAY THAT HAVING BEEN
A CRIMINAL TRIAL LAWYER BOTH AS
A PROSECUTOR AS WELL AS AS A
PUBLIC DEFENDER. THAT THE
DESCRIPTION OF THE AUTHOR GAVE
ON THE REALITIES A PROBATION
ARE NOT CONSISTENT WITH MY
EXPERIENCE IN THE CRIMINAL
COURTS. ME NUMBER ONE OPERATION
IS OFTEN USED AS PART OF THE
DISK THE JUDICIAL DISCRETION.
IT OFTEN AS AN ALTERNATIVE TO
JAIL TIME. YEAH A LOT OF THAT
IS NEGOTIATED EMPLOYEE
BARGAINING I'VE BEEN INVOLVED
IN MANY CASES WHERE BOTH THE
PROSECUTION THE DEFENSE
ATTORNEY WOULD AGREE THAT OKAY
AND LIEU OF JAIL TIME OR IN
LIEU OF ANY ADDITIONAL JAIL
TIME WILL EXTEND THE PROBATION
PERIOD SO I THINK THIS BILL
WILL TAKE AWAY THAT TIME OF TWO
TO SUPPRESSION. I PRE THE
AUTHOR MAKING THEIR MEMBERS SO
MY FOR QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR
WAS THE IMPACT ON DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. AND ON DO YOU AYE
CASES- AS THE AUTHOR INDICATED
THOSE HAVE MINIMUM PROBATION
PERIOD SPECIFIED. AND I BELIEVE
HER AMENDMENTS- ADDRESS MY
CONCERN IN TERMS OF MAKING SURE
THAT DEFENDANTS HAVE. ENOUGH
TIME TO COMPLY WITH THE TERMS
OF PROBATION. BUT THERE RE
MANY OTHER CASES MANY OTHER
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE THIS. CAP
ON PROBATION PERIOD WOULD
INTERFERE WITH THE GOALS OF
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN TERMS OF
REHABILITATION. THERE ARE CASES
THAT INVOLVE. DRUG REHAB
PROGRAMS ALCOHOL ALCOHOLICS
ANONYMOUS PROGRAMS STAY AWAY
ORDERS FOR- VICTIMS OF CRIMES
THAT ARE TIED TO THE PERIODS OF
PROBATION THIS BILL WOULD
INTERFERE WITH THOSE ATTEMPTS
FOR COURTS TO TRY TO COME UP
WITH CREATIVE SOLUTIONS TO
ORDER YOU KNOW DRUG TREATMENT
PROGRAMS AND ANGER MANAGEMENT
PROGRAMS. AND IT WOULD ALSO
TAKE AWAY V. THE INCENTIVE OR
OR THE ABILITY OF THE COURTS TO
ENFORCE COMPLIANCE WITH THESE
DRUGS OR ANGER MANAGEMENT OR
STAY AWAY ORDERS. FINALLY THERE
THERE IS. RESTITUTION IS OFTEN
TIED TO PROBATION WHERE FOR
VICTIMS TO BE COMPENSATED FOR
BEING VICTIMS OF CRIMES THAT
OFTEN PROBATION IS USED TO
ENSURE THAT THE CRIMINAL
DEFENDANT PACE THE RESTITUTION
THAT THEY OWE TO THE UP TO THE
CRIME VICTIMS LAST BUT NOT
LEAST. FROM MY EXPERIENCE.
ALMOST ALL PROBATION VIOLATION-
CASES. ARE BECAUSE SOMEONE
PICKS UP A NEW CRIME. AND SO
THAT THAT IS YOU KNOW THIS
THIS- TAKES AWAY FROM THE
ABILITY OF. PROSECUTORS TO YOU
KNOW IN LIEU OF A FILING AND
PURSUING NEW CHARGES THEY
PURSUE A PROBATION VIOLATION SO
THEY DO SO THAT THEY WOULD GET.
SOME KIND OF ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
THE NEW CRIME THAT WAS A THAT
OCCURRED DURING- APPEARED WHEN
SOMEONE IS ON PROBATION. SO YOU
KNOW AGAIN I RESPECT- WHAT THE
AUTHOR IS IT IS TRYING TO DO
HERE BUT I THINK. IT IT DOESN'T
PAYING A REALITY- PICTURE OF
REALITY IN TERMS OF WHAT
ACTUALLY HAPPENS IN OUR
CRIMINAL COURT SYSTEMS AND FOR
THAT REASON I WILL BE OPPOSE IN
THIS BILL. THANK YOU MURATSUCHI
MISTER KALRA YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
MISTER KALRA. PAUSE MISTER
KALRA FEET MAY HAVE A TECHNICAL
ISSUE. YEAH. A ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER JUST FOR OUR
UNIVERSITY IS VERY BRIEFLY I
KNOW WE HAVE DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCES OF PRIOR- BUT TO
OUR POLITICAL WORLD I WORKED AS
A PUBLIC DEFENDER FOR ELEVEN
YEARS AND I CAN TELL YOU
UNEQUIVOCALLY IN MY EXPERIENCE
THAT PROBATION VIOLATIONS ARE
NOT- PUT IN PLACE IN LIEU OF
NEW CHARGES NEW CHARGES ARE
BROUGHT AND THEY ADD PROBATION
VIOLATIONS AS ADDITIONAL
PENALTIES AND I CAN ALSO STATE
THAT IN MY EXPERIENCE IT'S ARE
MORE LIKE FOR PROBATION
VIOLATIONS NOT A. B. NOT EVEN
BE IN RELATION. TO A NEW CRIME
BUT TO THE AUTHOR'S POINT THEY
COULD BE SOME. IT'S AN
APPOINTMENT THEY CAN BE NOT
COMPLETING. IT COULD BE A LOT
OF WIDE VARIETY OF THINGS. THAT
IN MANY CASES WERE NOT IN THE
CONTROL OF- OF THE PROBATIONER
AND YET IT'S ONE STRIKE AND
YOU'RE OUT. AND SO I JUST WANT
TO MAKE THAT CLEAR FOR THE RICH
FOR THE RECORD FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE. THAT FAR MORE
PROBATION VIOLATIONS ARE DUE TO
TECHNICAL VIOLATIONS OF THE
CONDITIONS OF PAROLE NOT NEW
CHARGES AND AT THE NEW CRIME IS
COMMITTED PROBATIONERS ARE
CHARGED WITH THAT NEW CRIME.
AND A PROBATION VIOLATION IS
THAT IN ADDITION ADDED TO THAT
AND SO I JUST WANTED. TO STATE
THAT THOSE FACTS AND THAT I.
UNEQUIVOCALLY SUPPORT AB
NINETEEN FIFTY I THINK THIS IS
THE RIGHT PATH FOR OUR STATE.
IN TERMS OF ENSURING THAT
PROBATION NEEDS THE MISSION OF.
OF WHAT IT CLAIMS TO DO WHICH
IS TO TRULY REHABILITATE AND
GET- PROBATIONERS BACK IN TO
THE NORMAL MAINSTREAM OF LIFE-
AND- TO BE AS PRODUCTIVE AS
POSSIBLE AND SUCCESSFUL. NOT
RESET OF EIGHT AND NOT MANY
MORE CRIMES THANK YOU SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MUCH KALRA DOCTOR
WEBER. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YES
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN
FIFTY THE COULDN'T A CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS. IS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL BECAUSE WE
ALSO RECOGNIZE THE FACT THAT
ONE OF THE GREAT CHALLENGES IN
OUR COMMUNITY IS THE OVER THE-
A LARGE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
WHO ON PROBATION. AND THE FACT
THAT IS IT IN ADDITION TO THAT
IT BECOMES A ALMOST EIGHT AND
pEXPERIENCE THAT PEOPLE HAVE THE
GREATEST FEAR IS THAT THE
GUNNERS COMMITS A MINOR OFFENSE
AND GO SOME PLACES SHOULD'VE
GONE OR HAVE A- PERSON IN THEIR
PRESENCE WHO THEY DIDN'T KNOW
WAS GOING TO BE THERE AND AS A
RESULT. THEY PICKED UP FOR
VIOLATION OF THE PAROLE- IF
THEY COMMIT NEW CRIMES ARE
GOING TO BE SERVE THOSE ISSUES
WITH THOSE AND CRIMES AND BE
CONVICTED FOR IT. BUT BUT THE
PROBATION PERIOD IS OFTEN SEEN
THIS AS A- I GOT TO KIND OF X.
A LOT OF INDIVIDUALS AND THE
LONGER YOU ON PROBATION. THE
MORE LIKELY YOU WANT VIOLATE
SOMETHING THAT PROBATION THAT
HAS NOTHING TO DO AT ALL WITH
THE OFFENSE COPE BUT IT SO THE-
LET'S GET A BLACK CAR. THIS IS
ONE OF THE PRIORITY BE WE READ.
THE AS IN TO TALK SOCIAL
JUSTICE THE OPEN SURVEY. OF
PEOPLE OF COLOR IN THE CAN. OF
INDIVIDUALS. ALL BEING HARASSED
MINGLE BUT IN ON A REGULAR
BOXES OF AN OFFENSE AS HAVE
THEIR PRINT TO REBEL THE AND
THE. THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION MS KAMLAGER YOU MAY
CLOSE IF YOU WISH THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND I WANT TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE COMMENTS I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
SPEAKING ON THIS BILL AND ALSO
TO MY COLLEAGUE FOR TORRANCE-
FOR RAISING SOME ISSUES THAT I
CAN ADDRESS AND MY CLOTHES YOU
KNOW PROBATION TO PLAY DO WE DO
NOT DEBTORS PRISON- AND SO TO
XIN CANNOT BE LINKED WITH
PUNISHMENT. ONCE YOU ARE OFFER
PROBATION YOU CAN STILL HAVE
YOUR- RESTITUTION TRANSFER TO A
CIVIL JUDGMENT WHERE IT STAYS
WITH YOU FOR TEN YEARS AND YOU
STILL HAVE TO PAY THAT BACK.
THIS DOES NOT IMPACT NEW CRIMES
IF YOU COMMIT A NEW CRIME AND
YOU ARE CHARGED WITH THE NEW
CRIME THE CLOCK STOPS AND YOU
HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE NEW
CRIME. MY COLLEAGUE FROM
TORRANCE IS CORRECT PROBATION
AND PROSECUTORS OFTEN DO USE
PROBATION AND THE TERMS OF
BLACK PROBATION AS AN END RUN
AROUND NEW CHARGES WHERE THEY
MIGHT NOT HAVE THE FAX AND
CANNOT ACTUALLY CHARGED. A
DEFENDANT WITH THE NEW CRIME
BUT THAT IS ALSO NOT JUST. AND
WE HAVE TO ASK OURSELVES WHY WE
ARE USING THAT SYSTEM TO
CONTINUE TO TETHER FOLKS TO
PROBATION WITH THE FEAR OF
PUTTING THEM IN PRISON OR JAIL.
I WANT TO ALSO ADD THAT WE
SPEND AS A STATE TWO BILLION
DOLLARS INCARCERATING FOLKS FOR
TECHNICAL VIOLATIONS AS WE
STRUGGLE WITH OUR BUDGET. ITEM
I MUST. ASK THAT WE AGREED THAT
WE CAN SPEND THOSE TWO BILLION
DOLLARS SOME PLACE ELSE WHERE
WE WILL SEE A GREATER TURN ON
INVESTMENT. THIS DOES NOT
IMPACT JUDICIAL DISCRETION IF
YOU ARE GROSSLY OUT OF
COMPLIANCE EVEN WITH THE
CURRENT LAW THE JUDGE CAN
REVOKE YOUR PROBATION.
ULTIMATELY I WANT TO SAY WHY
THIS IS A BLACK CAUCUS PRIORITY.
BECAUSE THE DATA JUST LIKE THE
DATA SHOWS THAT YOU CAN HAVE
AFFECTED TERMS OF PROBATION THE
SHORTER THE TERMS ARE THE MORE
FOCUSED THEY ARE ON TREATMENT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY THE DATA
ALSO SHOWS THAT BLACK AMERICANS
ARE DISCRIMINATED AGAINST AT
EVERY STAGE OF THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM WE ARE TWICE AS LIKELY
TO BE PULLED OVER BY POLICE
THREE TIMES AS LIKELY TO BE
KILLED BY POLICE ARRESTED TWO
AND A HALF TIMES MORE OFTEN.
25% MORE LIKELY TO BE DENIED
BAIL AND GIVEN 35% HIGHER BAIL
AMOUNTS WHEN IT IS GRANTED WE
ARE GIVEN 25% LONGER SENTENCE
FOR THE SAME CRIME. WE ARE THE
MAJORITY OF THOSE SERVING LIFE
SENTENCES WE ARE SIX TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO BE INCARCERATED MAKE
UP 40% OF THOSE BEHIND BARS AND
ARE FOUR TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
BE ON PROBATION AND PAROLE AND
WE REMAIN ON PROBATION PAROLE.
LONGER AND YOUR LESS LIGHT TO
FIND JOBS UPON ENTRY. BUT I
HAVE TO TELL YOU THAT BLACK
PEOPLE ARE NO MORE PREDISPOSED
TO CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR THAN ANY
OTHER RACE. WE HAVE A REAL
BLIND SPOTS WHEN IT COMES TO
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM BECAUSE IT
IS BASED ON FEAR AND CLASS AND
RACE. AND WE NEED TO OWN THE
FACT THAT WE LIKE TO PUNISH BUT
PUNISHMENT IS NOT WHAT JOHN
AUGUSTA'S HAD IN MIND. WHEN HE
THOUGHT A PROBATION. WE OFTEN
PUNISHED WHAT WE FEAR BUT TODAY
I THINK THE STREETS ARE TELLING
US THAT FEAR IS NO LONGER A
VIABLE PLAYBOOK. I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON AB NINETEEN FIFTY.
THANK YOU MS KAMLAGER. CORE
CORPORAL. THE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS TO RESERVE A. CLARK
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE ICE FORTY
FIVE DOES SIXTEEN. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY
THREE. AB. NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME AGO
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
AN ACCOLADE AMOUNTS FOR
PRODUCTS. MS GARCIA YOU MAIL
BUT THANK YOU MISTER. SPEAKER I
MEMBERS AB NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE
TO PROTECT PEOPLE'S HEALTH.
LINE THE DISCLOSURE OF ALL
INGREDIENTS AND MISTER PRODUCTS
INCLUDING TAMPONS PADS CLUB
THIS SPONGES AND MYSTERY ON THE
WAR. IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
CONSUMERS HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW
WHAT IS IN THE PRODUCT IT WILL
BE SEEN FOR OVER FORTY YEARS
THEIR LIFE IN ORDER TO PROTECT
THEIR HEALTH. MY GOAL WITH THIS
LEGISLATION IS TO INCREASE THE
AWARENESS OF THE TOXIC
CHEMICALS CURRENTLY IN OUR
MISTER PRODUCTS. IT WAS
TROUBLING TO LEARN THAT
PRODUCTS RELY ON. PARABENS AND
P. FOSS AND OTHER HARMFUL
CHEMICALS FOR HUMAN HEALTH. IF
YOU'RE NOT A LUXURY AND PEOPLE
HAVE SHOULD HAVE THE RIGHT TO
KNOW WHAT'S IN THERE CHOI- IN
THE PRODUCT AND MAKES A FEW
CHOICES. I WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE OPPOSITION MY
OFFICE HAS HAD MANY STAKEHOLDER
CONVERSATIONS OVER THIS BILL
AND WE BELIEVE THAT AMENDMENTS
ARE REFLECTIVE OF THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION ON THE REMAINING
CONCERNS I BELIEVE NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE WILL REQUIRE THE
MOST COMPREHENSIVE THE CLOTH
DISCLOSURE FOR MISTER PRODUCTS
IN THE WORLD I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MS
GARCIA. I SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. QUIRK
LIBERAL. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. THE. WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF AN ICE FIFTY
NINE. THOSE ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. THIS IS FILE ITEM A
FIFTY FOUR. AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTEEN BY MR GLORIA. IN THE
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA AND
ACCOLADES TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
MR GLORIA YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS MANY
OF US ARE FAMILIAR. WITH THE
SCOURGE OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
WHAT MANY MAY NOT KNOW IS THAT
IN 99% OF THE VIOLENCE. BY
SHOULD BE USED ALL. OCCURS AB
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTEEN AIMS TO
HELP SURVIVORS DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE OF EXPERIENCE
FINANCIAL OF THESE BY
ESTABLISHING SOME PROTECTIONS
THE COURTS CAN USE IN
DETERMINING WHO IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR PAYING OFTEN ENCOURAGE
THAT. THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED NO
NO VOTES IN RECENT AMENDMENTS
HAVE REMOVED OPPOSITION TO THIS
LEGISLATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS KOREA. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
I CALL THE ROLL ALL MEMBERS.
DESERVE IT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF A. I SEVENTY.
THOSE THAT MEASURE PASSED. THIS
IS ITEM FIFTY FIVE. AB. TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTY SIX OPERATE SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY SIX
WHEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA
INOCULATE TO MENTAL HEALTH MR
GLORIA YOU MAY GET OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
CALIFORNIA VOTERS RECOGNIZE THE
NEED TO PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES TO SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS WITH THE
PASSAGE OF TWO THOUSAND FOUR'S
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT. IN
THE YEARS SINCE THAT TIME WE
HAVE WITNESSED OUR HOUSING
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS INTENSIFIED
OFTEN IMPACTING THOSE WHO ARE
MOST VULNERABLE I MENTALLY ILL
AT STAGGERING RATES. THIS BILL
RECOGNIZE THE CHANGING BEHAVIOR
HEALTH NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA AND
THEREBY REQUIRING UNSPENT
REVERTED MHSAA FUN TO BE
CONSIDER AS PART OF THE
PLANNING PROCESS FOR PURPOSES
OF PROVIDING SERVICES TO THOSE.
LIVING WITH MENTAL ILLNESS WHO
ARE ALSO AND SHELTERED I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE THE-
THANKS GLORIA. SEEING NO
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION.
OUR CLUB RURAL. THE SERVER ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ADDED VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLE TYLER I
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES WE'VE DISPENSED
WITH FILE ITEMS FIFTY SIX AND
FIFTY SEVEN. THAT BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM FIFTY EIGHT THIS IS
A. B. THIRTY THREE SIXTY SIX
CORPORATE SOME PEOPLE THIRTY
THREE SIXTY SIX BY THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
ANOTHER'S NATURALLY INTO
JUDICIAL EMERGENCIES AND
CLARITY YEARS EITHER UP SIX
BACK IMMEDIATELY. MR STONE
EMAIL THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS. WHEN CO THE HEAD
AND THE COURTS NEEDED TO ADJUST
THEIR SCHEDULES AND THEIR
TIMING AND THEIR IMPACT.
BECAUSE THEY HAD TO SHELTER IT
TOOK AN EXECUTIVE ORDER TO GIVE
THEM THE AUTHORITY TO TAKE THE
STEPS THEY NEEDED TO ON A
STATEWIDE BASIS. THE EXISTING
EMERGENCY AUTHORITY THAT THE
CHIEF JUSTICE HAS IS COUNTY BY
COUNTY AND ONLY AT THE REQUEST
OF THE PRESIDING OFFICER COUNTY
BY COUNTY IT CANNOT EVEN BE
DONE IN MULTIPLE COUNTIES IF.
THEY SUFFER FROM THE SIMILAR
EMERGENCY THIS BILL WOULD
PRECLUDE A SIMILAR EXECUTIVE
ORDER BECAUSE IT IS GIVING IT
IS APPROPRIATELY THE
LEGISLATURE NOW TAKING THAT
STEP AND GIVING THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL THE AUTHORITY WHETHER
IT'S ON A REGIONAL BASIS OR A
STATEWIDE BIT THIS. BASED ON AN
EMERGENCY IN ORDER TO CHANGE
THEIR PROCEDURES TO ENSURE
JUSTICE HAPPENS THIS BILL IS
NOT CONTROVERSIAL HAS NO
OPPOSITION IN. THE DEFENSE BAR
AND THE PROSECUTING BAR BUT THE
DEFENSE BAR AND THE PLAINTIFFS
BAR BOTH AGREE THAT THIS IS THE
RIGHT STEP FOR CALIFORNIA AT
THIS POINT I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER MISTER
GALLAGHER YOUR RECOGNIZE. YES
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS- WE HAD
THIS BILL AND JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AND I DID SUPPORT IT
THERE- THERE DOES NOT APPEAR TO
BE ANY REGISTERED OPPOSITION AT
THIS POINT- I DID RAISE A
CONCERN THOUGH I. BUT WE
CERTAINLY SEE WHERE IT COULD
HAVE BEEN NECESSARY AND NEEDED
AND IN THIS PARTICULAR PANDEMIC.
BUT I AM CONCERNED WITH GIVING.
TOO MUCH POWER TO THE GIST
JUDICIAL COUNCIL VIS A VIS
PRESIDING SUPERIOR COURT JUDGES
IN IN RESPECTIVE COUNTIES I AND
HOW THAT COULD POTENTIALLY BE
ABUSING AND MAYBE BE. OVER THE
OBJECTIONS OF. LOCAL COURT
SYSTEMS AND I GUESS YOU KNOW
WITH EVERYTHING WE'VE BEEN
DEALING WITH IN THIS
LEGISLATIVE SESSION WHERE THERE
REALLY HASN'T BEEN. AS MUCH
TIME FOR DELIBERATION TO HEAR
FROM ALL OF OUR COURTS. I DO AT
LEAST HAVE A CONCERN THAT THIS.
YOU KNOW THIS COULD LEAD TO A
BIGGER PROBLEM DOWN THE ROAD
AND I GUESS WHENEVER WHENEVER
WE ARE MOVING THINGS THROUGH
VERY FAST. IF WE AT LEAST NEED
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT AND SEE
THAT THERE IS POTENTIAL FOR.
ALBUMS HERE I HAVE AYE AYES
CERTAINLY HAVEN'T HEARD
SPECIFICALLY FROM PRESIDING
COURT JUDGES AND COUNTIES AT
THIS POINT BUT I DON'T KNOW
THIS IS REALLY ON THEIR RADAR
EITHER- SO I JUST RAISE THAT AS
A- POTENTIAL CONCERN AND I
THINK THAT'S WHY I BE WITH
HOLDING MY VOTE. TODAY. THANK
YOU MISS GALLAGHER SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. MR STONE YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I HAVE IN FACT TALK TO SEVERAL
PRESIDING JUDGES AND THEY ARE
GRATEFUL. THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
HAVE THIS AUTHORITY WITHIN THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH THIS BILL IS
APPROPRIATELY WRITTEN TO DEAL
WITH EMERGENCIES AND ALLOWS
JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO WORK WITH
THEIR LOCAL COURTS TO ENSURE
THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO ADMINISTER
JUSTICE IN THE WAY THAT THEY
NEED TO. RATHER THAN HAVING TO
GO GET AN EXECUTIVE ORDER OR GO
THROUGH OTHER. DIFFICULT
PROCESSES THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT THE JUDGES THAT I'VE
TALKED TO A IN A NUMBER OF
PLACES ACROSS THE STATE FEEL IS
VERY APPROPRIATE THE RIGHT STEP
AND AGAIN THE DEFENSE BAR AND
THE PLAINTIFFS BAR BOTH AGREE.
THAT THIS IS THE RIGHT WAY TO
GO FOR ADMINISTRATION OF
JUSTICE. DURING TIMES OF
EMERGENCY THAT I ASKED FOR I
HAVE A- THANK YOU MISS STONE
AND WITH THAT CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS RESERVE IT
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WELL. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. DESIRE TO VOTE.
TAKES FIFTY FOUR. THE CLERK.
WELL CLOSER ROLL TIDE ARISE
FIFTY FOUR NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY HIGHS FIFTY FOUR NO
ZERO ON THE MEASURE THAT BILL
PASSES. WE ARE AT FILE ITEM
FIFTY NINE. FIVE THIRTY NINE AB
TWENTY TO SEVENTY THREE BY
MISTER LOAN CORPORATION SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY TO SEVENTY THREE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM AN
ACCOLADE HEALING ARTS
MISERABLE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS BILL WILL
HELP BRING WORLD RENOWNED
PHYSICIANS TO CALIFORNIA WHO
WILL TRAIN NEW PHYSICIANS. AB
TWENTY TO SEVENTY THREE WOULD
ALLOW AN ACADEMIC MEDICAL
CENTER LIKE CEDAR SINAI- IN MY
DISTRICT TO SUBMIT CANDIDATES
FOR SPECIAL FACULTY PERMITS
DIRECTLY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL BOARD. UNDER CURRENT
LAW CEDARS MUST GO THROUGH UCLA
TO COMPLETE THE APPLICATION
PROCESS AND OBTAIN THE PROPER
PERMITS THE INTENT OF THIS BILL
IS TO TRY TO EXPEDITE. THIS
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS BY
ALLOWING CEDARS TO DO THE EXACT
SAME WORK BUT WITHOUT UCLA.
THIS BILL DOES NOT CHANGE ANY
OTHER REQUIREMENTS NEEDED TO
OBTAIN A SPECIAL FACULTY PERMIT
OR TO ESTABLISH ANY NEW
ENTITIES THAT MUST BE
REGULATED. THE SPECIALIZED
FACULTY POSITIONS WHO HOLD
THESE PERMITS TEACH PERFORM
RESEARCH AND POSITIVELY IMPACT
THE HEALTH CARE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIZENS BY IMPARTING THEIR
EXPERTISE TO THE NEXT
GENERATION. AB TWENTY TO
SEVENTY THREE WILL HELP THIS
INDEPENDENT MEDICAL CENTER
CONTINUE TO EXCEL IN ITS
MULTIPLE MISSIONS BY RECRUITING
AND ATTRACTING THE VERY BEST
PHYSICIANS IN THE WORLD AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
ARRIVAL. THANK YOU AS WELL.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM CLERK WILL OF THE
ROLE. MEMBERS IS THERE A VOTE
ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF. DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLE TYLER I
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS FILE
ITEM SIXTY. AB EIGHT NINETEEN
THIRTY FIVE GREGORY ASSEMBLY
BILL NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE BY-SOME REMEMBER VOEPEL AND OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE OF VETERANS MR
VOEPEL. MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY I PRESENT TO YOU A. B.
NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE THAT
SIMPLY ASKS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS
TO CONDUCT THIS STUDY TO
ATTEMPT TO DETERMINE WHY FEMALE
VETERANS COMMIT SUICIDE AND A
MUCH HIGHER RATE PER CAPITA
THAN THEIR MALE COLLEAGUES SO
FAR. THE FEDERAL VETERANS
ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT FOLLOWED
UP ON THIS. I ENCOURAGE
CALIFORNIA TO LEAD THE WAY.
MORE WOMEN ARE SERVING IN THE
UNITED STATES MILITARY BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE AN EXPECTED
15% INCREASE WE'RE VERY NEAR
15% OF THE MILITARY NOW FOR
WOMEN. WOMEN ARE ONE OF THE
FASTEST GROWING VETERAN GROUPS
WOMEN VETERANS ARE AT A HIGHER
RISK OF COMMITTING SUICIDE
COMPARED TO NON VETERAN WOMEN
DISCUSSING IN PREVENTING
MILITARY VETERAN SUICIDE IS
VITALLY NEEDED. FOR EVERYONE
BUT ESPECIALLY WOMEN. THIS
STUDY CAN BE THE BEGINNING OF
WHAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
CAN DO IN ORDER TO GIVE BACK TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE SELFLESSLY
PUT THEIR LIVES IN DANGER
THROUGH THEIR SERVICE TO OUR
NATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
VOEPEL. SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. DESIRE
VOTE. QUIRK WELL CLOSER ROLL
TIDE ABOUT AYE SIXTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES THIS
IS FILE ITEM SIXTY ONE A. B.
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE BY MS RUBIO
FOR COREY ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO AND OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE IN A SECONDHAND
GOODS THIS RUBIO THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE LEGISLATION
DEALING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
POND SECONDHAND DEALERS SYSTEM
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS CAPS CAPS IS
A SINGLE FEET WIDE REPORTING
SYSTEM OPERATED BY THE DOJ.
WERE INFORMATION ON
TRANSACTIONS IS RECORDED IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS THERE ARE
INDICATIONS I'M SORRY THE LAST
FEW YEARS- INDICATIONS THAT
THEY'RE THAT THE
CONFIDENTIALITY OF CAPS REPORTS
ARE BEING COMPROMISED FOR
INDIVIDUALS THAT USE MATRICULA
CONSULAR AS A FORM OF
IDENTIFICATION A SIGNIFICANT
PATTERN HAS EMERGED OR BY A
CUSTOMER WHO USES THE MULTI
COLLECT ON SALIVA IN A PART
ALONE BECOMES A PERSON OF
INTEREST AT THE IMMIGRATION AND
NON NATURALIZATION SERVICES INS.
WE THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE'S
CONTINUED EFFORTS TO PROTECT
OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES WE
CAN ONLY ARRIVE AT THE
CONCLUSION THAT THIS
INFORMATION HAS BEEN RELEASED
BY A SMALL GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS
WITH ACCESS TO THE CAP SYSTEM.
LET US BE CLEAR THAT UNDER THIS
BILL THE PALM BROKERS WOULD
LOCALLY COLLECT AND RETAIN ALL
OF THE CUSTOMER INFORMATION WE
CURRENTLY DO AND BE PART OF
CURRENTLY TO CAPS. HOWEVER IF A
MATRICULA CONSULAR WAS USED AS
ID PERSONAL INFORMATION WILL BE
RETAINED LOCALLY BY THE PROM
BROKER. TO ACCESS THIS
INFORMATION LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
SIMPLY SIMPLY REQUEST THE
OMITTED INFORMATION FROM THE
BEST THE SPECIFIC BROKER WHO
WAS. THAT WITH LOCALLY
RETAINED. AB NINETEEN SIXTY
NINE IS A VERY MILD AND SIMPLE
STEP THAT WILL PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES FROM ENTITIES THAT
ARE NOT USING THE CAP SYSTEM AS
INTENDED WITHOUT PLACING UNDUE
STRESS ON LAW ENFORCEMENT.
INVESTIGATIONS I THINK YOU AND
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE OF.
AMOS RUBIO. SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. WE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE. QUIRK WELL CLOSER ALL
THE TIME ABOUT ICE FORTY SIX
KNOWS FIVE. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY TWO AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY SEVEN BY MS
REYES QUICK READ. SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY ONE FORTY SEVEN BY SOME
MEMORY AS AN ACCOLADE TO
CONVICTIONS. MISS RAY S. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY I PRESENTED AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY SEVEN WHICH ALLOWS
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY PARTICIPATED ONE
OF CDC OURS CONSERVATION FIRE
CAMPS. TO APPLY FOR EXPUNGEMENT.
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE VETTED BY
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
UNDER CDC ARE STRICT CRITERIA.
AND THE ASSIST WITH PROTECTING
COMMUNITIES ALL ACROSS THE
STATE DURING OUR FIRE SEASONS
WHICH HAVE BECOME MORE
FREQUENT. AND DEADLIER. THIS
BILL WAS RECENTLY AMENDED TO
ADD JUDICIAL DISCRETION AND
MIRRORED THE EXCLUSIONS
CURRENTLY IN PLACE BY CDC OUR
WHICH EXCLUDE. CERTAIN VIOLENT
CRIMES SEX CRIMES AND ARSON.
MEMBERS THE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
IN THE CONSERVATION CAMP
PROGRAM HAVE LOW LEVEL CUSTODY
STATUS GOOD BEHAVIOR AND- ON
THE PATH OF REHABILITATION.
CANNOT REACH TRUE
REHABILITATION WITHOUT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SEEK MEANINGFUL
EMPLOYMENT. IF WE REALLY WANT
TO BRING ABOUT CHANGEIN LOWER
RECIDIVISM RATES. WE HAVE TO
MAKE CHANGES TO THE SYSTEMIC
POLICIES GOVERNING OUR
COMMUNITIES. AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY SEVEN DOES JUST THAT IT
WOULD ADD MUCH NEEDED BALANCED
FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THESE INDIVIDUALS WERE VETTED
BY CDC ARE AND SELECTED BECAUSE
OF THEIR LOW LEVEL CUSTODY
STATUS. THE GOOD BEHAVIOR AND
OTHER FACTORS. IF WE ARE
WILLING TO ALLOW INCARCERATED
PERSONS TO VOLUNTEER AND HELP
FIGHT FIRES PROTECTING LIVES
AND PROPERTY WILL PUTTING THEIR
LIVES AT RISK. BUT WE SHOULD BE
WILLING TO ALLOW THEM. AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RECEIVE AN
EXPUNGEMENT WHICH CAN BE
GRANTED AFTER JUDICIAL REVIEW.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL. THANK YOU MS RESPONSIBLE
YOUR RECORD ASKED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I STAND IN AND
TO THE AFRICAN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY ONE FORTY SEVEN
AND I'D LIKE TO THANK MY FRIEND
FROM SAN BERNADINO FOR BRINGING
FORWARD THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
THAT WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS HAVE A PATH TO
OBTAINING MEANINGFUL EMPLOYMENT.
THE INDIVIDUALS ARE PARTICIPATE
IN THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CAMP PROGRAM PUT THEIR LIVES ON
THE LINE ALONGSIDE OUR STATE
AND LOCAL FIREFIGHTERS TO
PROTECT AND DEFEND THE LIVES
AND PROPERTY OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS. OUR STATE
CONTINUES TO FACE DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES EVERY YEAR AND FIRE
CAMP CREWS HELP SUPPORT AND
AUGMENT THE EFFORT OF OUR
FIREFIGHTERS. ADDING THOUSANDS
OF WORK HOURS AND SAVING
TAXPAYERS MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN THE PROCESS. BUT INDIVIDUALS
TO SERVE IN THE PROGRAM
FREQUENTLY FIND THEMSELVES
UNABLE TO ACCESS OR OBTAIN
MEANINGFUL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES UPON THEIR RETURN
RELEASE. FINDING MEANINGFUL
EMPLOYMENT AND EARNING A LIVING
WAGE IS ONEOF THE MOST
IMPORTANT STEPS FOR FORMERLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS POST
RELEASE. AND WE MUST CONTINUE
TO REMOVE BARRIERS THAT HINDER
THEIR SUCCESS. AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY SEVEN IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP TOWARDS REMOVING THE
OBSTACLES THAT INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE PARTICIPATED IN THE FIRE
CAMP PROGRAM AND FAITHFULLY
SERVE THE STATE. FACED BY
MAKING THEM ELIGIBLE TO HAVE
THEIR RECORD EXPUNGED UPON
THEIR RELEASE AND MEMBERS. WITH
GOOD REASON WE GIVE ACCOLADES
TO OUR FIRST RESPONDERS- WHEN
THE WHEN FIRES HAPPEN EVERY
TIME WE SEE A WILDFIRE OR A
FIRE EVEN IN OUR URBAN AREAS.
AND WE FORGET ABOUT THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE BEHIND THE SCENES LIKE
THESE FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS OR THE SIM CARD FOR
IT INDIVIDUALS OR IN THE FIRE
CAMP PROGRAM. AND WE OWE THEM A
DEBT OF GRATITUDE TO WE SHOULD
BE ENTHUSIASTIC AND OUR
RESPONSE ON THEIR BEHALF AND
THIS BILL DOES EXACTLY THAT SO
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY SEVEN. NAMES
BELOW MISTER VOEPEL YOUR
RECOGNIZE I ENTHUSIASTICALLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND- WAS A CO
AUTHOR WITH MY NEIGHBOR. AND
LET ME TELL YOU WHY. I ENDED UP
IN THE MILITARY. ON A. HOW CAN
I PUT THIS DIPLOMATICALLY
UNDER- LESS THAN. FAVORABLE
CIRCUMSTANCES I'LL GO WITH THAT
ONE. AND THAT'S THE WAY IT WAS
DURING THE VIETNAM WAR. SO WHEN
I ENDED UP IN A MILITARY ONLY
THOUGHT OF MYSELF. BUT AFTER
JOINING THE MILITARY TEAM. I
ENDED UP THINKING OF ALL THE
TEAM MATES AND THEN WENT TO WAR
WE FOUGHT. WITH EACH OTHER
TRYING TO WIN AND SAVE EACH
OTHER NOW THAT'S THE WAY THIS
WORKS TO YOU'RE GONNA FIGHT
FIRES YOU HAVE TO JOIN THE
TEAM. YOU GOT TO THINK IS
SOMEBODY ELSE BESIDES YOURSELF
WHICH IS WHAT GOT TO NET
TROUBLE ANYWAY. SO THIS IS A
WONDERFUL BILL. IT WILL HELP
MOTIVATE YOUNG PEOPLE AND
PEOPLE THAT HAVE RUN AFOUL OF
THE LAW LIKE IT DID ME. STOP
AND THINK. IF WE ONLY SAVE
THREE AUDIT TED I'M NEAR WE
JUST SAY ONE OUT OF TEN ON
THERE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER VOEPEL. SAYING
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
ITEM. CLICK WELL OVER THE ROLE.
DESERT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS BETTER
DESIRED ABOUT. CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE AYES
FORTY SEVEN NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY THIS IS
MISTER MCCARTY IS MEASURE THIS
IS FILE ITEM SEVENTY. AB.
TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO.
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY AN ACT
RELATING TO PAROLE MR MCCARTY
MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THIS BUILDS UPON THE
MEASURE WE HEARD A FEW MINUTES
AGO FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES AB NINETEEN FIFTY WHICH
REFORMS THAT PROBATION SYSTEM
IN CALIFORNIA THIS RELATE TO
OUR PEARL SYSTEM ALSO. I
ALREADY OF OUR LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS OF STILL BE ON OUR
JUSTICE FOR ALL TWENTY TWENTY
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE. THIS GIVES
PEOPLE THE OPPORTUNITY TO EARN
REINTEGRATION CREDITS AFTER
THEY ARE PAROLED- PAROLE IS BY
DEFINITION ABOUT REINTEGRATION
NOT RETALIATION. IN PRISON OF
COURSE INDIVIDUALS CAN RECEIVE
CREDIT FOR GOOD BEHAVIOR THIS
BRINGS THAT PRINCIPLE ON THE
OUTSIDE ONCE PEOPLE ARE
RELEASED AND DEEMED BY THE PRO
ABORTS OF NO LONGER BE A DANGER
TO SOCIETY. WE ARE ALL STAY FOR
WHEN PEOPLE ON PAROLE ARE DOING
THINGS LIKE AND ROLLING IN A
COLLEGE- VOLUNTEERING AT A
LOCAL FOOD BANK- VOLUNTEERING
ON THEIR OWN TO BE PART OF A- A
TREATMENT PROGRAM TO HELP THEIR
SELVES. NOW WE ALSO KNOW THAT
PEOPLE ON PAROLE MANY TIMES
HAVE A SCARLET LETTER WHICH
LIMITS THEIR ABILITY TO GET A
JOB. GO TO THE GRADUATION FOR A
LOVED ONE GO TO A WEDDING
OUTSIDE OF THE FORTY OR FIFTY
MILE RADIUS. THIS BILL IS GOAL
ORIENTED LAYING OUT SPECIFICS
HOW INDIVIDUALS CAN RECEIVE
CREDIT FROM THE PAROLE TERM BY
DOING THINGS LIKE. ATTAINING AT
AS A BACHELOR'S DEGREE OR A
COMPLETING COLLEGE COURSES
AGAIN VOLUNTEERING THEIR
COMMUNITIES WE DID HAVE
OPPOSITION IN COMMITTEE BUT I
AM PROUD TO ANNOUNCE WE REMOVE
REMOVE THE OPPOSITION. FROM
PORAC THEY HAVE SUBMIT A
LETTER- CCPOA HAS ARTICULATED
TO US TO HAVE RECEIVED A LETTER
THAT THEY ARE COMFORTABLE WITH
THE POSITION OF THE BILL TODAY.
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK THE RIGHT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER MCCARTY MS BAUER K.
HAND IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TO
SUPPORT AB TWENTY THREE FORTY
TWO AS MANY OF YOU MAY HAVE
SEEN I VOTED AGAINST THE BILL
WHEN I WAS UP IN PUBLIC SAFETY
BUT- I'M STANDING UP IN SUPPORT
TODAY BECAUSE AFTER THE CHANGES
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS WE
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT. EVERY
TIME WE TAKE ABOUT IS HOW DO WE
MAKE OUR COMMUNITIES SAFER THAT
IS OUR GOAL IN PUBLIC SAFETY
AND WHEN PEOPLE COME INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES AND WE WANT THEM TO
RE INTEGRATE AND SUCCEED WHAT
WE NEED THEM TO DO IS EXACTLY
WHAT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY'S
BILL ENCOURAGES THEM TO DO GET
A DEGREE GO OUT THERE DO THE
WORK THAT WILL MAKE THEM
SUCCESSFUL IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND SO IT IS ABSOLUTELY
INCUMBENT UPON US TO PASS THIS
BILL AND TO MAKE SURE THAT IS
PEOPLE RE ENTER COMMUNITY THEY
SUCCEED. AND THEY DON'T
RECIDIVIST AND INSTEAD THEY ARE
SUCCESSFUL MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY SO I URGE AN AYE VOTE
ON TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO.
THANK YOU IS BURKE A HAM IS
CARILLO. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN
THE REAR CHAMBER. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS- AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO IT'S A
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT
PROMOTES HIGHER EDUCATION AND
VOCATIONAL TRAINING PROGRAMS.
THIS BILL LITERALLY AWARDS
CREDITS TO PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETED COLLEGE
COURSEWORK VOCATIONAL TRAINING
PROGRAMS REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS. THE BILL ALSO
EXCLUDES TO NINETIES THE BILL
WAS WRITTEN BY TO FORMALLY
INCARCERATED LEADERS THREE
YEARS AGO FROM THEIR OWN
PERSONAL EXPERIENCES. ON PAROLE
I'M PROUD TO SAY THAT HOMEBOY
INDUSTRIES WHICH IS THE LEADING
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION IS
LOCATED IN MY DISTRICT THAT
DOES THIS WORK. EVERY SINGLE
DAY THANKS TO THE WORK OF
FATHER GREG BOYLE WE HAVE I
THINK HAVE MANY DIFFICULT
CONVERSATIONS IN THE LAST FEW
WEEKS. REGARDING INSTITUTIONS
ARE SYSTEMS OF
INSTITUTIONALIZED RACISM ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY AND ACROSS THIS
NATION NOW IS THE TIME FOR US
TO SHOW UP. WITH OUR VOTE AND
ACTUALLY DO SOMETHING THAT
HELPS PEOPLE AND DISMANTLE.
PROGRAMS AND SYSTEMS AND
INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE FAR FAR
TOO LONG. CREATED OBSTACLES AND
CHALLENGES FOR PEOPLE TO MOVE
FORWARD ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
COMES TO GET AN EDUCATION AND
GETTING A JOB PEARL TENDS TO BE
PUNITIVE WITH FOCUS ON THINGS
LIKE VIOLATIONS BUT DOES
NOTHING TO PROMOTE. MISSION
CORRECT. BELL THIS BILL CHANGE
IS THAT ANY GIVEN NUMBER FOR
SOME TO SEE. A NEW AND STE
AGAIN. AND BECOME INTO AND BE A
OF OUR SO. PARK AS MENTIONED BY
THE AUTHOR HAS GONE NEUTRAL
WITH THE SHERIFF DEPLOYS
BENEFIT ASSOCIATION AS WELL I'M
HOPING THAT YOU CAN SEE. THE
VIRTUE OF WHAT THIS BILL DOES
HOW WE AS THE LEGISLATURE CAN
DO THE RIGHT THING AND BEGIN TO
CREATE SYSTEMS. THAT WORK FOR
EVERYONE IN OUR STATE THAT'S
WILLING. TO DO WHAT'S RIGHT
WHAT'S GOOD FOR THEMSELVES AND
THEIR SPEND THEIR FAMILIES SO I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
CREEL. AND MISTER BONTA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR AND CHAMBER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO AND I
APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUES
SACRAMENTO FIRST LEADERSHIP ON
THIS. PEROT IS INTENDED TO
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE TRANSITIONING. FROM ONE
LIFE TO ANOTHER UNFORTUNATELY
PAROLE HAS BECOME AN EXTENSION.
OF ARE FUNDAMENTALLY BROKEN
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM INSTEAD
OF ENSURING A SUCCESSFUL
TRANSITION. PAROLE HAS BECOME
ANOTHER SYSTEM OF PUNISHMENT
PAROLE REFORM IS LONG OVERDUE.
CALIFORNIA MUST ADOPT A NEW
PARADIGM THAT FOCUSES ON
SUCCESSFUL REINTEGRATION. AND
HELPING PEOPLE TURN THE PAGE
AND MOVE ON WITH THEIR LIVES AB
TWENTY THIRTY FORTY TWO
PROVIDES THIS NEEDED REFORM. BY
PROVIDING PEOPLE ON PAROLE WITH
THE OPPORTUNITY TO EARN
REINTEGRATION CREDITS IN ORDER
TO REDUCE. THEIR TERM OF
SUPERVISION. PEOPLE SKINNY
PAROLE REFORM IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT NOW AS COVERT
NINETEEN HAS CREATED A PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS IN OUR JAILS AND
PRISONS WE MUST ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIANS HAVE THE SUPPORT
THEY NEED. WHEN SEEKING TO RE
INTEGRATE THIS BILL PROMOTES
PUBLIC SAFETY BY INSTEAD BUY
INCENTIVIZING CALIFORNIANS ON
PAROLE TO PRO ACTIVELY. ENGAGE
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES AND WORK
BEYOND THEIR CONDITIONS OF
PAROLE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB. TWENTY
THREE FORTY TWO. THANK YOU
MISTER BONTA. AND MR PEROT YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THE REAR CHAMBER
AS WELL THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THE FACT OF THE MATTER
IS CALLING SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND THE
LEGISLATURE'S BUDGET HASA
TWENTY FOUR MONTH CAP ON PAROLE
I'D RATHER SEE PAROLEES ENGAGE
IN COMMUNITY SERVICE COLLEGE
CREDITS BE PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS
OF SOCIETY AND SIT AROUND AND
THREE MONTHS. SINCE HAVE A BAD
EXPERIENCE AND SAY JUST DON'T
GET IN TROUBLE OR GO BACK TO
JAIL SO I'M GONNA SUPPORTERS
MEASURE TODAY. THANK YOU MISTER
BROMA SEEING. NO OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM.
MR MCCARTY YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I APPRECIATE
THAT BIPARTISAN- DEBATING AND
DISCUSSION ON THIS AND JUST
NOTE THAT PAROLE IS ABOUT
FOCUSING ON SUCCESS NOT JUST
PUNISHING FAILURE AND THIS IS
CERTAINLY A RIGHT DIRECTION IS
BASED UPON A NATIONAL RESEARCH
AND- DIRECTION THROUGHOUT THIS
COUNTRY AND ASK THE RIVAL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IMAGE
MCCARTY AND WITHOUT. CLIP OF
NARAL. THE START OF ALL. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
THAT I FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE UP THE
MAIN BUDGET BILL. THIS IS
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE. SB.
SEVENTY FOUR. CALGARY. SENATE
BILL SEVENTY FOUR BY SENATOR
MITCHELL WHEN OUR TO THE STATE
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
BUDGET BILL MISTER TECH EMAIL
BUT- THANK YOU FOR SPEAKERS MY
HONOR TO PRESENT OUR BUDGET
BILL SB SEVENTY FOUR. THIS IS A
TIME OF GREAT UNCERTAINTY THIS
IS A VERY DIFFERENT BUDGET THAN
WE THOUGHT WE'D PRESENT. WE SAW
THE GOVERNOR RELEASED HIS
PROPOSAL FIRST IN JANUARY. IN
FACT WHEN WE RECESSED IN MARCH
IT WAS. EVEN UNCERTAIN HOW WE
WOULD BE VOTING ON THIS BUDGET
BILL TODAY. WHETHER WE BE IN
CHAMBERS WHETHER BE SOMEWHERE
ELSE OFF SITE MAYBE VIEW TO
EVEN BE IN. CAPITOL PARK. IN
THIS BUDGET THERE A LOT OF
THINGS THAT WE ARE ASSUMING BUT
I CAN'T REALLY SAY WE KNOW FOR
CERTAIN. WHAT WILL HAPPEN.
FIRST WE'RE ASSUMING THAT THIS
IS THE FIRST OF MANY YEARS OF.
ECONOMIC CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE
GOOD BUFFETS. I THINK SO. THIS
IS A BUDGET THAT WE ARE
ASSUMING WE'RE GOING TO GET.
FEDERAL AID. BUT WE ALSO HAVE A
TRIGGER IN CASE THAT FEDERAL
AID. DOESN'T COME. BUT HERE'S
WHAT WE DO KNOW. I KNOW THAT
FAMILIES LIKE MINE ARE ON EDGE
ABOUT HOW WE WILL RESUME
SCHOOL. IN THE SUMMER AND HOW
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE UP FOR THE
LEARNING LOSS THAT WE HAD
EARLIER THIS YEAR. I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE FAMILIES. WHO ARE.
WORRIED ABOUT HOW THEY'RE GOING
TO PAY FOR HEALTHCARE. AND
WHETHER OR NOT. THEY'RE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO GET. IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES. BECAUSE
NOW'S NOT THE TIME TO BE
SENDING SOMEONE. TO A NURSING
HOME. OR NOT HAVING SOMEBODY BE
ABLE TO STAY. AT HOME. THE LAST
WEEK. WE KNOW THE- MOST
FAMILIES MY CAR'S CAN'T GO TO
WORK WITH A CHILD CARE. BECAUSE
MANY OF US ARE TO WORKING. TWO
INCOME FAMILIES. BOTH PARENTS
ARE WORKING. WE NEED A PLACE TO
DROP OFF OUR CHILDREN IN ORDER
TO. GO TO WORK. SO WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT. CHARTER DIDN'T
TAKE RATE CUTS WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE PRESERVE. THOSE
SLOTS. BECAUSE PEOPLE SHOULDN'T
HAVE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN TAKING
CARE OF THEIR CHILDREN. WE'RE
GOING TO WORK. THIS IS I
IMAGINE THE FIRST BUDGET OF
MANY TOUGH BUDGETS OVER THE
NEXT COUPLE YEARS. SO THERE ARE
CHOICES WE MADE THAT WORD
PREFERABLE. WAS A LIKE LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET BECAUSE WE TALKED
ABOUT HOW MUCH MONEY WE WERE
SAVING HOW MUCH MONEY WILL PUT%
THE RAINY DAY FUND HOW MANY
RESERVISTS WE HAD. WELL I THINK
IT SEEMS THAT TODAY THE RAINY
DAY HAS ARRIVED. SO THAT MONEY
THAT. WE HAVE WORKED
COLLECTIVELY AS THE LEGISLATURE
TO PUT AWAY IN RESERVE. TO SAVE
THAT MONEY. THIS FOLLY BEING
USE BECAUSE NOW IS THAT TIME.
THEY WERE DOING IT BECAUSE
CALIFORNIANS TODAY NEED HELP
MORE THAN EVER. WE ARE AT A
TIME WHERE PEOPLE NEED TO THEIR
GOVERNMENT AND THEIR SERVICES
MORE THAN EVER. SO WE SHOULDN'T
AS AN INSTITUTION AS A STATE
RETREAT. IN FACT I THINK WE
HAVE TO DO THE OPPOSITE WE HAVE
TO GO HELP. THE WEATHER THAT IS
HELPING. WITH VENTILATORS WITH
MATH. WITH CLEANING SUPPLIES
FOR OUR SCHOOLS. WITH US
HELPING WITH HEALTH CARE WITH
US HELPING WITH. ENSURING THAT
WE ARE EXPEDITING THOSE
UNEMPLOYMENT PLACEMENTS THAT
PEOPLE NEED. THIS HELP THAT IS
SORELY NEEDED BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT. WHEN WE WERE ALL HOME IN
HERE IF MORE CONSTITUENTS WE
HEARD ABOUT ALL THE PAIN THAT
WAS GOING ON WITH THOSE
INDIVIDUALS ARE WORK SMALL%
BUSINESSES THAT WERE CLOSED.
BUT PEOPLE WERE IN NEED. IN
THIS BUDGET. THIS BUDGET TRIES
TO CONTINUE TO HELP THOSE
PEOPLE IN NEED WHAT THE SAME
TIME BEING FISCALLY SOUND
FISCALLY UNBALANCED YES WE DO
BORROW FROM OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE BUDGET. YES WE DO TO FOR
SOME PAYMENTS TO SCHOOLS. I
WOULD RATHER DO THAT. THE START
THE SCHOOL YEAR WITH CUTS. I
WOULD RATHER DO THAT THAN TO
CUTS IN HEALTHCARE. I WOULD
RATHER DO THAT THE MAKE SURE
THAT THERE WEREN'T CHILDCARE
SLOTS AVAILABLE FOR WORKING
FAMILIES. SO THIS BUDGET ON UP
TO SAY IS A PERFECT BUDGET.
IT'S NOT. I HAVEN'T I HAVEN'T
PRESIDED OVER ONE OF MY- FIVE
YEARS THOSE BUDGET CHAIR I
DON'T THINK I WILL IN ALL MY
TIME THE LEGISLATURE. BUT THIS
IS THE RIGHT BUDGET. FOR THIS
TIME. THE BUDGET. THAT HELPS
WORKING FAMILIES. IT'S A BUDGET
THAT HELPS KIDS KEEP THEM IN
SCHOOL IT'S A BUDGET THAT ALSO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DELIVER THOSE CRITICAL SERVICES
THAT CALIFORNIA'S. ME SO
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB SEVENTY
FOUR. THANK YOU MISTER CHANG
MISTER OBERNOLTE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES THERE IS
ACTUALLY A LOT TO LIKE IN THE
BUDGET THAT WE ARE VOTING ON
TODAY THIS BUDGET REJECTS MOST
OF THE EGREGIOUS PROBLEMS THAT
WERE- IT INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE. IT
REJECTS THE TRANSFER OF A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS AWAY FROM THE STATE
HIGHWAY ACCOUNT INTO THE
GENERAL FUND THAT WAS AN
APPROPRIATE. IT CONVERTS.
SIXTEEN A JUDICIAL OFFICER
POSITIONS INTO SUPERIOR COURT
JUDGESHIPS THAT'S REALLY GOING
TO HELP WITH THE JUDICIAL
SHORTFALL IT ESPECIALLY IN THE
FASTEST GROWING PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA. IT RESTORES FUNDING
THE K. FOURTEEN EDUCATION OUR
C. ISSUES IN OUR UC'S THAT WAS
INAPPROPRIATELY DIVERTED. I IT
KEEPS OPEN THE BARSTOW VETERANS
HOME FOR WHICH I AM VERY
GRATEFUL. I AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY. THIS BUDGET
REJECTS THE GOVERNOR'S ATTEMPT
TO USURP THE LEGISLATURE'S
AUTHORITY. TO OVERSEE STATE
SPENDING HE HAD REQUESTED THE
ABILITY TO APPROPRIATE OVER
NINE BILLION DOLLARS OF FEDERAL
CORONAVIRUS REIMBURSEMENT WE'VE
REJECTED THAT HE REQUESTED THE
ABILITY TO APPROPRIATE ALONE.
ALMOST THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN
CORONA VIRUS SPENDING THAT WE
ALSO REJECTED. COLLEAGUES THE
LEGISLATURE HAS A
CONSTITUTIONAL ROLE TO PLAY
HERE IN PARTNERING WITH THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH TO OVERSEE
THAT SPEED SPENDING I'D LIKE TO
COMMEND. OUR CHAIRMAN THE
GENTLEMAN FROM SAN FRANCISCO
AND OUR COLLEAGUES IN THE
SENATE FOR HOLDING THE LINE ON
THIS. AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
EXPRESS MY HOPE THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO HOLD THE LINE AS
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE GOVERNOR
PROCEED. HOWEVER I ALSO HAVE
SOME GREAT CONCERNS WITH THIS
BUDGET. FIRST OF ALL THIS
BUDGET APPROPRIATES MONEY TO
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD FOR THE
PURPOSE OF MAKING STRUCTURAL
CHANGES TO THE CAP INJURY
PROGRAM. THESE CHANGES WOULD
RAISE THE PRICE OF ENERGY IN
CALIFORNIA TO INCREASE TAXES ON
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES. AND WHEN
WE HEARD. THIS ITEM IN BUDGET
COMMITTEE IT WAS VERY
DISTURBING TO ME TO LEARN THAT
MANY PEOPLE THE END OF THE
ADMINISTRATION OF VIEW THE
PURPOSE OF THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM TO RAISE REVENUE WHICH
WE ALL KNOW IT IS NOT THE
PURPOSE OF CAP AND TRADE. IS TO
REGULATE THE EMISSION OF
GREENHOUSE GASES IN CALIFORNIA
REVENUE IS AN ANCILLARY BENEFIT.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY I BELIEVE
THAT THIS BUDGET. IS
STRUCTURALLY IRRESPONSIBLE WE
HAVE A FIFTY FOUR BILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET DEFICIT TO CLOSE
THIS YEAR. THIS BUDGET CLOSES
THAT THROUGH WHAT CAN ONLY BE
CHARITABLY DESCRIBED AS
BUDGETARY GIMMICKS. IT USES
OVER TEN BILLION DOLLARS OF
DEFERRALS WHICH IS MERELY
SAYING THAT THIS YEAR'S BUDGETS
ALL ITEMS ARE GOING TO BE PAID
ONE YEAR INTO NEXT YEAR SO THAT
WE CAN SAY THAT THEIR NEXT
YEAR'S ITEMS INSTEAD OF THIS
YEAR'S SPENDING. THAT'S A
RESPONSIBLE. THIS BILL THIS
ABOUT BUDGET BILL HAS BILLIONS
AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
BORROWING. WHICH WE ARE
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROHIBITED
FROM DOING BUT WHAT THIS BUDGET
DOES IS IT BORROWS FROM
RESTRICTED FUND BALANCES
TRANSFERS THAT MONEY INTO THE
GENERAL FUND WITH THE PROMISED
REPAIRED. LATER WITH INTEREST.
THE PROBLEM WITH THAT THINKING.
IS THAT EVERYBODY THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ALL OF
OUR BUDGET CONSULTANTS EVERYONE
AGREES THAT THIS IS A MULTI
YEAR BUDGET EVENT. WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE ANOTHER STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT TO DEAL WITH NEXT YEAR.
AND ANY SPENDING THAT WE MAKE
THISYEAR WE PUT OFF REPAYMENT
OF THAT TO FUTURE YEARS IT'S
JUST GONNA MAKE THE PROBLEM
BIGGER FUTURE YEARS FROM NOW.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY WE HAVE
NOT CUT GOVERNMENT SPENDING BY
HARDLY AT ALL. OF THAT FIFTY
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS IN DEFICIT.
EVEN IN THE WORST CASE SCENARIO
WOULD WE GET NO MONEY FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE'RE
CUTTING STATE SPENDING IN THIS
BUDGET BY LESS THAN EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS. YOU DO THE
MATH THAT MEANS THAT WE HAVE
BALANCED THE BUDGET 85% WITH
GIMMICK. 15% WITH ACTUAL
REDUCTIONS TO STATE GOVERNMENT
SPENDING AND COLLEAGUES I KNOW
IT'S DIFFICULT TO HAVE OCCURRED
CONVERSATION ABOUT CUTTING
FUNDING. IT'S DIFFICULT TO TALK
ABOUT WHAT FUNDS WE SHOULD
REDUCE SPENDING ON. BUT WE ARE
THE ADULTS IN THE ROOM IT IS
OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO HELP
THOSE DISCUSSIONS BECAUSE IF WE
DON'T HAVE THEM THIS YEAR.
WE'RE JUST GOING TO HAVE TO
MAKE EVEN MORE PAINFUL CUTS IN
THE FUTURE. FOR THAT REASON I
ORIGINAL VOTE. THINK OF A
SHOWING OF CA MR LEVINE. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBER
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVENTY
FOUR WE ARE EXTRAORDINARILY
CLEAR EYED. IN OUR APPROACH TO
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET THAT THIS AS
MY COLLEAGUE SAID FROM BIG BIG
BEAR SAID COULD BE A MULTI
YEAR. BUDGET EVENT THIS IN FACT
COULD BE A MULTI BUDGET EVENT
YEAR. TO MAKE SURE THAT WERE
THE STEWARDS THAT OUR SCHOOLS
AND PROGRAMS THAT MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS DEPEND UPON. AND
WHILE IT WOULD BE EASY TO SAY.
THAT THIS ISN'T THE BUDGET THAT
WE WANT TO PASS OR I DIDN'T RUN
FOR OFFICE TO PASS BUDGETS LIKE
THIS. AS SOMEONE WHO FIRST
SERVED IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION. HOW
TO CUT MID YEAR. THE STAFF THAT
I KNEW AND THE SERVICES THAT
THEY WERE PROVIDING THAT PEOPLE
DEPENDED UPON. AND I SAW THAT
FIRST HAND. THIS IS PRECISELY
WHY I RAN FOR THE ASSEMBLY.
THIS IS A TEST FOR US. IN EIGHT
YEARS LATER. AFTER SOCKING AWAY
SIXTEEN BILLION DOLLARS INTO
THE RAINY DAY OR RIVER RESERVES.
WE ARE PASSING THIS TEST WHEN
WE PASS THIS BUDGET. THE
OUTLOOK IS MURKY WHETHER YOU'RE
A FAMILY BUSINESS OR ANY
GOVERNMENT AROUND THE WORLD
RIGHT NOW. AND SO WHEN WE PASS
THIS BUDGET TODAY WE KNOW THAT
WE HAVE. EXERCISE THE
DISCIPLINE AND THE STORE CHIP
THAT WAS ASKED OF US WHEN THOSE
OF US THAT WERE FIRST ELECTED
IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE PROMISE
THAT WE ARE GOING TO GET THIS
RIGHT THAT WE WILL BE STORED OF
THE MONEY AND THE PROGRAMS FOR
OUR STATE. AND THAT SO MANY OF
YOU HAVE JOINED US TO DO EACH
AND EVERY BUDGET YOUR SENSE
THANK YOU. DOCTOR ARAMBULA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
TODAY I RISE ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE AFFECTED
BY THE DECISIONS THAT WE MAKE
IN THIS CHAMBER TODAY. MY
FATHER WHO SERVED IN THIS SAME
SEAT HAS GIVEN ME A LOT OF
ADVICE. AMONG THAT ADVICE IS
ALWAYS TO REMEMBER THE PEOPLE
IN YOUR DISTRICT. E. HALL.
REMEMBER WHERE YOU LAY YOUR
HEAD AT NIGHT IS WHAT HE SAYS
TO ME. THAT IS WHY I WILL BE
VOTING FOR THIS BUDGET OUTLINED
HERE TODAY. IT IS NOT PERFECT
AND THERE IS STILL WORK TO BE
DONE BUT I KNOW THAT PUTTING
FORWARD A PROPOSAL THAT ENSURES
THAT OUR SAFETY NET PROGRAMS
ARE PROTECTED. AT A TIME WHEN
THEY ARE NEEDED THE MOST. WE
HAVE TO WORK COLLABORATIVELY
DURING A TIME OF FISCAL STRESS.
AS WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OUR
ADMINISTRATION TO REACH AN
AGREEMENT THAT WILL PROVIDE THE
SHORT IMMEDIATE RELIEF THAT OUR
FAMILIES NEED WE WILL ALSO HAVE
TO BEAR IN MIND THE LONG TERM
RESILIENCY THAT OUR STATE NEEDS
IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE A HEALTHY
RECOVERY. AS IN MEDICINE THE
HEALTH OF THE WHOLE BODY.
DEPENDS ON THE STRENGTH OF EACH
ORGAN. I HAVE BEEN PRIVILEGED
TO SIT ON THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARINGS OVER THE
LAST FEW WEEKS AND I'VE HEARD
FROM THE MOTHERS WHO ARE
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THEIR
CHILDREN. FROM THE CARE GIVERS
WHO ARE CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THEIR PARENTS AND DEPENDENCE.
FROM THE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS AND
HEALTH POLICY ADVOCATES CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THOSE WHO HAVE NO
VOICE AND I HEAR THEM LOUD AND
CLEAR. ADVOCATES HAVE SAID
NOTHING ABOUT US WITHOUT US AND
TODAY'S VOTE MOVES THIS
CONVERSATION FORWARD. AND IT IS
AN IMPORTANT STEP TOWARDS
MEETING OUR STATE'S OBLIGATIONS
AND I WOULD URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
HERE TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DOCTOR REGULAR MISTER MATHIS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER. THANK YOU.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS YOU KNOW
THIS IS GONNA BE THE- FASTEST
BUDGET PROCESS I'VE EVER SEEN
IN MY TENURE HERE. AND I THINK
WE ALL NEED TO ASK OURSELVES IS
A FRAMEWORK. REALLY WHAT OUR
PEOPLE DESERVE. ARE WE RUSHING
THIS THING SIMPLY SO WE DON'T
HIT A DEADLINE SO WE CAN GET
PAID. NOW THERE ARE PARTS OF
THIS. THAT I LIKE PARTS THAT
I'VE FOUGHT TOOTH AND NAIL ON
ON BUDGET SO ONE FOR HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES. TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE NOT DOING MASSIVE
CUTS TO OUR HEALTH CARE TO OUR
FOLKS WITH DISABILITIES. I
AGREE WITH A LOT OF THE
LANGUAGE WE'RE DOING TO KEEP
EDUCATION A PRIORITY. WHAT IT
REALLY COMES DOWN INTO THE WAY
WE'RE DOING IT. YOU CAN CALLING
GIMMICKS YOU CAN CALL IT. THE
AGE OLD CONVERSATION OF.
STEALING FROM PETER TO PAY PAUL
BUT IN REALITY WERE STEALING
FROM OUR GRAND KIDS IN OUR
FUTURE GENERATIONS. THIS
CONCERNS ME DEEPLY. BECAUSE WHY
THIS PATCHWORK BLUEPRINT MIGHT
WORK FOR THIS YEAR. IT'S NOT
SUSTAINABLE. WE HAVE THINGS IN
THIS. THAT ARE GOING TO COST
ARE BUSINESSES THAT ARE TRYING
TO RECOVER FROM COVERT NINETEEN.
TRYING TO RECOVER FROM RIOTS
AND LOOTING. IT'S GOING TO HARM
THEM. WE HAVE THINGS IN HERE TO
READ DRAW. OUR CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM WHICH FRANKLY PISSES ME
OFF. BECAUSE I'VE FOUGHT TOOTH
AND NAIL. GT PERSECUTED
ELECTION OVER IT. BECAUSE WE
HAD A PROGRAM SET UP THAT WAS
DESIGNED TO DWINDLE OUT NO WE
WANT TO READ DRAW WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE. BUT WE'LL FIND OUT
IN ANOTHER TRAILER BILL. IN THE
FUTURE WE'LL SEE. MEMBERS.
FAMILIES DESERVE BETTER THAN
THIS. THEY DESERVE BETTER THAN
US HAVING A SYSTEMATIC WAY
THAT'S GOING TO INCREASE THEIR
COST OF LIVING. WHETHER TRYING
TO RECOVER FROM RECESSION. WE
OWE IT TO THEM WE OWE IT TO OUR
KIDS YOU KNOW WHAT I TELL MY
KIDS ALL THE TIME KEY THING
GUYS IF YOU KNOW BETTER. DO
BETTER. MEMBERS I ASK THE SAME
OF YOU THANK YOU. MR FRAZIER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. WELL WE'VE ALL.
NOTICE THAT A DRAMATIC CHANGE
IN HOW WE DO BUSINESS HERE
RECALL THAT NINETEEN. AND HOW
FRAGILE THE ECONOMY CAN BE. DUE
TO THIS PANDEMIC I WANT TO
APPLAUD OUR CHAIR. HERE IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND ALSO OUR CHAIR OF
THE SENATE FOR MAKING A STAND
FOR THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
IN LEADING THE WAY WITH THEIR
STAFF TO MAKE SURE. THAT WE'RE
NOT CUTTING. WHEN WE SHOULD BE
SUPPORTING. BUT I'LL REMIND MY
COLLEAGUES AS YOU KNOW AND I
SOUND LIKE A BROKEN RECORD. THE
I. D. D. POPULATION. IS PART OF
A PROCESS THAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE. TO SUPPORT. THE
CENSUS GROWS EVERY YEAR THE
POPULATION GROWS EVERY YEAR
COST NOT GO DOWN ON SUPPORTING
THIS POPULATION. ADULT DAYCARE
CENTERS ADULT HOUSING. ANYTHING
THAT HAS TO DO WITH SUPPORT OF
THIS POPULATION NEEDS TO BE
SOME KIND OF LINE ITEM LIKE WE
DO FOR EDUCATION I CAN PROP
NINETY EIGHT KIND OF SOURCE OF
FUNDING. THE COST IS AND GO
DOWN. WE DO MAIS THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS IN
CALIFORNIA AS A COST SAVINGS
AND MADE THE PROMISE THAT WE
WOULD TAKE CARE OF THIS
POPULATION IN THESE ADULT.
HOMES. BUT CUTS DRAMATICALLY
AFFECT THE PROVIDERS. WHERE
THEY CANNOT PROVIDE SERVICES IN
AGAIN YOU'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT
COST SHIFTING. IN THE IN THE
BUDGET WILL SHIFT THIS
CROSSOVER THAT SOMETIMES IS
STEPPING OVER NOT A DIME TO
PICK UP A ARE SENT OVER DOLLAR
TO PICK UP A DIME. EXCUSE ME
FOR THAT. UNDERSTANDING THAT
SOMETIMES IF YOU CUT A SERVICE
HERE AKASHI DRAMATICALLY MORE
DOWN THE ROAD BECAUSE OF
INSTITUTIONAL CARE THAT'S. OF
DAY CARE PROGRAM NOW YOU LOOK
AT THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
PROCESS IN CALIFORNIA ALSO HIS
ONLY FUNDED THROUGH THE ADA.
WHOSE KIDS THESE KIDS NEED
ADDITIONAL FUNDING ALSO. OKAY
WE DO NEED TO FIND A BETTER WAY
OF SUPPORTING THIS POPULATION
THEY DEPEND ON US. THEIR
PARENTS THEIR FAMILIES DEPEND
ON US THE MORTALITY RATE ON
MARRIAGE WITH A SPECIAL NEEDS
CHILD IS 85% COLLEAGUES. YOU
HAVE A LOT OF SINGLE MOMS OUT
THERE. FIGHTING CHILD AND
SOMETIMES A I CAN'T MAKE IT
WITHOUT HELP. THE REGIONAL
CENTERS ARE DOING ALL THEY CAN
BUT WE HAVE PROVIDE SERVICE
PROVIDERS THE I MEAN BECAUSE WE
THE CAN THE CONSTITUENT CASE
MANAGERS. UPWARDS OF A HUNDRED
CASES PER YEAR. OF NOT BEING
ABLE TO GIVE THAT FULL
ATTENTION. THAT FAMILY NEEDS WE
NEED TO LOOK AT OUR SYSTEM OF
CARE FOR THIS POPULATION. BUT I
NEED SUPPORT FROM EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU IN BOTH HOUSES.
TO UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
POPULATION DEPENDS ON US. THEY
DON'T HAVE ANYBODY ELSE THEY
DON'T HAVE. AT ABSOLUTE
WONDERFUL LOBBYIST TO BE ABLE
TO PROPOSE TO VIEW THEIR
PROPONENTS. THEY DON'T HAVE A
PLAN WAY TO GENERATE REVENUE.
WE CAN'T LOOK AT THEM AS A
LIABILITY. THEIR VALUE IN LIFE.
THEIR GLORY THEIR HAPPINESS IS
ALL. UNIQUE AND WONDERFUL AND
WE NEED TO HAVE GENEROSITY IN
OUR HEARTS. TO SUPPORT THIS
POPULATION I ASK IN FUTURE
BUDGET NEGOTIATIONS THAT WE
MAKE A STAND. AND WE MAKE IT
BIG WE SHOW THEM THAT WE CARE.
THIS BUDGET I'M URGING AYE VOTE
BUT IN FUTURE BUDGETS YOU'RE
GONNA SEE ME. THANK YOU MISTER
FRAZIER MR KILEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER OVER THE LAST FEW
MONTHS THE GOVERNOR HAS
REPEATEDLY ASKED US TO MEET
THIS MOMENT. AND THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA CERTAINLY HAVE.
MAKING UNTHINKABLE SACRIFICES
IN DURING IMMEASURABLE
HARDSHIPS. BUT THIS BUDGET I
FEAR IS MISSING THE MOMENT
ENTIRELY. THE ORDER OF THE DAY
IS ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND FISCAL
SUSTAINABILITY YET SOMEHOW WERE
ALLUDING BOTH. AS TO THE
ECONOMY YOU'D THINK THAT AFTER
SHUTTING IT DOWN FOR MONTHS
AFTER SHUTTING SMALL BUSINESSES
DOWN FOR MONTHS WE DO
EVERYTHING WE CONCEIVABLY COULD
TO HELP THEM AND INDEED THE
GOVERNOR DID SAY WE'RE GOING TO
DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO KEEP
SMALL BUSINESSES THE FLOW. YEAH
THIS BUDGET DOES THE OPPOSITE.
REGULATIONS ARE RATCHETED UP
NOT REALLY ROCK NOT RELIEVED
TAXES ARE RAISED NOT CAUGHT
LIABILITIES EXPANDED NOT
LIMITED AB FIVE IS REINFORCED
NOT REPEALED. WE HAVE FIVE
POINT THREE MILLION UNEMPLOYED
CALIFORNIANS THAT'S MORE THAN
THE ENTIRE POPULATION OF TWENTY
EIGHT STATES MORE THAN EVER WE
NEED A BUDGET THAT PROMOTES
WORK AND SUPPORTS WORKERS. YET
EVERY PROPOSAL THAT I AND
SEVERAL OF MY COLLEAGUES OFFER
TO DO THIS EVAPORATED INTO THIN
AIR NET OPERATING LOSS CARRY
BACKS FOR SMALL BUSINESSES TAX
EXEMPTIONS FOR PP LOANS
FLEXIBLE WORK ARRANGEMENTS
HISTORIC REGULATORY RELIEF
LIABILITY PROTECTIONS TAMING
THE MET THE MENACE OF PAGA.
THESE COMMON SENSE IDEAS WHICH
COULD DO SO MUCH GOOD FOR SO
MANY PEOPLE AT A TIME OF SUCH
PERIL WERE NOT INCLUDED IN THE
BUDGET. AND DIDN'T EVEN RECEIVE
A FORUM FOR PUBLIC INPUT OR
THOUGHTFUL CONSIDERATION. THE
SECOND IMPERATIVE WE FACE
CONCERNS THE STATE'S FINANCES.
GRAPPLING WITH WHAT COULD BE A
FIFTY FOUR BILLION DOLLAR
DEFICIT A GOOD PLACE TO START
WOULD HAVE BEEN THE HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS WE'VE ADDED TO
THE BUDGET. OVER THE LAST
DECADE. STRIKINGLY ALL OF THIS
ADDED MONEY HAS PRODUCED LITTLE
DISCERNIBLE SOCIAL BENEFIT.
DESPITE SIXTY FOUR BILLION AN
ADDITIONAL MEDI CAL SPENDING
RESEARCHERS AT THE NATIONAL
BUREAU OF ECONOMIC RESEARCH DID
NOT DETECT SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENTS IN PATIENT HEALTH.
AFTER THIRTY NINE BILLION
DOLLAR INCREASE IN EDUCATION
SPENDING THE NATIONAL
ASSESSMENT OF EDUCATIONAL
PROGRESS FOUND THE CALIFORNIA'S
EIGHTH GRADE MATH AND READING
SCORES CONTINUE TO DECLINE.
WITH SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS MORE
SPENDING ON SOCIAL SERVICES THE
CENSUS BUREAU REPORTS
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO HAVE
THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF POVERTY IN
THE NATION. THREE BILLION
DOLLAR RISING CORRECTIONAL
SPENDING HAS ACCOMPANIED A
10000% DECLINE IN THE INMATE
POPULATION. AND IT JUST THE
CLASS TWO YEARS WE SPENT TWO
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
MORE ON HOMELESSNESS ONLY TO
SEE THIS WORST IN THE NATION
TRAGEDY GET MUCH WORSE WE
TALKED A LOT. ABOUT HOW MUCH
MONEY WE'RE SPENDING WE TALKED
VERY LITTLE ABOUT THE VALUE OF
THAT SPENDING. WHETHER IT'S
ACTUALLY REACHING THE
CALIFORNIANS WHO NEED IT RATHER
THAN JUST PROPPING UP POWERFUL
INTERESTS IN DIFFERENT SECTORS
SECTORS AND THAT DISTINCTION
BETWEEN SPENDING MONEY. AND
SPENDING MONEY WISELY REALLY
MATTERS IT'S NOT A ONE
CHRISTIAN MATTER FOR BUDGET
HAWKS IT REALLY MATTERS ON A
HUMAN LEVEL. IT'S THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A SMALL
BUSINESS REMAINING THE HEART OF
A COMMUNITY OR CLOSING ITS
DOORS PERMANENTLY. BETWEEN A
YOUNG PERSON GOING OFF TO
COLLEGE OR DROPPING OUT OF
SCHOOL. BETWEEN A PERSON
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
TURNING THEIR LIFE LIFE AROUND
OR DYING ON OUR STREETS. THAT
IS THE GRAVITY OF THE BUDGET
PROCESS. AND THIS YEAR MORE
THAN EVER REPORT SHOULD HAVE
PULLED US STRONGLY TOWARDS
SMART AND COMPASSIONATE CHOICES.
BUT I WILL CLOSE WITH A WORD OF
ENCOURAGEMENT LIKE MY COLLEAGUE
FROM BIG BEAR I WAS VERY GLAD
TO SEE- THE LEGISLATURE TAKING
THE GOVERNOR TO TASK IN
IMPORTANT WAYS- ON HIS ATTEMPTS
TO AMASS A GREATER AUTHORITY IN
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH AT OUR
EXPENSE. AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE
A LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP IN THE
NEGOTIATIONS THAT LIE AHEAD TO
HOLD FAST TO THAT POSITION AND
DIE IN THE I TO HEED THE ADVICE
OF OUR LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S TO
YOU DOES THAT LESLIE GUARD THE
LEGISLATURE'S CONSTITUTIONAL
AUTHORITY. THERE WAS KELLY
MISTER COOPER. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
MEMBERS SPEAKERS MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS EXCUSE ME WELL I THINK
MR TING IN BUT STAFFER FOR
DOING THAT A HARD JOB IT'S A
TOUGH BUDGET IS A SUB TO YOU
SEE THEIR WORK DAY IN AND DAY
OUT AND- THERE'S THINGS YOU
LIKE ABOUT THIS BUDGET THINGS
WE DO MUST INCLUDE BUT ONE
THING. WE NEED ON MY COLLEAGUES
THE HEALTH RELIGIOUS BLACK
CAUCUS SPOKE ABOUT- EARLIER THE
VINCE SEE NINETY NASH IS GOING
ON AT ALL WORSE. IT IS LAW
TRAINING WE WANTED TO THINGS IN
MAY IT BETTER BUT YOU CAN'T DO
THAT GETTING BY ON THE CHEAP
AND THAT'S WHAT PART IS DOES
WITH PIECE OFF TRAINING IN THE
BUDGET IT IS THE DISTANCE. SO
WE TALK ABOUT HOW WE CHANGE
THINGS THE IMPORTANT THINGS IN
THIS BUDGET WE TALK ABOUT DE
ESCALATION FOR THAT NATION WHY
TALK ABOUT IMPLICIT BIAS IN
RACIAL PROFILING FOR THAT OVER
AND OVER AGAIN COMMUNITY
POLICING CULTURAL DIVERSITY WE
TALK ABOUT THOSE VIGNETTE.
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE OUR OFFICERS
TRAINED ON DISTANCE. ON IT WERE
YOU GO THROUGH AND CLICK. BUT
LET'S FACE. THAT'S WE WILL IT
WILL IT WILL SEE BUT SINCE THE
PAYING ATTENTION GET MUCH MORE
OUT OF IT BECAUSE WHEN YOU'RE
ON THE ON THE BY IN THE MAIL
YOU CAN YOU LIVE WITH THE TECH
TALK ON THE- SO IT'S REALLY NOT
GOOD TO FOR ALL. TO DO HE WON
BETTER OFF YOU GOT IN ON IT YOU
WANT TO CHANGE THE NARRATIVE
AND BY DOING LEARNING WE DO THE
PUBLIC THE SERVICE. WE ALSO DO.
ARE STILL THE CAN. THOSE
OFFICERS SERVICE. SO IT WILL
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE FOR THIS.
THIS SO. TO CHIU. IN THEIR- IT
STARTS WITH. THIS IS PRETTY
SIMPLE TRAINING. BECAUSE IF
YOU'RE MOST PEERS IN CALL THE-
OF DIFFERENT RACE. DIFFERENT
SEXES. YOU CAN HEAR THERE'S-
AND MUCH MORE. THAN SITTING AT
HOME. IN YOUR OFFICE. CLICKING
THAT BY. OVER IN AGAIN WITH THE
SUPPORT. IT MAKES NO SO. BUSH
WITH WHAT'S ON TODAY. AND IN TO
CHANGE OTHER. IF YOU'RE THIS
BUDGET AS IT IS IN WE DO THIS
TRAINING. IT DOES NOTHING TO
CHANGE THE SITUATION FIND
OURSELVES IN NOW IF YOU WANT TO
CHANGE IT GONNA BE CHANGE
OVERALL. THIS IS A BIG PART OF
IT. TRAININGS FOR TO FOREMOST
TO CHANGE THE NARRATIVE. THERE
WAS COOPER MISS GARCIA IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I WANT I'M
ALWAYS SO HARD WORK BETTER. I
CHAIR HAS DONE WITH THE LIMIT
I'M IN. AND A LACK OF REAL
INFORMATION ABOUT THE REVENUE
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE GENERATING
THIS YEAR- AND BECAUSE WE HAVE.
LIMITED INFORMATION WE KNOW
THAT THE LEGALIZATION THEY'RE
GOING TO BE GOING ON- THROUGH
THE NEXT FEW MONTHS THAT WE'RE
HERE IN SESSION. WITH THAT I
WANT TO BRING UP A COUPLE
POINTS ARE IMPORTANT TO MY
DISTRICT BUT JUST TO
COMMUNITIES COLOR IN GENERAL AS
WE CONTINUE WITHIN. I THINK THE
BUDGET CAR ONLY REPRESENTS OUR
COMMITMENT TO OUR COMMUNITIES.
I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT A FEW
POINTS WHERE WILL BEGIN TO HAVE
THAT COMMITMENT HERE AND THEN.
AND GOVERNOR OFFICE. FIRST OF
ALL AS WE DISCUSSED EDUCATE.
FUND THE AVERAGE. TO LOOK AT IT
LIKE THAT. LANCE I EQUITY. AND
I QUALITY. WE KNOW THAT IF
YOU'RE BLACK OR STEVEN. YOU
DON'T START IN THE SAME THAT AS
YOU MIGHT CAO. AND BECAUSE IN
NINETEEN THAT'S ONLY ME LIKE A
BROWN KIDS FOR THEIR BE.
STUDENTS FROM LOW INCOME. HAVE
A STORE CONFERENCE AT A TO. AND
EDUCATION GAPS. BETWEEN
THEMSELVES AND WHITE COUNTY.
ACCORDING TO MY CAN SEIZE. PRE
COVERT THE AVERAGE BLACK
HISPANIC MAY ROUGHLY YEARS WE-
THE AVERAGE WHITE ONE AND LOW
INCOME CITIZENS TO BE ON THE
RIVER A TOP. AND BECAUSE THE
COLD AND CAN TAKE BRIDGE THAT
BLACK STUDENTS WILL FURTHER
WILL FALL FOR THE BAHAI THE
PHONE TEMP. BLACK AND BROWN
KIDS SO THEY REALLY HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO REACH HER TRUE
POTENTIAL LIKE THE RIGHT KIND.
AND WHILE WE MAKE SOME CUTS. I
WOULD WITH OUR BY CLOSING THE
LOOPHOLE. THAT ALLOW HOMES WILL
CHARGE THE PAPER TO DISNEY.
LEGAL FOR RIDING. UNDER THE
PRIEST OF EDUCATION ENRICHMENT.
IT'S A WHOLE TEAM WE INSURE
COMMUNITY. WE CAN ANSWER SCHOOL
THINK REYES MINE CAN CLOSE THE
DID DIVIDE. WE CAN INSURE
COMMITTEES OF MY LIKE MY
CONTINUE BE THERE. FOUR HUNDRED
A REGULAR BASIS. AND SO AS WE
THINK ABOUT EQUITY I WILL BE
THINK ABOUT CLOSING THE
LOOPHOLE FIRST. SECOND AS WE
CONTINUE TO DISCUSS CARE. I BE
CONTINUE TILL AT IT WOULD AN
EQUITY LANCE. MAKING HAS BEEN
READ MICHAEL BUT NINETY. FOR
THE NINETEEN HAS FOR THE
MAGNIFY THE VISUAL RECEBER AND
I'LL HARKIS STUFF WE CAN'T TO
IGNORE THEM FOR TO THE- OF.
HEALTH THE NORTH MORE QUE THAN
I OTHER BE GROUPS MY ABOUT
AFRICAN IN. MAKE UP ON SIX FOR.
OF THE POPULATION BUT THEY
NEARLY TECH TEN OF THE THAT. WE
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS RALLY
COUNTY THE CITY OF A LOT OF MY
IN AFTER ONE OF THE. THESE
COMMUNITIES FIRST AND IS THAT
THE MOST IMPACTED WE DON'T JUST
SAY THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
DOING EQUAL CUTS ACROSS THE
BOARD BECAUSE IT'S VERY AN
EQUITABLE AND I'M FREE TO
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE THAT
OCCURRED ARE. BEING BURDEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY MICHAEL THAT.
AND IF YOU THINK OF HEALTH CARE
WILL HAVE TO BE THINKING ABOUT
THEIR THAT WE BREATHE. AND THE
REALITY IS THAT A LOT OF FOLKS
ARE DATING MY COMMUNITY. NOT
JUST COULD BECAUSE WE LACK
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE. BUT
BECAUSE WE'RE CONSTANTLY THE-
REALLY BAD HARMFUL AIR OUT
THERE. AND SO WE KNOW THAT
BROWN AND BLACK PEOPLE ARE MORE
LIKELY TO HAVE BEEN LIVE IN
HIGHLY POLITICAL- COMMUNITIES.
REFLECT RECENT HARVARD STUDY.
THE PEOPLE THAT CALL IN
NINETEEN WHO LIVE IN THE U. S.
REGIONS WITH THE HIGHEST LEVEL
OR POLLUTION. I'M MORE LIKELY
TO DIE FROM THE DISEASE THAT
PEOPLE WHO LIVE AND LESS
POLLUTED AREAS. WITH THE CITY
OF THE LORD AT NEW THAT'S IN
THE 5% MOST POLLUTED. AIR OF
THE STATE IT'S REALLY SCARY.
COMPOUNDING IT ALREADY- ON.
OVER BURDEN AND MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY. AND SO
WE WILL CONTINUE TO INVEST IN
PROGRAMS LIKE AV SIX SEVENTEEN
WHICH IDENTIFY HOT HOT THE
POLLUTION AND CREATE COMMUNITY
DRIVEN ACTION PLANS. THIS YEAR
WE ARE MAKING A MODEST
INVESTMENT IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT PROGRAM
BUT THE REALITY IS THAT WHEN
YOU START LOOKING FOR TO STAY
NOBLE STORES OF FUNDING I
THOUGHT A CAP AND TRADE TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE REALLY
LOOKING AT COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
INTO THEM EQUITABLY. OF IN
NINETEEN HAS SIMPLY MAGNIFIED
THE URGENCY TO FIX A PROBLEM
THAT HAS BEEN ALL MY LIFE.
THIRTY SECONDS. AND I ALSO WANT
TO REMIND FOLKS THAT WE MUST
REFORM THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOPICS. AND WE'RE DOING THAT
SLOWLY BUT I HOPE AFTER ALL
THESE YEARS WE- HURRY UP AND WE
DID A LITTLE BIT QUICKER WE
HAVE AB NINE NINE FIVE IN THE
SENATE. THAT IS THE NEGOTIATED
FOR FOUR YEARS. SUPPORT FROM
BOTH INDUSTRY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE. WITHOUT THEIR AND HAS
BEEN PRIVATIZED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION YET. THIS IS THE
TIME THAT WE'RE GONNA STAY.
THAT WE MATTER THAT COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR MATTER. THEN I PLEDGE
ANY TO REFLECT THAT IS AS WE
MOVE FORWARD IN THE
NEGOTIATIONS. I HOPE YOU
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT EQUITY-
HOLD AND HOW WE RAISE REVENUE
AND WE SPEND THAT AND HOW WE
MAKE UP. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER. MS WALDRON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. IN
EXPLAINING WHY WE CANNOT
SUPPORT THIS BUDGET SOME
MEMBERS OF OUR CAUCUS HAVE VERY
SPECIFIC CONCERNS WITH THE
VARIOUS LINE ITEMS IN THIS
NEARLY THOUSAND PAGE DOCUMENT.
MY COLLEAGUES ARE RIGHT THAT
THIS BUDGET CONTAINS SOME VERY
PROBLEMATIC ELEMENTS INCLUDING
CONTINUING TO FUND THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL PROJECT. TENS OF
MILLIONS FOR THE ENFORCEMENT OF
THE HARMFUL AB FIVE
LEGISLATION. FAILING TO ADDRESS
THE CRITICAL ISSUES THAT CAME
TO LIGHT IN COLVIN REGARDING
SAFETY IN A CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES. END OF COURSE
SPENDING CUTS THAT WILL
SUBSTANTIALLY WEAKEN OUR HEALTH
CARE INFRASTRUCTURE AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY ACCESS TO CARE. THE
BUDGET ALSO CONTAINS LAUDABLE
COMPONENTS INCLUDING SOME
PROTECTIONS FOR SENIORS AND THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
RESTORING OPTIONAL MEDI CAL
SERVICES PROTECTING THE STATE
HIGHWAY ACCOUNT AND INVESTING
IN CALIFORNIA'S HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS. WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO
FOCUS ON IS THE BROKEN PROCESS
THAT HAS LED US TO THIS BUDGET.
UNTIL TODAY NOT A SINGLE VOTE
WAS TAKEN ON THIS BUDGET THERE
WERE NO SUBCOMMITTEE VOTE NO
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE. ONLY
TOKEN PRO FORMA PUBLIC INPUT
WITH US WAS ALLOWED AND WHEN IT
WAS SPEAKERS WILL RUST AND
ENDED UP FRUSTRATED. MEMBERS OF
THIS BODY AND THE MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIA'S WE REPRESENT OR
OUT OF THE PROCESS BEFORE THIS
MOMENT FOR EXAMPLE. OUR
LEGISLATIVE MEMBERS HAD FOUR
MINUTES THAT WE COULD PRESENT
ISSUES OF CONCERN ESPECIALLY
FROM. OUR CONSTITUENTS. A SO
WHAT WE SAW WAS. THAT ON BEHALF
OF HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE WE REPRESENT WE CLEARLY
DIDN'T HAVE A VOICE. THIS IS
NOT HOW DEMOCRACY SHOULD
OPERATE FOR THE MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE BEING SHOT
OUT OF THE PROCESS ARE YOUR
JOURNAL FULL. AMOS WATER MISTER
COOLEY YOUR RECOGNIZED IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER. COLLEAGUES
I. AM PLEASED TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. I FIND IT
INTERESTING YOU KNOW I STARTED
MY CAREER IN THIS BILL IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN. I'VE
SEEN MANY A DOWNTURN COME AND
GO LAWMAKERS GOVERNOR'S
FIGHTING A CALAMITOUS TIME THIS.
JERRY BROWN DEUKMEJIAN A
HUNDRED DAY DELAY IN PASSING A
BUDGET. IT WILL SERVE. YOU KNOW
THESE ARE NOT THE VOTES ACTION
WHERE WE WANT TO BE HERE. AND
WHEN I REFLECT UPON THIS BUDGET
THIS CALAMITOUS FALL IN
REVENUES THIS NEED TO RESPOND.
I ACTUALLY RECALL. YEAH WE'VE
HAD OTHER BUDGETS. IN TIMES OF
RISING REVENUE. AND WE STAND
AROUND AND TALK ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF OUR DEMOCRATIC
VALUES. AND IT'S EASY TO STAND
UP FOR THAT AND PASSED THAT ONE
REVENUES ARE SURE G. I JUST SEE
A BUDGET LIKE THIS IS A TIME
WHEN. IF YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT. YOU
END UP ASKING CELLS IN MY
PREPARED TO BE ALL IN ON MY
DEMOCRATIC VALUES. DO WE
BELIEVE. THAT EVEN IN HARSH
FINANCIAL TIMES. DOING WHAT WE
CAN WERE INVEST IN THE LIVES OF
CALIFORNIANS THE DISADVANTAGED
THE AT RISK. THE FOSTER YOUTH I
WEAR MY AFTER YOUTH RIBBON
TODAY BECAUSE JUNE. DO WE
BELIEVE THAT INVEST IN THESE
LIVES IS THE BEST STEP WE CAN
TAKE. TO ENSURE THE AS WE GO
THROUGH THIS TIME OF TROUBLE.
THE CALIFORNIA BE STRENGTHENED
COMING OUT OF THE. THE PRAYER
TODAY TALKED ABOUT PLANET
GREENER SEAT IN HAVING A-
OUTSTANDING YIELD. AND I DO
THINK THERE IS NO ALTERNATIVE.
WHEN THINGS SEEM IN SUCH DIRE
CONDITION. TO PLOD AWAY AND
INVEST IN THE LIVES OF THOSE
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE MOST AT
RISK. AND DEPEND UPON WHAT WE
ARE ABLE TO BRING FORWARD
COPPING TOGETHER AS BUDGET. FOR
THE LONGEST TIME IN PUBLIC LIFE
I'VE ALWAYS LIKED WHAT THE
PROFFER AS A HAD TO SAY ABOUT
WHERE THERE'S A GOOD KING. I J.
THIRTY TWO IT CAME WILL ROTH
RIGHTEOUS AND EVERY PERSON.
SHALL BE LIKE STREAMS OF WATER
IN THE DESERT LIKE TO SHADOW OF
A GREAT ROCK IN A WEARY LAND.
IT IS A VERY ODD PICKED. UP TO
THINK THAT. LEADERSHIP CAN BE
REFLECTED IN A ROCK ON THE
LANDSCAPE. IT JUST GETS THE SUN
BEATING THE HECK OUT OF IT. BUT
BECAUSE IT'S TAKING THAT HE TO
CREATE SAFE SPACE. THIS TO ME
IS A SIMILE. OF WHERE WE ARE
TODAY THE ECONOMY IS THAT HARSH
SUN. BEATING ON PEOPLE INTO IN
OUR REVENUES. AND HOW WE
INTERPOSE THE BULK OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA SPENDING TO MAKE
SAFE PLACE FOR PEOPLE I THINK
THAT IS THE MOMENT ANDI
ACTUALLY DO BELIEVE WE NEED TO
FOCUS. ON BEING ALL IN ON
DEMOCRATIC VALUES STAND UP FOR
PEOPLE OF MOST AT RISK OTHER
PEOPLE HAVE MORE ACCESS TO
CAPITAL HAVE MORE ABILITY TO
ABSORB SHOCK AND WORK THINGS
THROUGH. BUT THERE ARE PEOPLE
WHO ARE VERY MUCH ON THE MARGIN
AND I THINK THAT'S WHERE NEED
TO BE AND I APPRECIATE THE WORK
HAS BEEN DONE IN THIS TO MORE
WHICH IS UNLIKE ANYTHING ANY OF
US HAVE SEEN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU MISTER COLLEY
MISTER BRO. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
MEMBERS IF YOU'D LIKE TO BE
RECOGNIZED PLEASE RAISE YOUR
MICROPHONES NOW MISTER BRO YOUR
RECORD. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I FIRST WANT TO THANK
OUR CHAIR FROM SAN FRANCISCO OR
VICE CHAIR FROM BIG BEAR AND
ALL THE STAFF THAT WORKED ON
THIS FRAMEWORK. I SAT THROUGH
ALL THE SUB COMMITTEE HEARINGS
IN THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
HEARINGS GOING BACK TO APRIL
TWENTIETH. HEARING FROM THE LA-
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AND REALLY NO ONE HAD A LOT OF
ANSWERS IT WAS A LOT OF
SPECULATION SO. I UNDERSTAND
THIS FRAMEWORK TODAY IS A
SNAPSHOT IN TIME- AND THAT'S
NOT DUE TO ANYBODY'S FAULT. AND
I BELIEVE THAT WERE REALLY
HERE- TO MEET THE
CONSTITUTIONAL DEADLINE. AND I
DO BELIEVE THAT WE WILL KNOW
MORE AFTER THE JULY FIFTEEN TAX
DEADLINE TO SEE WHAT REVENUES.
COME INTO THE STATE AND THIS
MAY BE A YEAR US ARE. CALLING
FROM CENTER FELL SAID MULTI
BUDGET YEAR- WE MAY HAVE AN
AUGUST THROUGH THE IN THIS
YEAR- I'M GONNA BE A NO TODAY
JUST BECAUSE OF THE INCREASE IN
TAXES ON ALL BUSINESSES. BUT I
I'M FIRMLY BELIEVE WILL BE BACK
CHARTER OUR PENCILS A- THANK
PRO MISS. YOUR RECORD ASSN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THE
COLLEAGUES TODAY I RISE
SOMEWHAT NERVOUSLY BECAUSE OF
CIRCUMSTANCES AND CONSEQUENCES
THAT I MIGHT FACE OUTSIDE OF
THIS ROOM AFTER TAKING THIS
VOTE TODAY. BUT AS WE ALL DID
WE GET INTO PUBLIC SERVICE FOR
A REASON. AND FOR MY BEFORE MY
TIME HERE I SPENT NINE YEARS ON
THE RECEIVING END OF SOME
PRETTY BAD BUDGET YEARS AND
DECISIONS THAT WERE MADE IN
THIS ROOM. AS A SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER. WE'RE LITERALLY WE
PENCILLED OUR SOLUTIONS DOWN TO
THE NICKEL. TO KEEP STAFF ON
PAYROLL TO KEEP CUTS ON
CLASSROOMS. AND TO CONTINUE OUR
OBLIGATION TO THE COMMUNITY AND
TO THE FAMILIES THAT WE SERVE.
AS I PUZZLED THROUGH THIS
DECISION ABOUT TODAY AND HOW IT
AYE REPROACH THIS REALLY
IMPORTANT WORK THAT WE'RE ALL
INVESTED IN HERE TOGETHER. IT
REALLY COMES DOWN TO VALUES. SO
I'D LIKE TO START BY SAYING I
AM GRATEFUL TO THOSE OF YOU WHO
PLACED A VALUE ON SAVINGS. IN
PRIOR LEGISLATIVE SESSIONS.
THAT ARE PROVIDED A RAINY DAY
FUND FOR US TO DRAW FROM. TO BE
ABLE TO BALANCE THE NEEDS OF
OUR PUBLIC. IN THIS MOMENT OF
CRISIS AND TO KEEP CUTS FROM
BEING AS EXTREME AS THEY MIGHT
HAVE OTHERWISE BEEN. I AM
GRATEFUL FOR THAT. WE VALUE A
BALANCED BUDGET IN CALIFORNIA
IS NOT ONLY REQUIRED OF US BUT
WE KNOW THE IMPORTANCE OF NOT
IN DOWN DEBT. TO THE
GENERATIONS WHO COME AFTER THE
US AND THAT IS EQUALLY
IMPORTANT. AND AS THE
OPPOSITION HAS RISEN AND SAID I
DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS AS A
MEMBER. ABOUT PROCESS IN THIS
BODY. AND I REGRET THAT I WON'T
BE HERE IN FUTURE SESSIONS TO
SPEAK TO THAT. BECAUSE I DO
THINK THERE IS MORE WORK WE
COULD DO TO BE DELIVERED OF.
ABOUT CUTS WE CAN MAKE AN ABOUT
GROWTH TO GOVERNMENT THAT IS
MEANINGFUL AND WORTHWHILE AND
WORTH THE INVESTMENT. BUT
FINALLY IN TAKING THIS VOTE.
THE REASON THAT I GOT INTO
GOVERNMENT TO BEGIN WITH. WAS
TO DO THE GREATEST AMOUNT OF
GOOD. FOR THE GREATEST NUMBER
OF PEOPLE. WITH THE RESOURCES
THAT WE HAVE AT HAND. I THINK
THIS BUDGET REFLECTS THAT. I
KNOW IT IS A CHALLENGE FOR MANY
OF US. BUT TODAY I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BUDGET FOR THAT
REASON THANK YOU. DAVIS WITH
MISS RACE IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. THIS IS DEMOCRACY.
THIS IS WHAT I LOVE ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE DOING HERE TODAY. IS THAT
WE HAVE NUMBERS THAT ARE THE
NUMBERS THAT WE WERE EXPECTING
BEFORE. THANK GOODNESS WE HAD A
RAINY DAY FUND THAT WAS SET
ASIDE. FOR SUCH A DAY IS THIS.
AND I THINK OUR CHAIRMAN OF
FINANCE ARE CHAIRED BUDGET. FOR
ALL THE WORK THAT HAS BEEN PUT
INTO THIS. WE JUST EXPERIENCE
THE EFFECTS OF A PANDEMIC
SOMETHING WE'VE NEVER HAD TO
SEE BEFORE. WE ALSO ASKED
CALIFORNIA ASTOR BUSINESSES TO
CLOSE DOWN TO FLATTEN THE
CURVE. SOMETHING WE'VE NEVER
DONE BEFORE. AND WE'VE SEEN
DEATH. LIKE WE'VE NEVER SEEN
BEFORE. THERE BEEN COMMENTS
ABOUT THE PROCESS ITSELF. I
APPRECIATE THAT EVEN WITH THIS
SHORTENED PROCESS. OUR OUR
CHAIR WAS AVAILABLE TO US.
QUESTIONS WERE ANSWERED TO THE
BEST OF HIS ABILITY I THINK OUR
VICE CHAIR FIRST COMMENTS AS
WELL I APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
YOU TALK ABOUT THAT THEIR VOICE
SURE TALKS ABOUT TO THE
POSITIVES OF THIS BUDGET. EVEN
IF THE END RESULT IS NOT GOING
TO BE WHAT THE REST OF US WHAT.
WHAT I WOULD WANT TO. IT'S NOT
AN EASY BUDGET THE CUTS THE
DEFERRALS REJECTIONS SUMMER
POSITIVE AS MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
NOTED SOMEONE NEGATIVE AS SOME
OF YOU HAVE HAVE HAVE NOTED.
I'M THANKFUL FOR THE LEADERSHIP
OF THIS BODY AND IN THE SENATE
AS WELL. GLAD THAT AS I
MENTIONED THAT WE HAVE THE
LARGEST RAINY DAY RESERVE
SIXTEEN BILLION IN OUR STATE'S
HISTORY. LARGER THAN THE ENTIRE
BUDGET OF MANY STATES IN OUR
NATION. LAST YEAR I INTRODUCED
AB FIFTEEN NINETY THREE TO
EXPAND THE CALIFORNIA EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT TO
IMMIGRANTS. THE FILE WHAT THE
ITUNES NUMBER INDIVIDUAL TAX
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER. THE EITC
IS ONE OF THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE GOVERNMENT TOOLS IT
IS HAS A DIRECT IMPACT ON
PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE TO HELP
LIFT THEM OUT OF POVERTY.
DESPITE ITS SIX NOTED SUCCESS
HOWEVER THERE CRITICAL
POPULATIONS CONTINUE TO BE LEFT
BEHIND. ONE OF WHICH ARE
IMMIGRANTS TO FILE THEIR TAXES
USING AND INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYER
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER. THERE
TAXPAYERS THERE ARE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS THE SPIKE IN
CONTRIBUTING TO OUR LOCAL
ECONOMIES THEY CANNOT ACCESS A
CRITICAL TOOL TO HELP WORK
THEIR WAY OUT OF POVERTY. BUT
I'M GRATEFUL THAT THE BUDGET
THAT WE WILL VOTE ON TODAY
INCLUDES. AN EXPANSION OF THE
EYE TO SEE THE FAMILIES OF FILE
WITH I TUNES WITH CHILDREN
UNDER SIX YEARS OF AGE. IT'S A
MAJOR STEP MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. BUT AS I NOTED AT
THE BEGINNING. IN THE END THIS
IS DEMOCRACY DEMOCRACY
OFTENTIMES IS DIFFICULT. TIMES
LIKE THESE MAKE OUR DECISIONS
EVEN MORE DIFFICULT. BUT IN THE
END WE MUST DO WHAT IS BEST FOR
THE MAJORITY OF THE PEOPLE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHO
DEPEND ON US TO MAKE THE RIGHT
DECISION AS DIFFICULT AS IT MAY
BE. I DO NOT VOTE TODAY. TAKE
HIS RESPONSIBLE PARTY YOUR
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THIS IS AN
UNPRECEDENTED BUDGET BUT IN
REALITY IT'S ON PRESIDENT
RESPONSE TO WHAT WE HAVE BEFORE
US TODAY- WE REALLY DON'T HAVE
A LOT OF GOOD CHOICES AND I'LL
GET TO THAT IN A IN A SECOND
BUT THE BASIS OF THIS IS WE ARE
FORTUNATE TURN OFF OUR ECONOMY.
IN ORDER TO TURN IT BACK ON WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DO
THINGS LIKE PROPERLY FUND OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM FROM EARLY
EDUCATION THROUGH OUR CHILD
CARE CENTERS ALL THE WAY
THROUGH HIGHER EDUCATION A
TODAY IS OF COURSE JUNE
FIFTEENTH IS THE DEADLINE IN
THE CONSTITUTION. TO VOTE ON
THE STATE BUDGET BY THIS
LEGISLATURE AND MAY NOT BE THE
FINAL BUDGET- WE ARE CURRENTLY
NEGOTIATING WITH OUR GOVERNOR
STILL I KNOW OUR BUDGET SHARES
DOING A GREAT JOB ALONG WITH
OUR LEADER IN THE SENATE OUR
SPEAKER PRO TEM IN OUR BUDGET
CHAIR IN THE SENATE. TO COME UP
LEAVE IT. MORE PER. FOR MY TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE STOP THE
BLEEDING AND CALIFORNIA- BACK
TO WORK- AGAIN THIS BUDGET IS
FOCUSEDON MAKING SURE THAT ARE
KEY ELEMENTS OF GOVERNMENT ARE
OPEN FOR BUSINESS. SUCH AS OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS WE DID HAVE TO
MAKE SOME TOUGH CHOICES IN THIS
BUDGET WE HAD TO MAKE SOME CUTS
FROM. PRIOR INVESTMENTS AND
EXPANSIONS OF THINGS LIKE
PRESCHOOL FOR ALL. AND TEACHER
TRAINING PROGRAMS THAT WE
EXPANDED LAST YEAR EVEN THE
JANUARY BUDGET WE HAD TO PULL
BACK TO MAKE SURE WE CAN PROP
UP. THE EXISTING PRIORITIES IN
THE STATE BUDGET. BECAUSE LET'S
FACE IT. IN THIS CALL THE
NINETEEN WORLD. OUR SCHOOLS
PROBABLY NEED MORE TO DO WHAT
THEY'RE DOING. NOT LESS. AND
UNFORTUNATELY IN THE MAY REVISE
WE SAW HERE SCHOOLS WOULD HAVE
BEEN HAVING A 10% COTTON. BASE
FUNDING. AND THAT WOULD HAVE
MADE IT NOT. RELIABLE FOR.
SCHOOL FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS TO
OPEN WHEN MADE SCHOOL BOARDS
HAVE. DECISIONS LAYING OVER THE
DAHLE TEACHER IT THE TOPIC THE
FIGHT THERE IS. A BIG. I THINK
LIKE THE LOWER LOSS OF THE
BUDGET BE US TODAY. RIGHT THIS
IS THE WE NEED TO. UPPER
SCHOOL. MAKE SURE PRESS. SINCE
SOME IT. IT'S RIGHT BEHIND THE
EVEN MORE BE NOW I WILL KNOW
THAT THERE'S BEEN SOME CAN
ABOUT THE FOR ME I RELATE TO
HOW THOSE MONIES GO OUT IN THE
LEARNING LOS BLOCK GRANT- WE
THINK WE HAVE AN APPROACH THAT
MAKES THE MOST SENSE TO IMPACT
ALL SCHOOLS AND FOR THEM I KNOW
THE GOVERNOR HAS IT BRING
OPINION WHERE WE'RE GOING WITH
THAT I MEAN FINANCE. WITH A
SOLUTION THERE. THE LADY TO OUR
AFTER SCHOOL OR ASUS PROGRAMS
AND CHILDCARE PROGRAMS. LET'S
FACE IT IN THE BEST OF TIMES
THESE PROGRAMS ARE HANGING ON.
BY A DEAR THREAD. AND SO HAVING
A 10% CUT IN FUNDING FOR OUR
CHILD CARE AND AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS ARE ACES. WOULD BE-
THE DEATH OF THESE PROGRAMS NOT
ONLY IMPACTS BROWNLEE WOMEN
OWNED BUSINESSES. AND A
LIVELIHOOD OF PEOPLE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA BUT REALLY THROW A
MONKEY WRENCH IN MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE TRYING TO GO
BACK TO WORK. AND SEE WHAT
THEY'RE GONNA DO WHEN THEIR
KIDS WHEN THEY GO BACK TO WORK
SO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE SAY
NO TO THESE CATS WITH HIS
BUDGET. DOES WE HAVE BEEN TOLD
TODAY THAT HIRED CATION MATTERS
AS WELL WE KNOW THAT OUR
ECONOMY IS BUILT UPON A EDUCATE
WORK FOR. OUR OUR BUDGET TRIES
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE KEEP
AFLOAT AT LEAST FOR ONE MORE
YEAR FUND THE UC AND CSU. AT
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE DO
KNOW THAT ALL OF OUR COLLEGES
DOING ON EDUCATION BY WILL I.
TO WHAT DOWN. L. THANKS IT OUT.
ON IS THAT IT THAT'S IT IN THIS.
AND LASTLY I JUST WANT TO TALK
ABOUT. THE NOSE THAT WE ARE.
STEALING THE FUTURE AND THIS
PULLED GIMMICKS CENTRIC. LOOK
WE CAN GO. AND GET IN A- FROM
THE LOCAL TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION. FOR ADOPTING THE
AUSTERITY BUDGET GET A TROPHY
BUT THE CONSEQUENCE OF THAT IS
GOING TO THE CHILD CARE CENTERS
AND SO YOU KNOW WHAT. YOU'RE
SHOT DOWN. GO NEAR LOCAL SCHOOL
FIFTY THOUSAND PINK SLIPS TO
TEACHERS GOING LOCAL AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAM. CAN'T STAY
AFLOAT SO THESE ARE TOUGH
CHOICES IS NOT GONNA MORTGAGE
ARE. PART IN OUR GRANDKIDS FOR
GENERATIONS WERE REALLY DOING
THIS ONE YEAR AT A TIME TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN KEEP THIS
STATE UPLOAD. TO TURN BACK ON
OUR ECONOMY AGAIN THESE THIS IS
ABOUT MAKING TOUGH CHOICES AND
I THINK THE RIGHT CHOICES WE
HAVE HERE TODAY WITH THAT ASK
THE RIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER MCCARTY. THANK YOU
MEMBERS. MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR THE
CHAMP THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS COLLEAGUES I WANT TO
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE FOR SB
SEVENTY FOUR PASSAGE OF OUR
BUDGET IS NEVER ROUTINE THIS
YEAR IT IS AS FAR FROM ROUTINE
AS WE CAN POSSIBLY GET. THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE FIRST
SIXTEEN THE FIRST SIX MONTHS OF
TWENTY TWENTY HAVE MADE RIDING
A BUDGET A MONUMENTAL PUZZLE.
BUT WE HAVE BEEN UP TO THAT
CHALLENGE. WE HAVE MORE OF
ADVERSITY AHEAD HOWEVER. THIS
BUDGET LAYS IT ALL OUT SO THAT
WE CAN BE READY TO ADAPT TO ANY
NEW CHALLENGES THAT COME OUR
WAY. I WANT TO THANK OUR BUDGET
YEAR I WANT TO THANK OUR BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIRS ARE BUDGET
STAFF AND YOU. BECAUSE YOU HAVE
ALL CONTRIBUTED TO THIS BUDGET
AS ALWAYS YOU'VE WRITTEN OUR
PRINCIPLES INTO THIS BUDGET IN
A WAY THAT WILL GUIDE US
THROUGH THE COME THROUGH THE
COMING MONTHS. CONGRATULATIONS
AND THANK YOU FOR ALL THAT
YOU'VE DONE ASK YOUR EYE BUT I
VOTE ON SB SEVENTY FOUR. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. AND MR TANG
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER JUST A
REMINDER TO EVERYONE. AS WE
TALK ABOUT THE BUDGET CUTS AS
IF THEY WOULD ONLY BE
CENTRALIZED HERE IN SACRAMENTO
IN ALL THE OFFICE BUILDINGS
THAT SURROUND THE CAPITAL. THE
MAJORITY OF THE BUDGET ACTUALLY
GOES INTO ALL OUR COMMUNITIES.
THE GOING TO OUR SCHOOLS. THE
GOING TOWARD CHILD CARE CENTERS.
THE GOAL FOR MEDI CAL SO PUTS
TO SUPPORT THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEMS IN EACH OF OUR
COMMUNITY. GOES INTO CAL FRESH
OR CAL WORKS ALL THE CRITICAL
SERVICES. THAT ARE NEEDED. SO
THIS BUDGET WE COULD HAVE DONE
ALL THE DEVASTATING CUTS LIKE
FROM FOLKS HAVE ASKED ABOUT AND
MAYBE THAT WOULD HAVE HELPED
US. WITH WALL STREET. THIS IS
THE BUDGET FOR MAIN STREET.
MAKING SURE THAT THE MONEY
THAT'S NEEDED THERE IS GOING
THERE. WITHOUT I ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE ON SB SEVENTY FOUR. THANKS
FOR STAYING LOCAL OF THE ROLE
MEMBERS. WE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS AT A VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WELL.
THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIXTY ONE KNOWS THIRTEEN. MAIN
BUDGET BILL IS ADOPTED. THE
MEDIA TRIES MIDDLE TO THE
SENATE. WITHOUT OBJECTION
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO THE
SENATE. MEMBERS WEIRD OUT
TAKING UP WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE. SB NINETY SEVEN.
CORPORATE. SENATE BILL NINETY
SEVEN BY THE COMMITTEE- BUDGET
FISCAL REVIEW AN ACCOLADE
EDUCATION FINANCE MAKING
APPROPRIATION OF FOUR TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BE RELATED
TO THE BUDGET MISTER CHANG
IMAGEN OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER SB NINETY SEVEN TO
FRAZIER TING PLEASE PAUSE.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR FUTURE MOTION
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I MOVE
TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE SIXTY
THREE AND SEVEN SEVEN TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING TO TAKE UP
THE BEES SEVENTY SIX IN EIGHTY
FIVE TODAY WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE FOR THE PURPOSE. OF
CONCURRENCE. MISS FOR THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER WITHHOLDING ELSE
CONCERT NATURAL COLOR. MR FLORA
IS WITHHOLDING. IN THIS CASE
MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND MR
TANG SECONDS. ON THE SUSPENSION
OF THE RULES MEMBERS THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE FOR CALL OF
ROLE. MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE AND MISTER
FLORA IS ASKING FOR A NO VOTE.
THIS IS PROCEDURAL. WHICH
CALDERON TESTING FOR NINE. A
MISTER FLORA IS ASKING FOR NO.
ON THE RULES SUSPENSION. CLERK
WILL. CLOSER ROLE TELL YOU BUT
I SIXTY ONE KNOWS FIFTEEN THE
RULES ARE SUSPENDED. MEMBERS
THIS IS WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE. ASSEMBLY BILL. SEVENTY
SIX. CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY SIX BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET MAC RELATED TO EDUCATION
FINANCE TO MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION OF FOUR TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BE RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. MR TAKE YOUR AN
**** THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AB SEVENTY SIX TO FIRST ONE
POINT EIGHT. BILLION DOLLARS
FOR K. TWELVE SCHOOLS AND-
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS FOR OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM IN.
FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN TWENTY A
DISK OF THESE A DEFERRAL THE
CURVE. IN THE CURRENT FISCAL
YEAR IN THE BILL'S NECESSARY SO
THAT WE CAN. PREVENT CUTS FROM
K. THROUGH TWELVE AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE THIS YEAR. WITH ALL
THESE DEFERRALS BEHALF. CUT
SERVICES FOR SCHOOLS THAT WERE
READY DEPENDING ON THIS MONEY.
WOULD HAVE TO BE FORCED TO CUT
SERVICES WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE ON AB SEVENTY
SIX. THANK YOU MISTER MISTER
OVER NINETY ARE RECOGNIZED
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY SIX THIS
BILL APPROPRIATE SEVERAL
BILLION DOLLARS TO BACK FILL
MISSING REVENUE FROM K.
FOURTEEN EDUCATION. IMPORTANT
NOTE COLLEAGUES THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT BACK FEELING
REVENUE FROM THE BUDGET OF
THESE INSTITUTIONS FOR THE
CURRENT FISCAL YEAR IN OTHER
WORDS NINETEEN TWENTY NOT FOR
THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR. THESE
INSTITUTIONS ONLY HAVE SEVERAL
WEEKS LEFT IN THAT FISCAL YEAR
IF WE DON'T TAKE THIS ACTION
THEY'RE GOING TO BE SEVERELY
IMPACTED AND THEY'LL BE IN
FISCAL DISTRESS ALL THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BUT I
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER BRO. SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION ON
THE ITEM. OR CALL THE ROLL
MEMBERS. DESIRE VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. AND WE DID
THE. CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL TIED
ABOUT. AYE AYES SEVENTY EIGHT
NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. AND WITHOUT OBJECTION
IMMEDIATE TRANS. WITHOUT
OBJECTION IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL
TO ENROLLMENT. WITHOUT
REFERENCE THE FILE MEMBERS THIS
IS AB. EIGHTY FIVE. COVERAGE
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY FIVE BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET KNACK
RELATING TO SEE TAXES AND
CHARGES MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
OF FOUR TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BE RELATED TO THE
BUDGET MR TANG A REAGAN OPEN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER A. B.
EIGHTY FIVE IS OUR REVENUES
TRAILER BILL THE TRAILER BILL
INCLUDES TWO MAIN ACTIONS WHICH
WOULD GENERATE FOUR POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. THE FIRST IS A SUSPENSE
NOT OPERATING LOSS DEDUCTIONS
FOR CORPORATIONS THAT HAVE NET
INCOME. OVER ONE MILLION
DOLLARS. AND THEY WOULDN'T BE
ALLOWED TO USE THOSE NET
OPERATING LOSS DEDUCTIONS TO
REDUCE OUR TAXES AND TWENTY
TWENTY. TWENTY TWENTY ONE OR
TWENTY TWENTY TWO HOWEVER THEY
CAN USE THOSE. DEDUCTIONS FROM
THOSE THREE YEARS IN FUTURE
YEARS. AND IN GENERAL. A
TYPICAL CORPORATION IN ORDER TO
GENERATE. A MILLION DOLLARS OF
NET. OPERATING LOSSES. WOULD
HAVE TO BE MAKING GENERALLY
ABOUT FIFTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS
OF GROSS INCOME. IT ALSO LIMITS
TAX CREDITS FOR BUSINESSES
CAN'T CLAIM MORE THAN FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN TAX CREDITS
PER YEAR OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE OR TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. AND SO THESE TAX
CREDITS WHICH REDUCE THE
BUSINESSES TAX. BILL DIRECTLY
ON A DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR BASIS
THE LARGEST BUSINESS TAX CREDIT
IN THIS CATEGORY IS RESEARCH
DEVELOPMENT TAX GROW. WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY AYE VOTE ON A. B.
EIGHTY FIVE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHANG MISTER OBERNOLTE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. MADAM SPEAKER I
RISE IN OPPOSITION AB FIVE
COLLEAGUES THIS TRAILER BILL
WILL INCREASE. TAXES ON
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS BY OVER
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS AND IT
DOES SO IN A PARTICULARLY
PERNICIOUS AN UNFAIR WAY. ONE
OF THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL
IS THAT IT CAPS- TAX CREDITS TO
A MAXIMUM OF FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR ANY INDIVIDUAL
TAXPAYER IN CALIFORNIA. SO LET
ME EXPLAIN. WHAT THAT WOULD BE
AN A METAPHOR. THAT RELATES TO
A TRANSACTION THAT YOU ARE I
MIGHT UNDERTAKE IF YOU'RE
BUYING A PHONE IN YOUR
CONSIDERING. ARE A LESS
EXPENSIVE PHONE IN A MORE
EXPENSIVE PHONE AND YOU SAY YOU
KNOW WHAT I'M GONNA BUY THE
MORE EXPENSIVE PHONE BECAUSE
THERE'S A REBATE THAT THE
MANUFACTURER IS OFFERING YOU
COMPLETE THE TRANSACTION YOU
SPEND YOUR MONEY. AND THEN
LATER THE MANUFACTURE TELLS YOU
YOU KNOW WHAT. WE'VE RESCINDED
THAT REBATE WE'RE SORRY WE'RE
NOT GOING TO SEND YOU THAT
MONEY BUT YOU CAN APPLY FOR IN
A COUPLE OF YEARS THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE DOING. TO CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS CONSIDER THE CASE OF
A MOVIE STUDIO WHO'S MADE THE
DECISION TO FILM IN CALIFORNIA.
EVEN THOUGH COSTS ARE HIGHER
HERE AND SAY THAT THEY FILLED A
MOVIE OR A TELEVISION
COMMERCIAL IN THE FIRST QUARTER
OF THIS YEAR BEFORE THE
SHUTDOWN. WE ARE RETROACTIVELY
TELLING THEM THAT THEY ARE NO
LONGER ELIGIBLE FOR THE MOTION
PICTURE PRODUCTION TAX CREDIT.
COLLEAGUES THAT IS UNFAIR THEY
RELATE RELIED ON THE CURRENT
CALIFORNIA TAX ALL IN GOOD
FAITH AND THEY DESERVE OUR GOOD
FAITH. ANOTHER REALLY TROUBLING
ASPECT OF THIS TRAILER BILL IS
THE SUSPENSION OF THE NET
OPERATING LOSS TAX DEDUCTION.
THIS IS A VERY SIMPLE TAX
DEDUCTION THAT IS DESIGNED TO
ALLOW CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES. TO
EVEN OUT THERE REVENUES IF THEY
HAVE A BAD YEAR IN A GOOD YEAR.
COMMON SENSE IS THAT YOU'D EVER
THOSE TOGETHER FOR THE PURPOSES
OF TAXATION. BUT WE ARE
RETROACTIVELY TELLING
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES THAT THEY
CAN'T DO THAT AND WE'RE DOING
IT IN A YEAR. WHEN THE STATE
GOVERNMENT HAS SHUT DOWN A
LARGER SWATH OF OUR CALIFORNIA
STATE ECONOMY. SO THESE
BUSINESSES ARE HAVING TO PUT AN
ADDITIONAL CAPITAL THIS YEAR
JUST TO KEEP THEIR DOORS OPEN.
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE A NET
OPERATING LOSS THIS YEAR AS A
RESULT OF THE ACTIONS OF THE
STATE. AND WE'RE TELLING THEM
THROUGH THIS ACTION. THAT THEY
ARE UNABLE TO CLAIM THAT LOSS
ON THEIR TAXES NEXT YEAR. THAT
IS NOT ONLY UNFAIR IT IS ON
JUST I URGE A NO VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER O'NEILL TO MISTER
MELLING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN
THE REAR CHAMBER. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS WE ENTER
THIS BUDGET CYCLE WITH MANY
UNKNOWNS THE ACTUAL DEATH AND
LENGTH OF THE RECESSION. YET TO
BE DETERMINED. THE AMOUNT OF
FEDERAL ASSISTANCE FOR
CALIFORNIA YET TO BE DETERMINED.
AND THE SUCCESS OR FAILURE OF A
MAJOR REVISION OF THE CORPORATE
SIDE OF PROP THIRTEEN ON THE
NOVEMBER BALLOT. WHICH IS MAJOR
BUDGET IMPLICATIONS ALSO YET TO
BE DETERMINED. SO I DON'T FULLY
UNDERSTAND. WHY WE ARE BEING
ASKED TO MAKE A THREE YEAR
FISCAL DECISION AND POLICY RD
TAX CREDIT THROUGH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. MY DISTRICT IS THE
BIRTHPLACE ABOUT TECHNOLOGY.
HERE'S WHAT I KNOW ABOUT THESE
COMPANIES MANY ARE WORKING ON
TREATMENTS FOR TOBIN. AND OTHER
LIFE THREATENING DISEASES AND
THESE COMPANIES WILL BE CRUCIAL
TO DRIVING ANY ECONOMIC
RECOVERY IN OUR STATE. SO WHAT
A TIME WHEN TOBIN CONTINUES TO
THREATEN US AND CLEARLY WILL
HAVE A NEED FOR THE LIFE
SCIENCES SECTOR TO BE AN
ECONOMIC ENGINE AND JOB- GOING
FORWARD GENERATING REVENUES TO
BOLSTER OUR STATE BUDGET IN
FUTURE BUDGET YEARS. WHERE WE
CONTEMPLATING A THREE YEAR
PAUSE I WILL SUPPORT THIS
TRAILER TODAY BECAUSE WE NEED
TO SHOW THE FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS FOR THIS YEAR. TO
BALANCE OUR BUDGET AND FIND
CRUCIAL PROGRAMS HOWEVER I
STRONGLY URGE OUR LEADERSHIP
AND THE GOVERNOR. VERY QUICKLY
REVISIT THIS ISSUE ONCE WE KNOW
THE ACTUAL REVENUE PICTURE FOR
TAX YEAR TWENTY TWENTY AFTER
THE JULY FIFTEEN TAX DEADLINE
AND AFTER THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HOPEFULLY TAKES
ACTION ON ADDITIONAL
ASSISTANCE. AND OR STIMULUS SO
WE HAVE A TRUE FEEL FOR THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE CHALLENGE
BEFORE US. IN ANY STATE LEVEL
ECONOMIC RECOVERY OR STIMULUS
CONVERSATIONS TO HAPPEN THIS
SUMMER. MUST INCLUDE A REVIEW
OF THESE TAX POLICIES. TO
ENSURE WE ARE NOT SACRIFICING
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC
COMPETITIVENESS AS WE TRY TO
STIMULATE JOB CREATION AND
RECOVERY. WILL ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE TO ADDRESS THE MEDIA
FISCAL CONCERN I MOST CERTAINLY
URGE MORE CAPRI CONVERSATION.
ONE THAT INCLUDES THE RAPID
RESTORATION OF THE UTILIZATION
OF THIS CREDIT SHOULD THE
CONDITIONS WARRANT. ASPEN I'VE-
THANK YOU MISTER MILLER MISTER
FLORA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I
URGE A NO VOTE ON THIS BILL AND
LARGELY. COUPLE MEMBERS OF
BROUGHT UP IT'S REALLY ABOUT
THE ALREADY HAD TAXATION. ONE
OF THE BIGGEST THINGS WOULD
COME THROUGH THE CODE AND THEN
RECESSION AND IS FOLLOWED THAT.
WE ASK OUR LIFE SCIENCE
INDUSTRY TO CREATE A CURE TO
HELP US WORK THROUGH THAT. BUT
NOW WE'RE GONNA ACTUALLY TAX
THE VERY PEOPLE WE'VE TASK.
WITH HELPING US FIX THIS ISSUE.
AND IT'S FASCINATING TO ME THAT
WE ARE HERE HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION AND PUT IT IN
PERSPECTIVE. LIFE SCIENCE
INDUSTRY EMPLOYEES ABOUT ONE
POINT THREE MILLION OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND DIRECTLY- AT WITH LIFE
SCIENCES AND IN TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY TWO THOUSAND MEMBERS.
WORK IN THE ARE IN THE SECTION
OF THE LIFE SIZE COMMUNITY.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT LIFE
SCIENCE IN OUR INDIE. THIS IS
NOT A BIG MANUFACTURING
WAREHOUSE. THESE ARE TYPICALLY
SMALLER INSTITUTIONS. IF YOU GO
TO MASSACHUSETTS THEY ARE
SALIVATING. FOR CALIFORNIA
COMPANIES TO LEAVE OUR STATE
THEY'RE OPENING THE DOORS FOR
COMPANIES TO MOVE TO THEIR
STATE AND WE'RE GOING TO DOUBLE
DOWN ON TAXING THEM THE VERY
PEOPLE. OUR ASKING THE WERE
POURING THEM TO HELP US FIX
KOBE NINETEEN TO DEVELOP A
VACCINE IN A CURE WELL GUESS
WHAT THANK YOU HERE'S INITIAL
TAX BURDEN I REQUEST
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN OVER.
THEY GIVE US FLORA. SEEING NO
OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE BILL. MR
TANG YOU MAY CLOSE. SPEAKER I
UNDERSTAND WITH MY COLLEAGUES
VOTING FOR REVENUES IS NEVER
VERY EASY. BUT THESE ARE THE
CHOICES THAT WE HAVE TO MAKE IN
THESE VERY TOUGH TIMES. WE
DON'T GENERATE THE FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS IN REVENUE. THEN IT'S A
TWO BILLION DOLLAR HIT FOR K.
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS. AND IF
WE DON'T EDUCATE OUR CHILDREN.
THERE WON'T BE ANY FORTY TWO.
FLOYD AT THESE LIFE SCIENCES
COMPANIES TO BE EMPLOYED THE
TECHNOLOGY. THE OTHER TWO
BILLION DOLLARS WOULD COME AT
THE EXPENSE OF MANY OF OUR
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEMS
SYSTEMS THAT WERE THE BIRTH. OF
THE FLY FOR THE COMPANY WHAT
THE UNIVERSITY I REPRESENT
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO WHICH IS WHERE
GENENTECH FOR START. SO AGAIN
THESE BUDGETS THIS BUDGET IS A
VERY. TOUGH CHOICES WE HAD TO
MAKE. UNPOPULAR DECISIONS. WE
HAD TO MAKE VERY TOUGH CHOICES.
AND WE TRIED TO DO WAS TO
ENSURE. THAT OUR INVESTMENT IN
EDUCATION. OR INVESTMENTS IN
HEALTHCARE. OUR INVESTMENTS IN
THE SERVICES THAT ARE
COMMUNITIES NEED FOR EVERYDAY
LIFE. WILL CONTINUE TO BE MET.
AND WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE- WERE HELPING ALL OF THOSE
FOLKS OUT BOTH FAMILIES THE
NEEDED THE HELP. THE MOST.
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE ON A. B. EIGHTY FIVE.
THANK YOU MICHELLE AND WITH
THAT KIRK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE OUT
EYES FIFTY FIVE KNOWS TWENTY
ONE. THAT MEASURE PASSES IN
WITHOUT OBJECTION IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL TO. SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
WITHOUT OBJECTION IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL TO ENROLLMENT.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE. TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TO TAKE
UP AND A GERMAN IN MEMORY
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS. OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
GREEN CARPET. FOLLOWING MEMBERS
GREATER PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY. MR
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS A YOUNG MANY TIMES ON
THIS FLOOR- YOU REFER TO ME AS
THE GENTLEMAN FROM NECKLACE OR
EAST NECKLACE. A MAN AS YOU
KNOW IT'S A VERY SPECIAL PLACE.
IN MY HEART IS A SPECIAL PLACE
BECAUSE- BECAUSE A REALLY
SPECIAL PEOPLE. LIKE VICKY LEE
HEY MORE. OUR WHO PASSED AWAY
UNEXPECTEDLY ON MARCH NINTH
TWENTY TWENTY. AT THE AGE OF
SEVENTY SEVEN. VICKI WAS A
BELOVED MOM WIFE. GRANDMOTHER
GREAT GRANDMOTHER. BUT WE KNOW
HER BEST AS A MOTHER OF OUR
VERY OWN. DEBRA GRAVERT. CHIEF
OF THE RULES COMMITTEE AND
SHERRY CAME. IN THE SPEAKER'S
OFFICE. TO BE THE MOTHER OF
THOSE TWO LADIES THAT WE KNOW
SO WELL SHE MUST HAVE BEEN.
QUITE A LADY HERSELF. SHE IS
MORE IN A MESS BY MANY
ESPECIALLY HER HUSBAND. DON ARE
A MORE WHO IS HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS WITH US TODAY AND HER.
EXTENDED FAMILY CHILDREN GREAT
GRAND CHILDREN. VICKI WAS BORN
YUBA CITY ON JUNE EIGHTH
NINETEEN FORTY TWO THE VIC AND
HELEN PETS. AT A YOUNG AGE SHE
ACTUALLY BECAME AN ACCOMPLISHED
PROFESSIONAL SKATER. AND HER
NAME CAN EVEN BE FOUND IN THE
WORLD ALMANAC. IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY ONE SHE MARRIED THE
LOVE OF HER LIFE OUR- AND THEY
SHARED A LONG HAPPY MARRIAGE
ROUTED BY DEEP LOVE. AND
RESPECT FOR EACH OTHER. VICKI
WAS ALWAYS CONFIDENT AND
BEAUTIFUL. SHE WAS A SOCIAL
BUTTERFLY THAT BEFRIENDED
EVERYONE SHE MET. SHE WAS
CALLED SUSIE. GAMMA AND GIGI.
AND MOM BY COUNTLESS PEOPLE
BECAUSE OF HER NURTURING AND
COMFORT AND COMFORT IN NATURE.
SHE WAS DESCRIBED BY FRIENDS
AND FAMILY AS SOMEONE WHO WAS A
RAY OF SUN OF SUNSHINE. AND
THAT IS VERY TRUE. VICKI WAS
SOMEONE WHO WOULD GIVE SMALL
ACTS OF KINDNESS EVEN TO THOSE
THAT SHE ONLY KNEW MY
ACQUAINTANCE SHE HAD NEVER MET.
A STRANGER. SHE WAS
ENTHUSIASTIC AND ALWAYS
CHEERFUL. JUST FROM SEEING HER
YOU WOULD HAVE A SMILE ON YOUR
FACE. VICKI WAS MOST PROUD OF
HER CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN
WAS AN INTEGRAL PART OF THE OF
THE LIVES OF THOSE. AROUND HER.
SHE WAS DESCRIBED AS THE HUB OF
THEIR FAMILY. AND ON A PERSONAL
NOTE I WANT TO SAY THAT. THE
INTERACTION THAT I HAD WITH
VICKI WERE ALWAYS. VERY MUCH
THE SAME THAT YOU WOULD ALWAYS
LEAVE THAT CONVERSATION. YOUR
FEELING A BETTER PERSON SHE WAS
ALWAYS VERY THOUGHTFUL I CAN
RECALL COMING OUT OF THE POST
OFFICE AND NICOLAS WHICH IS
KIND OF A HUB. IN THE TOWN. AND
VICKI'S CAR PASSED ME BY. AND
SHE ALL OF A SUDDEN SHE STOPPED
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE STREET
TURNED AROUND- CAME BACK AND
SAID HEY I NEED ONE YOUR SIGNS.
WHEN I WAS CAMPAIGNING. AND.
VERY SPECIAL TO ME SHE ACTUALLY.
GAVE ME A PICTURE HER FATHER
VIC PITS WAS A- GREAT GUY
AMAZING BASEBALL PLAYER IN THE
AREA HE HAD A AND HE HAD ONE OF
THE GREAT BASEBALL HANS IN THE
CITY OF MARYSVILLE THE EAGLES
NEST WHERE. MY GRANDFATHER MANY
OTHER BALL PLAYERS WOULD MEET
UP AFTER AFTER GAMES OF THE
MARYSVILLE GIANTS AND YUBA CITY
BEARS. AND VICKY ALWAYS A
THOUGHTFUL PERSON THAT SHE WAS
ON. A GAVE ME A PICTURE OF HER
DAD AND MY GRANDFATHER AND-
THAT I STILL HAVE UP ON MY WALL
THAT I KEEP TO THIS VERY DAY.
THOSE ARE JUST SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT THAT SHE WOULD DO
AND SHE WOULD DO THAT FOR A
GRAND KIDS AND FOR HER FAMILY.
EXTENDED FAMILY. SHE WAS THE
CENTER OF THE A CENTER OF LOVE-
MISTER TODAY WE CELEBRATE HER
VERY SPECIAL LIFE- THAT HAS
IMPACTED. CERTAINLY MANY IN THE
COMMUNITY OF NICHOLAS AND- AN
EXTENDED OUT FURTHER THAN THAT
BUT IS EVEN IMPACTED US HERE.
BECAUSE OF HER TWO AMAZING
DAUGHTERS THAT SERVE- AND THIS
GREAT BODY WITH ALL OF US AND
SO TODAY ASK MEMBERS THAT WE
ADJOURN- IN THE LOVING MEMORY
OF VICKI LEE. HEY MORE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER.
THANK YOU MEMBERS. MEMBERS WE
ARE BACK ON THE FILE. ON
RECONSIDERATION FILE ITEMS ONE
THROUGH FOUR ARE TO BE
CONTINUED.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT
THE TOP OF THE THIRD READING
FILE. THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY THREE.
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN SIXTY THREE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
ACCOLADES THE BUDGET ACT TWENTY
TWENTY MISTER CHANG THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY THREE IS A BUDGET BILL.
TRADITIONALLY WE WERE SUPPOSED
TO DO THIS IN MARCH RIGHT
BEFORE WE RECESS WE DID NOT
HAVE A CHANCE TO EXCHANGE OF
BUDGET BILLS WITH THE SENATE SO
OUR E. P. A. B. A. B. EIGHTEEN
SIXTY THREE ALL THE WAY TO A BI
NATIONAL TO. ARE THE BUDGET
BILLS THAT WE ARE SWAPPING WITH
THE SENATE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE ON A. B. C. EIGHTEEN
SIXTY THREE. THEY WERE SITTING
MISTER OVER NINETY. MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN OPPOSITION AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY THREE- ONCE
AGAIN WE ARE PROPOSING TO PASS
BILLS WITH ABSOLUTELY NO
CONTENT OUT OF THIS CHAMBER LET
ME SUGGEST THAT IT SETS A
TERRIBLE EXAMPLE AND SENDS A
TERRIBLE SIGNAL TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS WHEN WE ATTACH OUR
VOTE ARE YES VOTE ON A BILL
WITH NO CONTENT. I KNOW THAT
THE ARGUMENT EVERY YEARS AT
THIS IS NECESSARY FOR THE
BUDGETING PROCESS BUT AS THE
BUDGET THAT WE JUST PASSED THIS
YEAR THE- TODAY IN THIS CHAMBER
LIST RATES IT'S NOT NECESSARY
WE CAN BUILD A MORE TRANSPARENT
PROCESS THAT DOES NOT REQUIRE
US TO PASS MIKE BILLS I
ORIGINAL VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
OBERNOLTE SEEING NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CLARK LIBERAL. RESERVE A
VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. YEAH. ALL
MEMBERS THE THOUGH IT IS AT
ABOUT.
WORK WELL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT AYE AYES SIXTY KNOWS
THIRTEEN. THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
FOUR READ SOME AGO EIGHTEEN
SIXTY FOUR BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET NATURALLY TO THE BUDGET
ACTTWENTY TWENTY. MISTER TECH.
SO I LIKE OUT THE ROSTER WILL
BE SUBSTITUTED FOR AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY FOUR THROUGH NINETEEN OH
TWO. FROM THE PREVIOUS VOTER OF
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY THREE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FOR
FILE ITEMS FIVE THROUGH. FORTY
FOUR. WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL
SUBSIDY THE ROLE ON THE
REMAINING TRAILER BILLS CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE ON THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET ACCOLADE TO
THE BUDGET ACT TWENTY TWENTY.
YEAH BUT I SIXTY KNOWS THIRTEEN
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN SIXTY
SIX BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
NATURALLY TO THE BUDGET ACT OF
TWENTY TWENTY. I SIXTY KNOWS
THIRTEEN SOME AGO EIGHTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET NATURALLY TO THE BUDGET
ACT TWENTY TWENTY. AYE AYES
SIXTY KNOWS THIRTEEN SOME AGO
EIGHTEEN SIXTY EIGHT BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET NATURALLY
pTO THE BUDGET AFTER TWENTY
TWENTY- SIXTY KNOWS THIRTEEN
SOME AGO EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET NOT
REALLY GOOD AN ACCOLADE TO THE
BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY.
FIVE SIXTY KNOWS THIRTEEN SOME
AGO EIGHTEEN SEVENTY BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET NATURALLY
TO THE BUDGET ACT TWENTY
TWENTY. FIVE SIXTY KNOWS
THIRTEEN SOME OF EIGHTEEN THE
ONE BY THE COMMITTEE- BUT
ACTUALLY TO THE BACK TWENTY
TWENTY. I SIXTY KNOWS THIRTEEN
SOME OF- EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO
BY THE COMMITTEE BUDGET
ACTUALLY TO THE BUDGET ACT
TWENTY TWENTY. I SIXTY KNOWS
THIRTEEN SOME AGO EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY THREE BY THE COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET ACTUALLY TO THE
BUDGET ACT TWENTY TWENTY. FIVE
SIXTY KNOWS THIRTEEN SOME OF-
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY FOUR BY THE
COMMITTEE- BUT GENERALLY TO THE
BUDGET ACT TWENTY TWENTY. I
SIXTY NO THIRTEEN SOME PEOPLE
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY FIVE BY THE
COMMITTEE- BUDGET NATURALLY TO
THE BUDGET ACT TWENTY TWENTY. I
SIXTY KNOWS THIRTEEN SOME
PEOPLE EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SIX BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
NATURALLY TO BUDGET ACT OF
TWENTY TWENTY. FIVE SIXTY KNOWS
THIRTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN BY THE COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET NATURALLY TO THE
BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY.
FIVE SIXTY KNOWS THIRTEEN SOME
AGO EIGHTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
ACTUALLY TO THE BUDGET ACT OF
TWENTY TWENTY- SIXTY KNOWS
THIRTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY NINE BY THE COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET ACTUALLY TO THE
BUDGET ACT. TWENTY TWENTY. FIVE
SIXTEEN OF THIRTEEN SOME AGO
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET ACTUALLY TO
THE BUDGET ACT TWENTY TWENTY.
FIVE HE KNOWS THIRTEEN SOME
PEOPLE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY ONE BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
ACCOLADES THE BUDGET ACT TWENTY
TWENTY I SIXTY KNOWS THIRTEEN
SOME PEOPLE EIGHTEEN. TO BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET ACCOLADES
OF BUT IN OUR TWENTY TWENTY. I
SIXTEEN OF THIRTEEN PEOPLE
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FOR BY THE
COMMITTEE BUDGET COOLEY TO THE
BUDGET ACT TWENTY. FIVE SIXTY
THIRTEEN PEOPLE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR BY THE COMMITTEE- BUT NOT
QUITE THE BUDGET AT. TWENTY
TWENTY. FIVE SIXTY KNOWS
THIRTEEN SOME PEOPLE EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN BY THE COMMITTEE
BUDGET ACTUALLY TO THE BUDGET
ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY- SIXTY
KNOWS THIRTEEN SOME PEOPLE
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET ACTUALLY TO
THE BUDGET ACT. TWENTY TWENTY.
FIVE SIXTY KNOWS THIRTEEN. SOME
AGO EIGHTEEN EIGHTY NINE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND- INTO
THE BUDGET ACT. TWENTY TWENTY.
I SIXTY KNOWS THIRTEEN SOME
PEOPLE EIGHTEEN NINETY BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET NATURALLY
TO THE BUDGET ACT. TWENTY
TWENTY. I SIXTY KNOWS THIRTEEN
SOME PEOPLE EIGHTEEN NINETY ONE
BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
ACTUALLY TO THE BUDGET ACT.
TWENTY TWENTY. I SIXTY KNOWS
THIRTEEN SO MAYBE- EIGHTEEN
NINETY TWO BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET ACCOLADES THE BUDGET. OF
TWENTY TWENTY. I SIX SHE KNOWS.
SOME PEOPLE A- NINETY. BY THE
COMMITTEE OF. NOT RELATED TO
THE- ACT OF. TWO I SIXTY KNOWS.
SOME PEOPLE EACH NINETY FOUR BY
THE COME ON BUDGET ACTUALLY TO
THE BUDGET. TWENTY FIVE SIX
KNOWS THE- SOME PEOPLE A-
NINETY FIVE BY COMMITTEE ON.
AND RELATING THE BUDGET I OF
TWENTY TWO SIXTY DOES THIRTEEN
SOME BUILT. NINE SIX BY THE
COMMITTEE BUDGET AND ACT
RELATING TO THE BUDGET. OF
TWENTY. AYE AYES. KNOWS
THIRTEEN SOME PEOPLE A- NINETY.
ABOUT COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND I
RELATING TO THE BUDGET ACT. TWO
FIVE SIXTY KNOWS. SOME EIGHTEEN
NINETY EIGHT THE COMMITTEE BUT
THAT IN AKRON. THE BUDGET ARE
TWENTY TWO. FIVE SIX KNOWS THE-
SOME. EIGHTEEN NINETY NINE THE
COMMITTEE BUDGET ACCOLADES THE
BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY TWO. FIVE
HE KNOWS THIRTEEN. SOME REAL
NOT HUNDRED BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND ACT. TO THE BUDGET.
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY THOSE. SOME
PEOPLE. TO KNOW WHAT BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND ARE
FROM.
MEMBERS WE. ARE GOING TO
TAKE A MISTER GIBSON'S
AMENDMENTS THIS IS FILE ITEM
SIXTY FOUR FILE ITEM SIXTY FOUR
AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY FIVE FOR
THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS CLERK
READ WITH AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY SIX FIFTY FIVE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME REMEMBER
GIPSON MISTER GIBSON ON THE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SIX FIFTY FIVE FOR THE PURPOSE
OF AMENDMENTS I REFER TO THIS
BILL THE KOBE BRYANT FIELD
THESE A MEMBERS WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH LAW FORCED. TO GET
US TO THIS PARTICULAR POINT ONE
LOWERS THE MISDEMEANOR PENALTY
FROM FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
ONE THOUSAND FROM ONE YEAR IN
JAIL TO- NOTE JAIL TIME ALSO IT
PROVIDES A NOTIFICATION TO ALL
LAW ENFORCEMENT OF THE NEW LAWS
THAT COULD POTENTIALLY TAKE
PLACE IN THE SHIP IN THE LAW L.
GLUED SIR. URGENCY STEP I NOT
KLAY AT THE C. OF CRIME FOR
ALSO THIS UP TALK ABOUT NGUYEN
PLEASE OFFICERS TAKE ADDED IS A
SCENE OF A DECEASED
INDIVIDUATED THIS LAW WILL
PROHIBIT THAT MEMBERS ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE ON
OF THESE AMENDMENTS. TWENTY SIX
FIFTY FIVE. DAVID GIPSON WITH
OF. WE TAKE A FOR ON AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN SAY AYE. I AM SAY
NAY. YEAH HAVE AT THE MEMBERS
ARE. BILLS OUT TO PRINTABLE ON
FIVE. MEMBERS WE ARE BY IN FILE.
WE HAVE BUSINESS. STILL TO
ATTEND TO MEMBERS. PLEASE
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS KEEP YOUR
CONVERSATIONS TO A MINIMUM IN
THE FILE ORDER FILE ITEM SIXTY
THREE. MR STONE'S. AB. TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE. THE
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARK STONE AN
ACT RELATING THE JUVENILES MR
STONE YOU MAIL BUT THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS MEMBERS
WE'VE WORKED OVER THE YEARS
QUITE A BIT ON CEILING OF
RECORDS FOR JUVENILES WHO HAVE
MADE A MISTAKE AS ONE TO ATONE
FOR THAT MISTAKE DO THE
PROGRAMMING TO THE DIVERSION
NECESSARY. AND YET IF WE DON'T
FEEL THE RECORD IF WE DON'T
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT THEY CAN GO
BACK INTO THE SOCIETY WITHOUT A
CLOUD HANGING OVER THEM GO TO
SCHOOL GO TO WORK. THEIR LIVES
BECOME A LOT MORE DIFFICULT.
THIS IS A YET ANOTHER STEP IN
THAT RECORD CEILING BECAUSE
WHEN A YOUTH IS DIVERTED INTO A
PROGRAM. THE PROBATION
DEPARTMENT AND THAT PROGRAM
PROVIDER SEAL THE RECORD FOR
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY DOES
NOT THIS BILL MERELY CLOSES
THAT GAP. AND HAS THE RECORD
SEALED FOR. AT THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY THE SAME WAY
THAT IT IS IN THE AND- THE
OTHER PROVIDERS OR THE
PROBATION DEPARTMENT OR OTHER
PLACES. AND WITHOUT ASK YOUR
AYE ABOUT. THANK YOU MICHELLE.
SAY NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. THE CORPORAL MEMBERS.
RESERVE IT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSER
ROLL TIDE OF IT I FIFTY THREE
KNOWS FOURTEEN. THAT MEASURE
PASSES WE'VE DISPENSED WITH
FILE ITEM SIXTY FOUR THIS IS
FILE ITEM. SIXTY FIVE. AB
THIRTY FIFTY SIX. ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY FIFTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ AND
OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
EMPLOYMENT MISS HIS HOUSE YOU
MAY OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. AB THIRTY FIFTY SIX
WOULD CREATE WORKPLACE SAFETY
AND FAIR PAY STANDARD FOR
WORKERS WHO OPERATE UNDER A
QUOTA WHILE WORKING IN A
WAREHOUSE. IN MODERN WAREHOUSES
COMPANY SET SPECIFIC QUOTAS FOR
WORKERS TO MEET MONITOR
PRODUCTIVITY INCLUDING HOW MUCH
TIME OFF TASK OCCURS IF THEY
CAN'T MEET THAT QUOTA THREE
TIMES THEY'RE OFTEN FIRED. IN
EVEN WHEN THEY NEED TO WASH
THEIR HANDS DURING THIS
PANDEMIC OR TAKE A BREAK TO
WALK TO THE RESTROOM. THOSE
MINUTES ARE COUNTED AGAINST
THEM AND IF YOU LOOK AT ONE
FACILITY IN PARTICULAR AND
RIVERSIDE IT TAKES A WORKER
SEVEN MINUTES TO WALK TO THE
BATHROOM. USE THE BATHROOM OF
COURSE AND WALK BACK SO ALL OF
THOSE MEN SIR ACTUALLY COUNTED
AGAINST HER QUOTA. OUR BILL
DOESN'T TOUCH THE QUOTA IT
ALLOWS THE EMPLOYER TO CONTINUE
TO DECIDE WHAT THE QUOTA SHOULD
BE BUT TO TELL THEM HAT YOU
CAN'T COUNT AGAINST A WORKER IF
THEY HAVE TO USE THE RESTROOM
OR WASH YOUR HANDS. OR TAKE A
PICTURE OF A LABOR CODE
VIOLATIONS. THOSE THREE THINGS
IT ALSO TELLS WAREHOUSES THAT
IF YOU UP THAT QUOTA AND THAT'S
WHAT AT OPTIONALLY HAPPENS.
WHEN THEY GET BUSIER AND BUSIER
THEY DON'T OFFER THEIR
EMPLOYEES OVER TIME. THEY JUST
SAY YOU TO GET THE WORK DONE
FASTER SO WE SAY IF YOU UP YOUR
REGULAR QUOTA YOU HAVE TO PAY
PREMIUM TAP TIME THE SAME WAY
YOU WOULD. IF YOU WERE DOING
OVERTIME. THIS IS A- COMMON
SENSE SOLUTION TO A WORK
PRODUCT THAT WE'RE NOT USED TO.
IT'S MORE IT'S- MORE FAMILIAR
ARE IT SEEMS MORE LIKE PIECE
WORK IN OUR FIELD THAN IT DOES.
A NORMAL HOURLY JOB. FOR THAT
REASON WE'RE TRYING TO CREATE A
STANDARD THAT'S HUMANE. THAT
LOOKS OUT FOR WORKERS IN ALLOWS
THEM TO AT LEAST FUNCTION LIKE
NORMAL HUMAN BEINGS. THEY WANT
TO WASH THEIR HANDS IN A
PANDEMIC. WHERE THAT MIGHT BE
ESSENTIAL FOR THEIR HEALTH AND
WE KNOW THESE OUTBREAKS SIR
THROUGHOUT THESE WAREHOUSES. WE
NEED TO USE THE RESTROOM. I
THINK THAT THAT'S A COMMON
DECENCY WHICH ALLOW ALL WORKERS
WITH THAT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MISS. MISS GONZALES
MISTER MEDINA AND- THE CHAMBER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THEY YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY FIFTY SIX. THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT IS OF THE UTMOST
IMPORTANCE. IN MY DISTRICT.
WHERE WE HAVE CONTINUED
DEVELOPMENT OF WAREHOUSES.
WAREHOUSE WORKERS ARE ESSENTIAL
IN OUR CURRENT SOCIETY BUT
FACED BACKBREAKING WORKPLACE
CONDITIONS. AND EXPECTATIONS.
WAREHOUSE WORKERS CURRENTLY
SUFFERED INJURIES AND NEARLY
TWICE THE NATIONAL AVERAGE DUE
TO STRENUOUS AND TAXING WORKING
CONDITIONS. WE ALSO WORK LONGER
SHIFTS DURING PEAK SEASONS SUCH
AS HOLIDAYS FOR THE CURRENT
PANDEMIC WHICH SHIPS MAY BE
EXTENDED TO LAST BETWEEN TEN
AND TWELVE HOURS PER DAY. AND
FEAR BEING FIRED WAS STILL
KEEPING DISTRICT QUOTAS.
MESSAGES SENT TO AMAZON WORKERS
DURING THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS HAVE ASKED THEM TO QUOTE
UNQUOTE MANDATORY WORK
MANDATORY EXTRA TIME. OR FACE
SEPARATION OF EMPLOYMENT. IT'S
CLEAR THAT WAREHOUSE WORKERS
NEED ADDITIONAL WORKPLACE
SAFETY AT PACE STANDARDS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THIRTY FIFTY SIX. THANK
THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA MR FONG
IN THE REAR CHAMBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. I THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THERE ARE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES WITH THIS BILL AB
THIRTY FIFTY SIX IS AN EXAMPLE
OF WHY MANY BELIEVE SACRAMENTO
IS HAVING- IS HARMING OUR
STATE'S BUSINESS CLIMATE. AN
AMAZON FACILITY WILL BE COMING
TO MY DISTRICT THIS SUMMER AND
THAT IS SOMETHING TO BE
CELEBRATED OUR COMMUNITY I JUST
OPENS THAT MUCH NEEDED WORK
OPPORTUNITIES FOR RESIDENTS AND
PROVIDES REVENUE FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. HOWEVER THIS BILL
DOES IS EMPLOYERS ABILITY TO
HIRE MORE WORKERS BY ALLOWING
THE OFTEN ABUSING FOR LET'S
TALK A LAWSUIT TO BLEED
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS. WE HAVE
HEARD STORY AFTER STORY HOW
FRIVOLOUS PAGA LAWSUITS BY
ATTORNEYS ARE PREVENTING- OR
ARE WELL THEY'RE WELL
DOCUMENTED AND WE KNOW THAT
THESE OF THESE LAWSUITS DO NOT
PROVIDE EMPLOYEES REAL
PROTECTIONS OR BENEFITS. AB
THIRTY FIFTY SIX IMPOSES
SIGNIFICANT BURDENS THAT
PUNISHES COMPANIES THEY'RE
SEEING SELECT REASONS YOU
BUSINESS IN OUR STATE FOR THESE
REASONS I ASKED. FOR KNOW ABOUT.
DEAN NO OTHER MAY SEEKING.
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM MS
GONZALEZ YOU MAKE LAW. I JUST
WANNA BE CLEAR AND THING THERE
ARE NO MOM AND POP MASSIVE
WAREHOUSES. I'M AS PRIMARILY IS
ONE COMPANY I'LL BE HONEST. BUT
ALSO PART DOES NOT US I KNOW
IT'S OFTEN BROUGHT UP BUT I
WISH PEOPLE WOULD REALLY
UNDERSTAND IT THIS IS A SECTION
OF HARDER THAT'S NOT AUTOMATIC
IT ALLOWS A THIRTY DAY PERIOD
TO CURE OF VIOLATION THAT MEANS
EVEN IF YOU WANTED TO STILL AND
WANTED TO LITIGATE ON IT YOU
ACTUALLY HAVE TO TELL- THE
EMPLOYER THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
IN THE PLAYER HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO FIX WHATEVER
THEY'RE DOING WRONG. SO I WANT
TO BE CLEAR THAT THIS ISN'T AN
AUTOMATIC LAWSUIT IT ALLOWS THE
EMPLOYER THE ABILITY TO GET IT
RIGHT AND I DO BELIEVE THAT
AMAZON HAS THE ABILITY TO DO
THE RIGHT THING AND ALLOW
PEOPLE TO USE THE REST AND.
EVERY LAST VOTE. WITH THAT
CLARK OF THE ROLE. DESERVE ON
MEMBERS OF ARE VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS. IT IS ERA. BUT. WE
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT AYE AYES FORTY EIGHT NO
SEVENTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY SIX AB.
THIRTY SEVENTY FIVE. KERKORIAN
ASSEMBLY RULE THIRTY SEVENTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ
AND OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
EMPLOYMENT THIS IS ALSO MAKE AN
OPEN. THIS BILL IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW
UNFORTUNATELY IF WELL.
FORTUNATELY THE LAWS ARE THE
LIES IF YOUR WORKER IN YOU
STEAL FROM YOUR EMPLOYER YOU'RE
GONNA GO TO JAIL. YOU'RE NOT
ONLY GOING TO LOSE YOUR JOB BUT
YOU'RE GOING TO GO TO JAIL
UNFORTUNATELY UNDER THE LAW IF
YOUR EMPLOYER AND YOU STEAL THE
WAGES OF YOUR WORKER YOU DON'T
GO TO JAIL. AND IN FACT EVEN IF
THERE IS A FINAL WAGE CLAIM
AGAINST YOU A FINAL ADJUDICATED
CLAIM THAT SAYS YOU STOLE FROM
YOUR WORKERS YOU CAN SIMPLY
SHUT DOWN YOUR BUSINESS. AND
START AGAIN AND START A NEW
BUSINESS AND NOT BE HELD
RESPONSIBLE IN IT HAPPENS WELL
OVER A MAJORITY OF THE TIME
CASES FILED. THROUGH THIS
DAMAGE WHAT WE FOUND ALREADY IS
COMPANIES WHO SHUT DOWN DURING
PANDEMIC DID NOT HATE FINAL
PAYCHECK TO THE WORKERS THAT'S
TWO WEEKS AT LEAST OF LOST TIME
WATCH. STOLEN FROM EACH ONE THE
WORKERS AND THERE ARE RED
STARTING TO STAR A NEW. DURING
THE GAME. I WANTED TO DO A BILL
TO BE THESE AND- ENJOY.
HONESTLY BUT GIVEN HOW WE DON'T
DO NEW CRIMES. INSTEAD WE
SIMPLY WANT PEOPLE TO SAY IT
YOU CAN NOT YOU HAVE TO A TEST
THAT YOU DON'T HAVE A FINAL
WAIT ORDER CLAIM AGAINST YOU
WHEN YOU TRY TO START A NEW
BUSINESS. THE CHAMBER WAS
OPPOSE BECAUSE SOME OF THE
LANGUAGE ABOUT THE FINAL
ADJUDICATION AND ABOUT ALLOWING
LOCAL CITIES TO OUR AS ARTY
LOUD UNDER LAW TO PURSUE STATE
WAGE CLAIMS. WE'VE TAKEN THEIR
AMENDMENTS. THEY WANT A FEW
MORE COMMAS IN AN INWARD
CHANGES WE'VE AGREED TO TAKE
THOSE AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE.
BUT IN ORDER TO STRIKE SOME
BALANCE IN ENSURE THAT. THE
FEEL BAD EMPLOYERS THAT ARE OUT
THERE. WHO ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY HURTING
BLACK AND BROWN WORKERS THROUGH
THE CONCEPT OF STEALING THEIR
LABOR THAT THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO
JUST. START AGAIN WITHOUT
PAYING THAT DEBT OFF. AND DO IT
TO NEW WORKERS. THIS BILL IS
SPONSORED BY AS CHAU IN A
VARIETY OF WORKER CENTER
INCLUDING THE BLACK WORKER
CENTER IN LA AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. FAMOUS
CONSULTS SEEING. NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE BILL. THE
CLERK WILL OF THE ROLE
SERVER ALL MEMBERS OF THIS
ARTICLE. ALL MEMBERS OF HIS OUT
OF A. QUIRK WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ARISE FOR DINO SEVENTEEN
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE I'M
SIXTY SEVEN IS AB TWENTY THIRTY
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THIRTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLANCA RUBIO INOCULATING
STUDENT FINANCIAL AID. THIS
RUBIO THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
SINCE JOINING THE ASSEMBLY A
PRIORITY OF MINE HS BEEN
ENSURING EVERY STUDENT HAS
ACCESS TO FUNDING FOR COLLEGE.
COSTS SHOULD NEVER BE THE FINAL
DETERMINATION WHEN CHOOSING A
COLLEGE TO ATTEND AND THAT IS
WHY I AM VERY EXCITED TO OFFER
AT SOME WITH THE TWENTY THIRTY.
THIS BILL WILL BRING STABILITY
TO THE CAL GRANT AWARD BY
IMPLEMENTING A NEW WORD FUNDING
FORMULA FOR STUDENTS ATTENDING
PRIVATE NONPROFIT UNIVERSITIES
CAL GRANT AWARDS PROVIDE A
CRITICAL FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
TO STUDENTS THAT CAN OFTEN THE
FINE FINAL DETERMINATION SCHOOL
ACCESS. NOT ONLY DOES THE CAL
GRANT PROVIDING AFFORDABLE
PATHWAY TO COLLEGE IT SERVES A
SIGNIFICANT POPULATION OF
STUDENTS IN FACT NEARLY HALF OF
ALL CAL GRANT RESET. EMAIL. I'M
TAKEN INTO. THE BOB THIS BILL
FROM CAUSING ADDITION FISCAL
STRAIN ON THE TO THIS THIS YEAR
WHILE IN ENSURING WE NEED AN
OUR OBLIGATIONS ASSIST UPCOMING
SCHOLARS AS THE ABOUT JR AND
HIGHER EDUCATION NOW MORE THAN
EVER IT IS THAT WE IN AT TO
CALL FOR ALL CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS SO STUDENTS FINANCIAL.
DO NOT TO WHETHER OR NOT THEY
CAN AFFORD BECAUSE THANK YOU
AND I RESPECT FOR ASK FOR NINE.
THANK YOU THIS REVIEW. SEEING
NO DISCUSSION OF A ON THE AT.
OR CALL THE ROLL. THIS A VOTE
ON MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL
MEMBER VOTERS OF A. CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES PASSER TATE OF OUT OF
SIXTY EIGHT THIS IS FILE ITEM
SIXTY NINE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM
SIXTY NINE AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY ONE. SOME PEOPLE TWENTY
THREE FORTY ONE BY SIMILAR
MCCARTY INOCULATE TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THIS MISTER
MCCARTY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS BILL WOULD
ESTABLISH THE RISING SCHOLARS
PROGRAM AND THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO ENCOURAGE
ENROLLMENT RETENTION IS SUCCESS
OF JUSTICE INVOLVED STUDENTS
THIS INCLUDES STUDENTS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY. IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND ALSO
STUDENTS WHO HAVE RECENTLY-
BEEN- SENT HOME TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES MAKING HIGHER
EDUCATION AVAILABLE NOT ONLY
KEEPS INDIVIDUAL FROM GOING
BACK TO PRISON IT CAN CHANGE
THE TRAJECTORY OF THEIR FAMILY
AND FUTURE GENERATIONS AND IT
HELPS US GET MORE COLLEGE
GRADUATES TO FILL THE JOBS. OF
TODAY AND TOMORROW. PRISON IN
CALIFORNIA HAS A WAIT LIST FOR
THE PAYMENT PROGRAMS THIS WILL
HELP BE FOUGHT THESE PROGRAMS
BY USING OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM TO INTEGRATE WITHIN. OUR
CALIFORNIA JUSTICE SYSTEM THIS
BILL WILL UTILIZE EXISTING
MONIES WITHIN A CATEGORICAL
PROGRAM IN THE COMMUNICABLE ITS
BUDGET. AND HOPEFULLY IN FUTURE
YEARS WE CAN EXPAND UPON THIS
PROGRAM- NO NO VOTES NO
OPPOSITION I ASK THE ARRIVAL
THANK YOU. THING WAS REGARDING.
SEE NOTICED OF A- CORPORAL OF.
MEMBERS IS THAT ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS OUT OF A. WELL THOSE
ARE ALL TIME BUT I SIXTIES NO
ZERO MEASURE PASSES WE DISPENSE
WITH FILE ITEM SEVENTY THIS IS
FILE ITEM SEVENTY ONE AB.
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON
ACCOLADE TO ARAB MERCHANTS HE'S
AT AMBULANCE TO CLEARLY YOU SEE
OF THE THICK MEATY. MISTER GRAY
EMAIL. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I AM. TO PRESENT TO YOU
AB TWO FOUR FOR. WHICH WILL
EXTEND THE EXISTING FUNDING FOR
EMERGENCY ERR AMBULANCE
PROVIDERS EMERGENCY ERR
AMBULANCE PROVIDERS ARE
ESSENTIAL PART OF THE STATEWIDE
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
SYSTEM THEY ALSO PLAYED A KEY
ROLE IN HOMELAND SECURITY AND
DISASTER RESPONSE. INCLUDING
EVACUATING HOSPITALS IN THE
PATH OF WILDFIRES AND
RESPONDING TO THE COVERT
NINETEEN SAYS COLONEL ERR
AMBULANCE PROVIDERS ARE FUNDED
THROUGH EMERGENCY MEDICAL AIR
TRANSPORTATION ACT. THE FUND IS
SET TO EXPIRE ON JULY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY AB TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY WILL EXTEND THE EXISTING
AMADA FUNDING UNTIL JULY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IN DOING SO
THIS BILL WOULD ENSURE AIR
AMBULANCE PROVIDERS CAN PROVIDE
CONTINUE PROVIDING LIFESAVING
SERVICES. TO RESIDENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ESPECIALLY
IN LIGHT OF OVER EIGHTEEN WHILE
I FULLY INTEND TO FIND LONG
TERM ENDING A LONG TERM THING
SO IN IN THE YEAR BY WORK KALRA
BUT POPPIES THIS BILL. PROVIDES
LESS. THE FOR THEY NEED. TO PUT.
SAVINGS AND THE INTERIM THIS
BILLS AND BY PARTISAN IN YOUR
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY FOR AND
I'VE- THANK YOU MISS GRAYSON
MISSED FRAZIER. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AS A- WHO'S A
BIT OF AN AND MIGHT LITTLE GIRL
ALIVE. BECAUSE OF THAT SITS. WE
DON'T REAL HOW MUCH WE
APPRECIATE SOMETHING TO WE ARE
NEED. I HAVE FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THEY GIVE US FRAZIER. SAYING NO
OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING.
DISCRETION WE CLOSE HERE. I
RESPECT ASK WHEN I THINK QUIRK
WELL. SARAH VOTE ON VOTERS OUT
OF A. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. BURKE WELL. CLOSE YOUR
ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SIXTY NINE
KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE URGENCY I
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO ON THE
MEASURE. AND WITHOUT OBJECTION
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO THE
SENATE. THIS IS PARTLY
PASSERINE CANNOT FILE ITEM
SEVENTY TWO THIS IS FILE ITEM
SEVENTY THREE AB. TWENTY EIGHT
NINETY ONE. MISTER JONES
SAWYER. MISTER JONES SAWYER-
SET. I WAS GOING TO MAKE A MOVE
TO THE WELL WISHERS JONES
SAWYER BUT YOU MAY TAKE AT THAT
ITEM. THIS IS. FIVE SEVEN THREE
B. TWENTY NINE ONE CORPORATE
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
NINETY ONE BY SOME MEMBERS
JONES SAWYER ANOTHER'S
IMMACULATE IN THE PEACE
OFFICERS MISTER JONES OR- A
GOOD AFTERNOON. SPEAKER I HERE
I AM HERE TODAY TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY ONE A
DISTRICT BUILT THAT WILL
PROVIDE PEACE OFFICER STATUS TO
DO MUSEUM OFFICERS IN
EXPOSITION PARK. LAST YEAR THE
ADMINISTRATION SIGNED A
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING
WITH BARGAINING UNIT SEVEN OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE WIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION.
PROVIDE PEACE OFFICER STATUS TO
THE MUSEUM OFFICERS. MUSEUM
OFFICERS IN EXPOSITION PARK
PROVIDE SAFETY AND SECURITY TO
APPROXIMATE TWO MILLION FIFTY
THOUSAND ATTENDEES AT THE
SCIENCE CENTER. AND WHERE MY
DISTRICT OFFICE IS LOCATED.
THIS BILL IS. TO RESUME OFFICES.
PARK I WAS AMENDED AND ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS TO CLARIFY THAT
MUSEUM OFFICERS MUST COMPLETE
POST TRAINING. THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR EITHER. THANK YOU
SHOWS WHERE MISTER LACK. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. YEAH JUST REAL
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
ACTUALLY TAKEN THE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE THE TRAINING
RETROACTIVE IN THE SERVER
SUPPORTABLE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS LACKEY. SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. MR ON
SERVING BECAUSE YOU WISH THANK
YOU MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THREE I DON'T LIKE WILL OPEN
THE ROLL. THAT A VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE IN USER TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF A RESERVE VOTE.
CLICK WELL. CLOSE THE ROLE
TÁI THAT I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES THIS IS
FILE ITEM SEVENTY FOUR A. B.
THIRTY ONE SIXTY NINE BY MISTER
GIBSON CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY ONE SIXTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON AN ACT
RELATING TO GAMBLING MR GIPSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT TO SELL
THE BILL- THIRTY ONE SIXTY NINE
THIS BILLS SEEK TO DO THE
FOLLOWING ALLOW PORTABLE
PROBABILITY. AMBLING SO. OF A
CARD ROOM CAN SIM POSITIONS
WITH OTHER GAMBLING ENTERPRISES
WITHOUT NEEDING MULTIPLE
LICENSE TO EXTEND ACE ESTATE
GAMBLING LICENSE FROM TWO YEARS
TO THREE YEARS. THE CURRENT
LICENSE SEE- TIME CAN TAKE AN
X. SEAT UP TO SIX MONTHS THIS
BILL WILL STREAMLINE THE
LICENSE PROCESS. WILL BE
RESTRICTIONS AND ULTIMATELY
BENEFITING THE EMPLOYEE MAY NOT
BE ABLE TO RECEIVE A FULL TIME
WORK AT WHAT OKAY. MISSION
ABOUT I THINK THE- OF THE
ALLIES AND AB THIRTY ONE NINE
WILL. THE NUMBER OF ANNUAL
RENEWALS AND HOPE PROVE. FUTURE
LIFE BACK. THIS BILL RECEIVED
BY. SUPPORT NO NOBLE IRIS ASK
FOR I BUILT. NAME IS GIPSON.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION FOR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM A CLUB ROLL.
RESERVE OUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF.
DESIRABLE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES. WHEN
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
FILE ITEM SEVENTY FIVE A. B.
THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN THIS IS FILE
ITEM SEVENTY SIX. AB THIRTY
THREE HUNDRED. CORPORATE SOME
BILL THIRTY THREE HUNDRED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO WHAT
OTHERS AN ACTOR LIVING
HOMELESSNESS AND MAKING A
PROBATIONER FOR MISTER SANTIAGO
I THINK IT WAS SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB THIRTY THREE HUNDRED PER IT
WOULD IT WOULD DELIVER A
HISTORIC AND INVESTMENT. TO
RADICALLY HOMELESSNESS I THINK
WE TAKE A LOOK AROUND OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS AND WE KNEW THAT
PEOPLE ARE FALLING HOMELESSNESS
THIS PANDEMIC IS WORSE THAN THE
SITUATION WE NOW KNOW THAT IN
CERTAIN REGIONS LIKE THE
REASONS I REPRESENT WE'VE
ALREADY SEEN AN UPTICK AT
13214% INCREASE IN THE HOMELESS
POPULATION. AND IT KIND OF
MAKES SENSE TO INVEST IN OUR
BUDGET AND AN ONGOING BASIS ON
THE ISSUE OF HOMELESSNESS. WHAT
WE'RE ASKING TODAY'S TWO
BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT ON
GOING TO CONTINUE TO BE
DELIBERATED ONLY BECAUSE WE SAY
THAT HOMELESSNESS IS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND IT'S THE
MOST ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
OF OUR LIFETIME BUT WE TAKE A
LOOK AT IN OUR STATE BUDGET WE
HAVE AN ALLOCATION AHMADIS
TOWARDS HEALTHCARE YOU HAVE AN
ALLOCATION MONEY TOWARDS
TRANSPORTATION WE HAVE ALLOCATE
THE MONEY TO. TO KEEP. I WOULD
ON IT. ON ABOUT THE ARE OUT OUR
BY BUT WE HAVE ALLOCATE. FOR
HOMELESSNESS. SO IT'S NO
SURPRISE THAT. I WE CAN WE
WOULD CAN TO SEE THE WHOLE.
NUMBER CONTINUE GROW YOUR YEAR
AFTER YEAR. SO IN TOTAL
ACTUALLY INVEST. IN THE USUAL
HOME. WE'RE NOT GOING TO DO NOT
GOING TO BE TO. THE IS SO
HOMELESSNESS. TO CALL THESE ARE
RESPECTFULLY FOR KNIVES ON A.
THREE THIRTY TO HUNDRED. THANK
YOU FOR SANTIAGO WAS BLOW YOUR
RECORD THAT THANK YOU MISTER
MEMBERS I AS A PROUD JOIN ALL.
OF AB THIRTY THREE HUNDRED
BEFORE THE BAND BIG HOMES WAS
ALL A CRISIS I. AND THE COVERT
NINE PAN. HAS ONLY A- OUR
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS. IN FACT THE MOST RECENT
LOS ANGELES COUNTY HOMELESS
COUNT. TAKEN BEFORE THE COVERT
NINETEEN HEALTH AND ECONOMIC
CRISIS SHOWS THAT HOMELESSNESS
HAD INCREASED BY FOURTEEN
PERCENT. AND NOW DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC UNPRECEDENTED NUMBERS
A CALIFORNIANS ARE FINDING
THEMSELVES OUT OF WORK EVERY
DAY. AND FACED WITH THE LOOMING
FEAR OF AFFECTION AND
EVENTUALLY HOMELESSNESS. CITIES
AND COUNTIES WHICH ARE THE
BACKBONE OF OUR HOMELESS
SERVICES AND RENT ASSISTANCE
ARE IN DIRE NEED OF HELP.
COVERT NINETEEN IS PRESENTED
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WITH THE ON
DAUNTING TASK. OF FINDING WAYS
TO PROVIDE VITAL SERVICES WITH
SHRINK REVENUE IS. WE MUST
INVEST IN A PREDICTABLE ONGOING
FUNDING SOURCE TO FIND
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS VITAL
SAFETY NESS AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY TO AND THE NONSTOP
CYCLE OF HOMELESSNESS. MESSAGE
PASS AND INCREASE OUR PLATES
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND AB
THIRTY THREE IS THAT INVESTMENT.
AS NOT WHEN WE LANDED
CALIFORNIA'S THE NEEDED MOST
AND I ASKED THAT YOU VOTE. ON
AB THREE. THANK YOU MISS BLOOM
ESTHER KILEY RECORD. RISE IN
OPPOSITION I'D BE A LAW HAPPIER
WITH THIS BILL OF AN IDEA FOR
PRO ARE WITH ATTRACT OF TRANSIT
PEOPLE OUT OF HOMELESSNESS TO
PREVENTING THEM FROM FALLING
INTO HOMELESSNESS AND THEN. IN
THANK OFFER THAT'S PRO. STATUS
SORT OF. THROW TWO BILLION
DOLLARS OUT THERE UNDER THE
CHEN BANNER OF HOME. THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING WEAPONS PAST AND
THERE'S NO REASON TO THINK IT'S
GONNA IN THE FEW. MR YOUR
RECOGNIZING THE CHAMP. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTY THREE HUNDRED I WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES FOR INTRODUCING THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURES AS WE NOW.
BEFORE WE EVER HAD THAT KOBE
NINETEEN CRISIS AND THE
ECONOMIC CRISIS THAT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS CREATED WE ARE IN
THE MIDDLE OF A HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS WE HAVE SEEN AND WE
CONTINUE TO SEE THE SUFFERING
ON THE STREETS THAT ARE STILL
THE LARGEST HOMELESSNESS.
POPULAR HOMELESS POPULATION IN
THE NATION AND WE HAVE SEEN WE
FOR THE STATS FROM COLLEGE TO
MENTION IT THAT THIS CRISIS IS
ONLY INCREASING AND RETURNING
TO THE ECONOMIC HARDSHIP OF
COOK NINETY WE'VE SEEN THAT YOU
CAN'T SHELTER IN PLACE IF YOU
DON'T HAVE SHELTER THAT YOU
CAN'T STAY AT HOME. IF YOU
DON'T HAVE A HOME AT TODAY IN
AND WE HAVE A OFTENTIMES ABOUT
WE SHOULD BE JUDGED BY HOW WE
TREAT EN SUPPORT OUR VULNERABLE
ON OUR- AND SIR ARE HOMELESS
HOMELESS POPULATION IN
CALIFORNIA IS A ON OUR MOST
VULNERABLE IN ORDER TO MEET. BE
IN AND MORE THIS THAT IT CAL
HOMELESSNESS WE NEED A SOLUTION
THAT MATCHED THAT ARE THAT
MATCHES THE CRISIS IN SCALE AND
SCOPE AND SPEED AND THAT IS
WHAT THIS TWO BILLION DOLLAR
ONGOING APPROPRIATION TO IT
HOMELESSNESS AS RESPECT AFTER
AYE VOTE SB THIRTY THREE. THANK
YOU MISS BONTA. SEEN NO
ADDITIONAL. DEBATE SONDHI YOU
MAKE LOVE SIR I THINK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. ONE RESPONDED
TO FACT THAT THAT THEY SAID
THAT THERE WERE PROGRAMS
OUTLINE BUT- IF YOU LOOK DEEP
INTO THE BILL. AND YOU READ THE-
YOU WOULD YOU WOULD TAKE A LOOK
AT THAT POINT TO LOCAL. TO OF
CARE SINCE. THAT I GOT A PROBE.
AND THEIR THEIR ARE A LOT
DOCUMENTS A BILL OF THE MAY TO
THOSE WHO READ. I'D TELLING NOT
ONLY HELD DOLLARS WOULD BE
SPENT BY TIME. AND A- MAY. ART
BUT ALSO HONOR MY THIS BY THAT
SAME BAR. OUR LAST PASSED AND
PASSED THE BILL. AND THE MIKE
FROM FRANCISCO AND I WOULD
WORKING ON. AT THAT RECALL
STRICT TO CAN. AND IT MIGHT
ABOUT. HOME FUNDS ARE YOU. ARE
IN THE STATE. AND THOSE THAT
HAVE BEEN. IN PASSED BEFORE.
THAT ONE MIGHT BE. IF YOU. AND
IF IT AND I AND I WOULD ALMOST
ABOUT THAT MY OF OUR CAN. WOULD
AGREE THAT HOME IS THE CRY ONE
OF THE CRISIS OF OUR LAW. AND
IT NO LONGER WHAT YOU WOULD
HAVE A WHO ON THE STREET THE
YOUNG MAN OF THE WHO MADE FOR
BEEN CON HOME BUT IF YOU TAKE A
LOOK AT THE SIDEWALK. AND UNDER
PASSES IN OUR NEIGHBORHOOD.
THERE START TO FILL UP WITH FAN.
LITTLE KIDS. OR YOU'VE NEVER
THOUGHT AROUND THE STREET FOR
FUN GOING TO WAR. AND WHO JUST
AFFORD RENT. AND THEY'RE SO UP
THE JETTA THE PLACE OF LIKES OF
HOPE IN OUR AREA. WOULD YOU
TAKE A SHOWER AND A TO GET
THROUGH THEIR DAY. GOOD PEOPLE
ARE ONE PAYCHECK AWAY. FOR
MISSING AND LANDING ON THE
STREET IN THIS JUST LAY THEM ON
THIS. SO I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THEY BEGIN MAKE A MODEST
INVESTMENT. AND REFLECT THE
VALUE CAL THANK YOU. THE THING
WAS SANTA WITH THAT CARPOOL THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MY VOTERS ARAB. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE. QUIRK
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
FIFTY FIVE. KNOWS ONE THAT
MEASURE PASSES ORTEGA FILE ITEM
SEVENTY SEVEN. AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY SIX BY MR FLORA.
FEBRUARY SOME PEOPLE TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY SIX BY SUMMER
FLORA ACCOLADE VITAL RECORDS MR
FLORA. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SIX
WOULD ALLOW COUNTY RECORDER'S
TO CONTINUE ACCEPTING
ELECTRONIC VERIFICATION OF
IDENTITY FROM APPLICANTS
REQUESTING CERTIFIED VITAL
RECORDS ONLINE AB TWENTY THREE
SEVEN SIX SIMPLY SEEK TO
ELIMINATE THE SUNSET DATE OF
THIS REGIONAL PROGRAM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR PRIVATE.
THANKS FOR SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CORPORAL OF
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE ABOUT. KIRK WELL CLOSE REAL
TIDE BUT I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS
FROM WAY BACK IN THE FILE THE
FILE ITEM SEVENTY TWO. AB
TWENTY FIVE A ONE FIVE MINUTES
LONG. CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIVE A ONE BY SOME
MEMORABLY MONNING ACKLEY NICOLE
BUT NOT LEAVE VISIBLE. THANK
YOU SPEAKER TODAY I BRING
BEFORE YOU TWENTY FIVE OH ONE
TO ADDRESS THE VERY DIFFICULT
FINANCIAL SITUATIONS THAT MANY
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES ARE
EXPERIENCING. THESE FAMILIES
ARE STRUGGLING NOT DUE TO ANY
FAULT OF THEIR OWN BUT DUE TO
THE SPREAD OF A DANGEROUS VIRUS
AND DUE TO THE NEEDED RESPONSE
THAT WE HAVE TAKEN TO ADDRESS
THE PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS.
COLLECTIVELY WE HAVE MADE
DECISIONS DECISIONS THAT WE
UNDERSTAND ARE NECESSARY TO
PROTECT THE LIVES OF CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS BY IMPLEMENTING STAY
AT HOME ORDERS AND RESTRICTING
A BROAD RANGE OF ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY. THESE RISKS SINCE
HAVE SUCCEEDED REDUCING THE
TRANSMISSION OF THE VIRUS BUT
THEY ALSO CREATE VERY DIFFICULT
FINANCIAL CHALLENGES FOR
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIA FAMILIES.
THE LAST RECESSION. LIVING
EXPENSES INCREASE MUCH FASTER
AND WAGES AND CALIFORNIA
HOUSEHOLDS ENTERED THIS
PANDEMIC WITH HIGHER LEVELS OF
DEBT THAN WE HAVE EVER SEEN.
FOR FAMILIES WHO BARELY WHO ARE
BARELY GETTING BY AND WERE
BARELY GETTING BY THE FOR THE
CRISIS. THEY'RE HAVING TO COPE
pWITH THIS TEMPORARY REALITY
UNTIL WE CONTAIN THE VIRUS AND
WE CAN SAFELY RETURN TO NORMAL
ACTIVITIES. AS THEIR ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES WHAT ARE WE
DOING NOW TO PREPARE FOR THE
MONTHS AHEAD. EPIDEMIOLOGIST IN
PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS WARN IS
THAT THE SECOND WAVE MAY COME
LATER THIS YEAR AND MAY REQUIRE
ANOTHER ROUND OF STAY AT HOME
ORDERS AND ECONOMIC
RESTRICTIONS. THE WRITING IS ON
THE WALL CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
ARE FINANCIALLY STRUGGLING NOW
AND EVEN MORE MAYBE STRUGGLING
SIX MONTHS FROM NOW. AB TWENTY
FIVE A ONE SIX TO PROVIDE THESE
FAMILIES WITH TIME TO WEATHER
THE STORM. THE BILL DOES NOT
FOR GAVE OR CANCEL ANY DAY.
INSTEAD IT REQUIES LENDERS TO
OFFER FORBEARANCE OR A
TEMPORARY DELAY IN MAKING
PAYMENTS ON MORTGAGES CAR LOANS
AND SMALL DOLLAR LOANS. AS WE
EVENTUALLY LEARN HOW TO CONTAIN
THE VIRUS THE BILL PROVIDES A
PATHWAY BACK FOR CONSUMERS TO
RESUME MAKING THEIR LOAN
PAYMENTS. SO I THINK WE HAVE TO
MAKE A CHOICE. DO WE TRUST
EVERY FINANCIAL INSTITUTION AND
OTHER FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS TO
ALWAYS DO WHAT'S BEST FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
WHEN WE DID THAT LAST HOW DID
IT WORK OUT FOR US WHEN THEY
AWARDED THE PPP FUNDING. OR DO
WE ESTABLISH THE SAFETY NET
THAT PREVENTS PEOPLE FROM
FALLING INTO FOR CLOSURES AND
REPOSSESSIONS I COULD BE
PREVENTABLE. THE FIRST APPROACH
IS BASED ON TRICKLE DOWN
ECONOMICS THE IDEA THAT IF WE
MAKE SURE BUSINESSES ARE
HEALTHY THEN THE BENEFITS WILL
TRICKLE DOWN TO WORKERS AND
CONSUMERS. THE OTHER APPROACH
IS BASED FROM A BOTTOMS UP
PERSPECTIVE HOW CAN WE PRO
ACTIVELY HELP EVERY DAY PEOPLE
SO THAT THEY HAVE THE FINANCIAL
STABILITY AND WELL BEING TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE BROADER
ECONOMY. I BROUGHT THIS BILL
FORWARD PRIMARILY TO HELP
FAMILIES. BUT THIS BILL IS ALSO
ABOUT SETTING CALIFORNIA UP FOR
AN ECONOMIC RECOVERY. CONSUMER
SPENDING MAKES IT MORE THAN TWO
THIRDS OF OUR ECONOMIES GDP.
WITHOUT A HEALTHY CONSUMER
THERE IS NO SUCH THING AS
ECONOMIC RECOVERY. USING
FINANCIAL TOOLS LIKE FOR
PARENTS CAN OF AVOID
UNNECESSARY FOR CLOSURES EVOKE
SHINS DISPLACEMENT AND
REPOSSESSIONS THAT WILL HARM
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH EFFORTS TO
DATE AND SLOW DOWN OUR ECONOMIC
RECOVERY FOR THE FUTURE. BEFORE
I WRAP UP MY OPENING REMARKS I
WANT TO ADDRESS THE MYTH THAT
HAVE BEEN FLOATING OUT THERE.
THE MYTH BE SPREAD AROUND IS
THAT THE IDEA THAT FORBEARANCE
IS OFFERED. THAT A FLOOD OF
PEOPLE WHO DO NOT NEED IT WILL
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT ANYWAY. WE
HAVE EVIDENCE FROM THIS
EMERGENCY THAT THIS IS SIMPLY
NOT TRUE. IN LATE MARCH
CONGRESS PASSED THE CARES ACT
WHICH PROVIDES MORTGAGE FOR
PERRANCE UP TO ONE YEAR FOR
FEDERALLY BACKED MORTGAGES. THE
CARES ACT PROHIBITS A MORTGAGE
SERVICER FROM REQUIRING ANY
DOCUMENTATION FROM A BORROWED
TO PROVIDE THEIR FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP SO WE SHOULD EXPECT
THAT MANY PEOPLE. WOULD HAVE
TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF THIS RIGHT.
ACTUALLY THAT'S NOT THE CASE
THE MORTGAGE BANKERS
ASSOCIATION PUBLISHES DATA
WEEKLY ABOUT THE PERCENTAGE OF
MORTGAGES MORTGAGES AND
FORBEARANCE THIS WEEK'S REPORT
SHOWS THAT ONLY EIGHT POINT 5%
OF MORTGAGES ARE IN FORBEARANCE.
SO WE HAVE THE NATIONAL
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE AT 16% WE
HAVE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS WHO ARE
OPERATING AT REDUCED CAPACITY
IF AT ALL. BUT THE FORBEARANCE
RATE REMAINS IN THE SINGLE
DIGIT PERCENTAGES THIRTY TELL
US. IT TELLS ME THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF HOMEOWNERS ARE
STILL PAYING FOR THEIR MORTGAGE
WHO CAN AFFORD IT EVEN THOSE
HOMEOWNERS WHO HAVE SEEN THEIR
INCOME GO DOWN ARE TIGHTENING
THEIR BUDGETS. WE MUST ACT
TODAY FOR CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
AND. FOR EIGHTEEN BACK AND
WAITING FOR CLOSURES
REPOSSESSIONS AND PERMANENT
DAMAGE TO CREDIT DOES NOT ALLOW
FOR AN ECONOMY TO RECOVER.
THANK YOU. THANK HIM AS A MOM
IS BOERNER HORVATH THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY TO ASK
YOU TO VOTE I WON AB TWENTY
FIVE A ONE AND I HAVE TO SAY
THERE ARE MANY THINGS IN THIS
BILL I DON'T LIKE AND I'VE
TALKED TO THE AUTHOR AT LENGTH
ABOUT THE THINGS I LIKE AND
WHAT I DON'T LIKE AND THE
AUTHOR HAS PROMISED TO WORK
WITH US TO GET TO A PLACE THAT
PROTECTS. CONSUMERS WHO ARE
AFFECTED BY DEFAULT YOUR
BECAUSE THEY CANNOT WORK. IN A
PROTECT THEIR CREDIT SO THAT
WHEN WE ARE FACING A CONSUMER
GOODS RECESSION IN A YEAR OR SO
THAT WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO CAN
BUY. AND THAT IS THE POWER OF
THIS BILL IS WE HAVE TO PROTECT
OUR CONSTITUENTS FROM DEFAULTS
BECAUSE OUR ECONOMY HAS BEEN
SHUT DOWN. AND I THINK WHEN WE
LOOK AT OUR ROLE OF GOVERNMENT
AND WE LOOK AT HOW DO WE LEAVE
THIS IS THE BILL THAT LEAVES.
NOW I DON'T LIKE EVERYTHING THE
BILL BUT I TRUSTS THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FROM SANTA BARBARA. WHO
KNOWS THIS IS OUR BAKING SURE
TO REALLY MAKE SURE WE REACH
THE RIGHT BALANCE AND JUST LIKE
ALL OF US HAVE THE RIGHT WHEN
IT BACKING FOR PRINCE OF WE'RE
NOT HAPPY WITH WHAT WE SEE. WE
RESERVE THE RIGHT TO VOTE NO
WHEN IT COMES BACK. ALL I THINK
HE'S DOING IMPORTANT BILL AND
THE RIGHT SPACE. CHECKED OUR
CONSUMERS AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE
YOU TO VOTE I TODAY. MR FRAZIER
YOUR RESIDENTS. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER WELL I
APPRECIATE THE INTENT OF THE
BILL AND THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
HER WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION
THIS BILL CONTINUES TO HAVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES AB
TWENTY FIVE OH ONE IS AIMED AT
ASSISTING PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
FINANCIALLY IMPACTED BY COVERT
NINETEEN. THIS BILL IS TO
PROVIDE HELP TO THOSE WHO NEED
IT TO SURVIVE AND MUST RELY ON
FOR PARENTS. HOWEVER THERE
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HIGHER WE PATROL CREDIT UNION
WHO ARE NOT FINANCIALLY IMPACT
BECAUSE THEY ARE CLOSE CHARTER
AND GETTING UNFAIRLY AFFECTED
BY THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL.
I ASKED THE AUTHOR TO CONTINUE
AND WILL NOT OF THE HEAD I WILL
GIVE A COURTESY VOTE TODAY.
LOOKING FORWARD TO UGH. A GOOD
OUTCOME WITH THE CREDIT. THEY
DO GOOD WORK FOR THEIR MEMBERS
AND I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO A
RESOLUTION THAT WILL MAKE HER
HAPPY AND THE ASSOCIATION HAPPY
FOR THAT. I THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
TODAY BUT RESERVE THE RIGHT TO
CHANGE MY VOTE IF. IT'S NOT A
HAPPY ENDING. DOCTOR WOULD
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TO ASK THAT YOU
VOTE I ON THIS BILL. THIS IS
THE ONLY BILL OF ITS KIND IN
EITHER HOUSE OF THE LEGISLATURE
RIGHT NOW. THIS ISN'T A BILL
THAT THE AUTHOR DECIDED SHE
WANTED TO CARRY IN JANUARY. IS
A BILL IN RESPONSE TO A CRISIS.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE FUTURE
HOLDS AT THE END OF THE YEAR.
WE ADJOURN ON AUGUST THIRTY
FIRST AND WE DON'T COME BACK
SOME OF US DON'T ARE COMING
BACK AT ALL BUT WE DON'T
RECONVENE UNTIL JANUARY.
FINANCIAL MARKETS COULD CHANGE
DRAMATICALLY WE HAVE FIVE
MILLION PEOPLE UNEMPLOYED IN
CALIFORNIA. MANY SO MANY IN
CALIFORNIA RELY ON CARS TO GET
AROUND. ARE THE ENHANCE-
UNEMPLOYMENT WILL END AT THE
END OF JULY. MANY PEOPLE ARE
SIMPLY HANGING ON IT WOULD BE
REALLY. I DON'T WANT TO GO BACK
TO MY CONSTITUENTS AND SAY I
DIDN'T LIFT A FINGER TO TRY TO
PROTECT YOU. BECAUSE I WASN'T
SURE WHAT MIGHT HAPPEN. WHAT
THE AUTHOR IS TRYING TO DO IS
TO CREATE SOME GUIDELINES HERE.
NOT EVERY FINANCIAL INSTITUTION
IS CREATED EQUAL THERE'S A
REALLY FINE FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION IN MY DISTRICT THAT
I HAVE TREMENDOUS RESPECT FOR
THEY WORK REALLY WELL WITH
THEIR CONSTITUENTS BUT THEY- IF
THAT WAS THE CASE OF ALL OF
THEM THEN WE WOULDN'T BE HAVING
THIS CONVERSATION. IF PEOPLE IF
THESE FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS
AND HANDLE PP LOANS EQUITABLY
FOR EVERYBODY WE WOULDN'T BE
HAVING CONVERSATIONS LIKE THIS.
DURING THE LAST FINANCIAL
MELTDOWN. THESE BIG
INSTITUTIONS THESE HUGE
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS WENT TO
THE GOVERNMENT FOR A HAND OUT
FOR A BAIL OUT. AND THEY GOT IT.
WELL GUESS WHAT WE AS CONSUMERS
MIGHT NEED THAT BAIL OUT THIS
TIME. THESE INSTITUTIONS ARE
HEALTHY. THEY'RE HEALTHY AND WE
MIGHT NEED THEIR HELP AND WE
SIMPLY DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN IN THE NEXT FEW
MONTHS. SO VOTE TODAY IS KEEP
THIS CONVERSATION GOING. AND A
VOTE TODAY IT'S A TRICK
POTENTIALLY ALLOW FOR SOME
GUIDELINES IN THE FUTURE SO WE
CAN PROTECT CONSUMERS WHO CAN
HELP PEOPLE KEEP THEIR CART
CARS TO HELP PEOPLE KEEP THEIR
HOMES. AND THESE INSTITUTIONS
ARE NOT GOING TO LOSE ARE GOING
TO GET THEIR MONEY BACK THEY'RE
GOING TO GET IT A LITTLE BIT
LATER. I THINK THAT'S AN OKAY
COMPROMISE HERE. I HOPE YOU'LL
JOIN ME TODAY IN VOTING FOR
THIS BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR
OF. THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. MS LOW MOAN YOU
MAY CLOSE WE WISH. THANK YOU
MEMBERS I ASKED US ALL TO FAST
FORWARD ONE YEAR RIGHT CONNIE
CONTINUES TO STRUGGLE BECAUSE
EVERY TIME THE DISEASE FLARES
UP WE ARE REQUIRED TO IMPLEMENT
STRONG PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN
ORDERS. UNEMPLOYMENT REMAINS
STUBBORNLY HIGH FAR HIGHER THAN
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION. WE
MAY PERHAPS HIT PROJECTIONS
LIKE THE LA TIMES SAID OF
INCREASING OUR HOMELESS
POPULATION UP 2405% IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. HUNDREDS
OF YOUR CONSTITUENTS ARE
CALLING TO TELL YOU THAT THEY
HAVE RECEIVED A NOTICE OF
DEFAULT. AND THAT THEIR SERVICE
PLANS TO FOR CLOSURE ON THEIR
HOME. TO TELL YOU THAT THEIR
CAR WAS REPOSSESSED OR TO TELL
YOU THAT THEY HAVE FALLING
BEHIND ON OTHER DEBT. WHAT ARE
WE GOING TO SAY TO THEM. WILL
WE BE WILLING TO ADMIT THAT WE
PUT OUR FAITH THAT THINGS WERE
JUST GOING TO WORK OUT FOR THEM.
WILL WE BE WILLING TO ADMIT.
THAT WE WERE NOT WILLING TO
CONSIDER PROPOSALS TO HELP OUR
CONSTITUENTS STAY IN THEIR HOME
AND STABILIZER FINANCIAL
SITUATIONS. THIS BILL ENVISIONS
THE DIFFICULT TIMES THAT
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES ARE FACING
NOT ONLY THE CHALLENGES OF
TODAY BUT ALSO LOOKING MONTHS
DOWN THE ROAD. UNEMPLOYMENT
PAYMENTS ARE SET TO EXPIRE THIS
JULY WHAT HAPPENS IN AUGUST. IT
IS THE HOPE THAT THE ECONOMY
REBOUNDS WE ALL WISH THAT WE
ALL HOPE. AND THAT VERY FEW
FAMILIES WILL FACE THE
FINANCIAL HARDSHIPS THAT
REQUIRE THEM TO RELY ON THESE
PROTECTIONS PROVIDED BY THE
BILL. BUT WE NEED TO FACE THE
REAL POSSIBILITY THAT THE WORLD
MAY NOT WORK OUT THAT WAY. I AM
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO
WORKING ON THIS BILL WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS. THESE ARE NOT
EASY CONVERSATIONS THEY ARE NOT
EASY PROBLEMS THERE ARE NO EASY
PROBLEMS UNDER COVERT AND A
COLLAPSING ECONOMY. I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL SO
THAT THIS IMPORTANT DISCUSSION
CAN CONTINUE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. WITH THAT
PURPLE OF RURAL. FOLK. DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS ARE
RESERVE VOTE. YEAH. ALL MEMBER
SERVICE SAID ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS
THE RESERVE A.
HIS MOM WAS A
CALL.
HERE. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE BACK TO BUSINESS
ON THE DAILY FILE FILE ITEM
EIGHTY SB FOUR SEVENTEEN THE
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE BILL
FOUR SEVENTEEN BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO WHAT ACCOLADES THE
VICTIM COMPENSATION BOARD
MAKING APPROPRIATION OF FOUR
DECLARE YOUR TO SEE THEIR UP TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. DALLAS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN THIS
MATTER. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
SB FOUR SEVENTEEN WHAT
APPROPRIATE FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE GENERAL FUND
TO THE VICTIMS COMPENSATION
BOARD FOR CLAIMS- THE
INDIVIDUALS WITH THE RONI'S
CONVICTIONS ARE IMPRISONMENT.
THE SEVEN CLAIMS HAVE ALREADY
BEEN APPROVED PASSING A BILL
QUICKLY WILL AND THE HARDSHIP
TO THOSE CLAIMANTS. COLLEAGUES
IF YOU GET A CHANCE I KNOW
THESE ARE STANDARD BILLS THAT
WE PASS EVERY YEAR THERE THERE.
BY LAW WE HAVE TO PASS THEM. IT
MIGHT I SUGGEST IN THIS TIME
PERIOD THAT PEOPLE GO BACK AND
ACTUALLY READ THESE CASES AND
YOU'LL SEE. A GENTLEMAN WHO WAS
IMPRISONED FOR TWELVE YEARS
BECAUSE MISTAKEN. IDE ABOUT
ROBBING A BANK WHERE THE ONLY
PIECE OF EVIDENCE HIS PALM
PRINT. DIDN'T MATCHES YET
ALIBIS FROM EMPLOYERS FROM HIS
WIFE FROM HIS FAMILY IN STILL
SAT IN PRISON. FOR OVER A
DECADE BEFORE THEY FINALLY
FOUND HIM FACTUALLY INNOCENT
THESE ARE COMPELLING CASES I
THINK SOMETIMES IT'S IMPORTANT
TO REMIND OURSELVES THAT NOT
EVERYBODY ACCUSED OF CRIME OR
EVEN FOUND GUILTY OF A CRIME.
IS NECESSARILY TRUE GUILTY OF
THAT CRIME WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK MY VOTE. THANK
YOU MISS GONZALES SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE-
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO GO. I. WELL CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE I
SEVENTY ONE NEWS HERE ON THE
URGENCY EYES HAVE ANYONE KNOWS
HEROES THE MEASURE PASSES. FILE
ITEM. EIGHTY ONE SB SIX TWENTY
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL SIX TWENTY FIVE BY
SENATOR GRAHAM FOR ANOTHER'S AN
ACCOLADE WATER TO CLEAR THE
ABSENCE EITHER OTHER TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. THIS
CARILLO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THE MATTER. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SB SIX TWO
FIVE ADDRESSES THE CRISIS OF
GOVERNANCE IN THE CENTRAL BASIN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT IN
SOUTHEAST LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
CENTRAL BASIN AT THE WHOLESALE
WATER AGENCY OR MIDDLE MAN
SELLING IMPORTED WATER TO THE
PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS HOLE
ACTUALLY DELIVER WATER TO THE
TAP THE RESIDENTS. THE AGENCY
HAS BEEN OPERATING AT A DEFICIT
FOR MORE THAN A DECADE AND NOW
ITS BOARD OF DIRECTORS HAS ONCE
AGAIN FAILED TO PROVIDE
LEADERSHIP. IT IN A DAY AND CAN
ANYTHING TO RESOLVE THE CRISIS.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN EIGHT ORDER.
OUT THIS FAILURE OF LEADERSHIP
BY THE CENTRAL BASIN BOARD THE
NEXT YEAR AND TWENTY SIXTEEN
THE LEGISLATURE PASS REFORM
LEGISLATION. TO TAKE THE
AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATION AT
LEAST IN PART BY ADDING THREE
APPOINTED DIRECTORS
REPRESENTING THE DISTRICT'S
CUSTOMERS. THAT MEANT EIGHT
DIRECTORS REQUIRING FIVE VOTES
TO MOVE FORWARD. BUT NOW ALL
FOUR OF THOSE DIRECTORS HALF OF
THEM. HAVE CLAIMED TO TAKE
CONTROL OF THE AGENCY WITHOUT A
MAJORITY OF VOTES. THE LAW IS
NOT ALLOW HALF THE BOARD TO
LEAD THE AGENCY OUT OF CRISIS
IT TAKES FIVE VOTE. THIS AGENCY
IS STOCK AND A NEEDS OUR HELP
TO RESTART OR START THE
TRANSITION TOWARD STABILITY. SB
SIX FIVE. THE BASE INTO
RECEIVERSHIP FOR THE NEXT
EIGHTEEN MONTHS IT'S ONLY
EIGHTEEN MONTHS AT A PUBLIC
AGENCY WITH THE ELECTED BY MANY
OF THE SAME VOTERS. THAT PUBLIC
AGENCY IS THE WATER
REPLENISHMENT DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WOULD
REPLENISHES THE CENTRAL BASE
AND GROUNDWATER UP BEFORE AND
THE WEST BASIN AQUIFER. THE
BILL'S MOST IMPORTANT PART IS
KICKING OFF A BROADER COMMUNITY
DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW TO
STABILIZE AND GOVERN THE AGENCY
IN THE LONG TERM. IT REQUIRES
OUR LAST COUPLE MADE UP OF
OTHER PUBLIC AGENCIES TO LEAD
THE PUBLIC DISCUSSION. WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO COME BACK NEXT
YEAR TO HEAR LAUGH GOES
RECOMMENDATIONS AND DECIDE HOW
THE AGENCY SHOULD BE GOVERNED.
SB SIX TWO FIVE JUST GET THIS
STARTED IT PUTS A PAUSE ON THIS
FUNCTION AND START THE VERY
PUBLIC PROCESS TO FIGURE OUT
GOVERNANCE I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISS CARILLO SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. VERY VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED OF THE-
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE
IT. WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY TWO NEWS
ONE OF YOUR TO SEE AYE AYES
SIXTY TWO YOU KNOW WHO WON THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE
ITEM EIGHTY TWO SB THREE FIFTY
THE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
BILL THREE FIFTY BY SENATOR
HILL OF OTHERS AN ACCOLADE IN
INJURY. MR HOLDEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
LAST YEAR ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
FIFTY FOUR. THE LEGISLATURE
IMPOSE STRICT CONDITIONS ON PGA
ANY TO EXIT BANKRUPTCY AS A
TRANSFORM UTILITY. SB THREE
FIFTY HOLES PGA ANY ACCOUNTABLE
FOR MEETING THOSE REQUIREMENTS
AND PROVIDES OUR STATE. WITH A
FAIL SAFE IN CASE THE NEW PGA
ANY FAILS AND FALL SHORT OF
EXPECTATIONS. SB THREE FIFTY
AUTHORIZES THE CREATION OF A
NEW ENTITY GOLDEN STATE ENERGY.
A NON PROFIT PUBLIC BENEFIT
CORPORATION. WHICH WOULD STEP
IN AND TAKE OVER IF P. JEANNIE
FAILS TO EMERGE FROM BANKRUPTCY
OR IF P. JEANNIE FAILS TO
TRANSFORM AS REQUIRED BY
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN FIFTY FOUR.
SB THREE FIFTY IS A BILL I HOPE
WILL NEVER BE NEEDED. BECAUSE
IF SB THREE FIFTY IS TRIGGER IT
WOULD MEAN P. JEANNIE HAS
FAILED US AGAIN. I WILL GO INTO
A LONG DISCUSSION OF P. GENIES
FAILINGS. WE'VE ALL LIVE THEM.
FAR TOO MANY CALIFORNIANS FOR
FAR TOO MANY TIMES HAVE HAD TO
LIVE THEM. CALIFORNIA DESERVES
A REFORMED P. JEANNIE. HI HO
PGA NEVER STARTS ANOTHER
WILDFIRE BECAUSE OF ANOTHER
PIPELINE EXPLOSION. I HOPE. WE
ALL HOPE THAT P. JEANNIE
IMPROVES ITS SAFETY RECORD AND
IT'S ACCOUNTABILITY. WE ALL
HOPE P. GINNY FULFILLS ITS
COMMITMENT TO TRANSFORM ITSELF
INTO A SAFE RELIABLE.
AFFORDABLE AND RESILIENT
UTILITY. BUT OUR STATE CANNOT
RELY ON HOPE ALONE. SB THREE
FIFTY IS OUR CONTINGENCY PLAN.
SHOULD WE SHOULD THE NEED ARISE
SB THREE FIFTY ENSURES THAT OUR
STATE CAN TAKE STRONG AND SWIFT
ENFORCEMENT ACTION INCLUDING IF
NECESSARY THE CBC'S REVOCATION
OF P. GENIES LICENSED OPERATOR.
SB THREE FIFTY. AND I CANNOT
EMPHASIZE THIS ENOUGH. IS ALSO
CRITICAL FOR THE WHILE FIRE
VICTIMS. SHOULD BE EASY IN A
FAILED TO EXIT BANKRUPTCY THE
PATH LAID OUT IN SB THREE FIFTY
IS MOST EXT EXPEDITIOUS WAY TO
RESOLVE THE VICTIMS.
SETTLEMENTS AS THE ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT AND ACCEPTED
AMENDMENTS MAKE VERY CLEAR.
COLLEAGUES SB THREE FIFTY ISN'T
A BILL WE WANT. WHAT WE WANT IS
FOR P. JEANNIE TO BE A REFORM
UTILITY. BUT IT IS A BILL WE
NEED. TO PROTECT P. GENIES
REPAIRS AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I DRIVE VOTE ON SB
THREE FIFTY. THANK YOU MISTER
HOLDEN SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE- ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ON
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FORTY
NINERS FOURTEEN THE MEASURE
PASSES WILL PASS AND RETAIN A
PILOT IN SEVENTY EIGHT AND
SEVENTY NINE. MEMBERS WE CAN
ENTERTAIN VOTE CHANGES AT THIS
TIME IF ANYONE HAS A VOTE
CHANGE YOU MAY GO TO THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER OR RAISE YOUR
MAKING YOUR DESK. MR CHOI YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR OF
THE CHAMBER. CHOICE WILL CHANGE.
FROM I AM MORE MOBILE. ON THE
SP SO BEFORE. WELL CHANGE CHOI
SENATE BILL SEVENTY FOUR ODD TO
KNOW. CORRECTION CHOICE IN A
BILL SEVENTY FOUR I TO NOT
VOTING. MR MAIENSCHEIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR DESK THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB EIGHTY
FIVE NO TO NOT VOTING. IT'S.
MAIENSCHEIN STE ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTY FIVE NO TO NOT VOTING.
MR CHOI WOULD YOU LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE AGAIN YEAH THAT WAS A
MISTAKE IN NON ALMOST MONTH I
CHANGE MY VOTE AS BE SEVENTY
FOUR FROM AYE MORE NORMAL. CHOI
SENATE BILL SEVENTY FOUR I TO
KNOW.
THIS COME OVER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR CHAMBER.
THANK YOU MODE CHANGE AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY SIX FROM I'D TO
NOT VOTING. KAMLAGER ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SIX I
TO NOT VOTING.
MISS WICKS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED YOUR DESPERATE
CHANGE THANK YOU AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY SIX I DO NOT
VOTING. WICKS ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SIX I'D TO
NOT VOTING.
MEMBERS. MEMBERS I
WOULD ASK THE U. PLEASE KEEP
YOUR PHYSICAL DISTANCE AND KEEP
YOUR MASK ON WHILE YOU WERE IN
THE CHAMBER. MEMBERS PLEASE
RESPECT SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
PUT YOUR MASK BACK ON PLEASE
THANK YOU.
YEAH. MR MON IS
PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL ON AB
TWENTY FIVE OH ONE THE CLERK
WILL POST.
MISS LIMóN NOTICES
RECONSIDERATION CLOSER ALL YES
THANK YOU. CLOSE THE ROLE.
TALLY VOTES EYES TWENTY EIGHT
KNOWS TWENTY FIVE THIS MEASURE
FAILS MISLI MON NOTICES
RECONSIDERATION. NO. MAY I
THINK I. MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY
JUNE SIXTEENTH CHECK IN SESSION
WEDNESDAY JUNE SEVENTEENTH
CHECK IN SESSION THURSDAY JUNE
EIGHTEENTH WE RETURN TO FLOOR
SESSION AT NINE AM. FRIDAY JUNE
NINETEENTH THERE WILL BE FLOOR
SESSION UPON CALL OF THE
SPEAKER. ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED TO
RETAIN OUR MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MR GRAYSON MOVES A MISTER
FLORES SECOND THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY JUNE
EIGHTEENTH AT NINE AM FORM
COLLEGE LIFTED. AS IT TURNS.